ai and machine learning have become a
revolution in the 21st century
companies across the globe are using ai
and machine learning techniques to solve
business problems and increase growth
hi everyone welcome to this live session
on ai and machine learning full course
by simply learn in this session we will
cover all the important concepts
techniques and algorithms that you need
to know to become a successful ai or
machine learning engineer
our highly experienced trainers will
take you through this live session
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply learn channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
so we'll start off by learning the
basics of ai and machine learning from
short animated videos
then we will understand the different
supervised and unsupervised learning
algorithms such as linear regression
logistic regression decision trees svm
knn as well as k-means clustering
then we will sift our focus towards
learning deep learning where we will
look at what is deep learning and how
neural networks work
we will also cover two important deep
learning frameworks tensorflow and keras
finally we will understand about
generative adversarial network and
recurrent neural networks so let's get
started
picture this a machine that could
organize your cupboard just as you like
it or serve every member of the house a
customized cup of coffee makes your day
easier doesn't it these are the products
of artificial intelligence but why use
the term artificial intelligence well
these machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but ai may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact ai is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an ai do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the ai robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a crossroad
one that is paved and the other rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across using the plank provided as an
input the robot is able to cross this
stream so our robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this is problem solving these three
capabilities make the robot artificially
intelligent in short ai provides
machines with the capability to adapt
reason and provide solutions
well now that we know what ai is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
in ais classified into
weak ai also called narrow ai focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak ai you might
say alexa is definitely not a weak ai
since it can perform multiple tasks
well that's not really true when you ask
alexa to play despacito it picks up the
keywords play and despacito
and runs a program and is trained to
alexa cannot respond to a question it
isn't trained to answer for instance try
asking alexa the status of traffic from
work to home alexa cannot provide you
this information as she is not trained
to
and that brings us to our second
category of ai strong ai
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now
ultron from avengers is an ideal example
of a strong ai
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable
you must be wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning
we saw what ai is machine learning is a
technique to achieve ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning
machine learning provides a machine with
the capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms
deep learning does this learning through
ways inspired by the human brain this
means through deep learning data and
patterns can be better perceived
ray kurzweil a well-known futurist
predicts that by the year 2045 we would
have robots as smart as humans
this is called the point of singularity
well that's not all
in fact elon musk predicts that the
human mind and body will be enhanced by
ai implants which would make us partly
cyborgs since the human brain is still a
mystery it's no surprise that ai2 has a
lot of unventured domains
for now ai is built to work with humans
and make our tasks easier
however with the maturation of
technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of ai holds for us
well that is artificial intelligence for
you in short we know humans learn from
their past experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from the past data and
do what humans can do and much faster
well that's called machine learning but
it's a lot more than just learning it's
also about understanding and reasoning
so today we will learn about the basics
of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity and the gender of voice for
simplicity let's just use tempo and
intensity for now so here tempo is on
the x axis ranging from relaxed to fast
whereas intensity is on the y-axis
ranging from light to soaring we see
that paul likes the song with fast tempo
and soaring intensity while he dislikes
the song with relaxed tempo and light
intensity so now we know paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a song a has fast
tempo and a soaring intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song or not correct so paul likes this
song by looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily right let's say now
paul listens to a new song let's label
it as song b so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether paul likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it are the choices unclear
correct we could easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b yes and that's
where machine learning comes in let's
see how in the same example for song b
if you draw a circle around the song b
we see that there are four words for
like whereas one would for dislike if we
go for the majority votes we can say
that paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called k
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
the label when you feed this data to the
machine learning model it learns which
feature is associated with which label
for example it will learn that if a coin
is of three grams it will be a one rupee
coin let's give a new coin to the
machine on the basis of the weight of
the new coin your model will predict the
currency hence supervised learning uses
labeled data to train the model here the
machine knew the features of the object
and also the labels associated with
those features on this note let's move
to unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you'll clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored
higher runs and took less wickets while
the other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
a reward based learning or we can say
that it works on the principle of
feedback here let's say you provide the
system with an image of a dog and ask it
to identify it the system identifies it
as a cat so you give a negative feedback
to the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning moving on don't
you sometimes wonder how is machine
learning possible in today's era well
that's because today we have humongous
data available everybody is online
either making a transaction or just
surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing often where it
says the fear of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model which is used by global
taxi giant uber and others where they
have differential pricing in real time
based on demand the number of cars
available bad weather rush r etc so they
use the search pricing model to ensure
that those who need a cab can get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict where the demand will be high
with the goal that drivers can take care
of the demand and search pricing can be
minimized great hey siri can you remind
me to book a cab at 6 pm today ok i'll
remind you thanks no problem comment
below some interesting everyday examples
around you where machines are learning
and doing amazing jobs what is
artificial intelligence and today's
world is probably one of the most
exciting advancements that we're in the
middle of experiencing as humans so what
is artificial intelligence and here we
have a robot with nice little clampy
hands hey what am i you are what we call
artificial intelligence i am your
creator reminding him who programmed him
and who he's supposed to take care of
artificial intelligence is a branch of
computer science dedicated to creating
intelligent machines that work and react
like humans in today's place where we're
at with artificial intelligence i really
want to highlight the fact that they
work and react like humans because that
is where the development of artificial
intelligence is and that's what we're
comparing it to is how it looks like
next to a human thanks any tasks you
want me to do for you get me a cup of
coffee poof here you go he brings him a
cup of coffee that's my kind of robot i
love my coffee in the morning you'll see
there's kind of a side theme of coffee
today's uh tutorial so here we have a
robot that's able to bring him a cup of
coffee seems pretty far out there you
know that we have a walking robot that's
doing this but it's not as far out there
as you think we have automatic coffee
pots we have devices that can move an
object from one point to the other you
know anything from amazon delivering
packages or whatever you want all these
things are in today's world we're right
on the edge of all this that's what
makes this so exciting such an exciting
topic and a place of study so let's take
a look a real general look at types of
artificial intelligence in the really
big picture i mean we drill into it
there's like machine learning and all
kinds of different aspects but just a
generic level of artificial intelligence
so hi there discovered four different
types come have a look so we have our
kind of einstein looking guy or
professor at some college so the very
first part that we're really this is uh
as reactive machines they've been around
a long time this kind of ai are purely
reactive and do not hold the ability to
form memories or use past experiences to
make decisions these machines are
designed to do specific jobs remember i
talked about the programmable coffee
maker that makes coffee in the morning
it doesn't remember yesterday from
tomorrow it runs its program even going
back to our washing machines they have
automatic load balancers that have been
around for decades so reactive machines
we program to do certain tasks and they
have no memory but they're very
functional then we have limited memory
this is kind of right where we're at
right now this kind of ai uses past
experience and the present data to make
a decision self-driving cars are kind of
limited memory ai we bring up
self-driving cars because that's a big
thing especially in today's market they
have all these images that they brought
in and videos of what's gone on before
and they use that to teach the automatic
car what to do so it's based on a
limited memory limited memory means it's
not evolving new ideas they have to
actually when they need to make a change
they have the programming built on the
memory but then they have to make those
changes outside of that and then put the
new setup in there so it's continually
reprogramming itself theory of mind
these ai machines can socialize and
understand human emotions machines with
such abilities are yet to be developed
of course that's under debate there's a
lot of places that are working on the
theory of mind and having it be able to
cognitively understand somebody based on
the environment their
facial features all kinds of things and
evolve with them so their own they have
some kind of reflective ability to
evolve with that and finally
self-awareness this is the future of ai
these machines will be super intelligent
sentient and conscious so they'll be
able to react very much like a human
being although they'll have their own
flavor i'm sure achieving artificial
intelligence so how in today's world
right now are we going to achieve
artificial intelligence well the main
arena right now is machine learning
machine learning provides artificial
intelligence with the ability to learn
this is achieved by using algorithms to
discover patterns and generate insights
from the data they are exposed to and
here we have a computer as we get more
and more to the human realm of art and
official intelligence you see this guy
splits in two and he's inside his hidden
networks and machine learning programs
deep learning which is a subcategory of
machine learning deep learning provides
artificial intelligence the ability to
mimic a human brain's neural network it
can make sense of patterns noise and
sources of confusion in the data let's
try to segregate different kinds of
photos using deep learning so first we
have our pile of photographs much more
organized than my boxes in my closet of
photographs the machine goes through the
features of every photo to distinguish
them this is called feature extraction
bingo figures out the different features
in the photos and so based on those
different features labels of photos it
says these are landscapes these are
portraits these are others so it
separates them in there if you've ever
been on google photos a favorite of mine
i go through there and i type in dog and
i get all the images of my dog it's
pretty amazing how it's able to pull
those features out so when we're
achieving artificial intelligence and
the deep learning let's take a closer
look and see just how deep learning
works there are a lot of models out
there this is the most basic model used
this is a neural network there are three
main layers in a neural network the
photos that we want to segregate go into
the input layer and so we have a picture
of mona lisa it looks like in a couple
of people when it goes into the first
input layer the arrows are drawn to like
individual dots each one of those white
dots in the yellow layer or in the input
layer would be a pixel in the picture
maybe a value for that pixel so the
picture of the mountains goes in there
and it fills in that whole input layer
and then the next picture of the
nightscape goes in there the hidden
layers are responsible for all the
mathematical computations or feature
extraction on our inputs so when you see
here we have the two kind of oranges red
layers here and there's all these lines
in there those lines are the weights
each one of those represents a usually a
float number or a decimal number and
then it multiplies it by the value in
the input layer and you'll see that as
it adds all these up in the hidden layer
each one of those dots in the hidden
layer then has a value based on the sum
of the weights and then it takes those
and puts it into another hidden layer
and you might ask well why do we have
multiple hidden layers well the hidden
layers function as different
alternatives to some degree so the more
hidden layers you have the more complex
the data that goes in and what can they
can produce coming out the accuracy of
the predicted output generally depends
on the number of hidden layers we have
so there we go the accuracy is based on
how many hidden layers we have and again
it has to do with how complex the data
is going in the output layer gives us
the segregated photos so once it adds up
all these weights and you'll see there's
weights also going into the output layer
based on those weights it'll say yes
it's a portrait no it's a portrait yes
it's a landscape no it's a landscape and
that's how we get our setup in there so
now we were able to label our photos
let's take a look and see what that
looks like in another domain we have
photograph domain now let's look at it
in the airline ticket so let's predict
the airline ticket prices using machine
learning these are the factors based on
which we're going to make the
predictions and choosing your factors is
so important but for right here we'll
just go ahead and take a look what we
got we have airlines we have the origin
airport the destination airport the
departure date here are some historical
data of ticket prices to train the
machine so we pull in the old data this
is what's happened over the years now
that our machine is trained let's give
it new data for which it will predict
the prices and you remember from our
four different kinds of machines we have
machines with memory well this is the
memory part it remembers all the old
data and then it compares what you put
in to produce the new data to predict
the new prices the price is 1000 that's
an expensive flight of course
if that is a us dollars if it's india i
don't know what the price range is on
that hopefully it's a good deal for
wherever you're going so we predict the
prices and this is kind of nice because
if you're looking way ahead it'd be nice
to know if you're planning a trip for
next year
how much those tickets are going to cost
and they certainly fluctuate a lot so
let's take a look at the applications of
artificial intelligence we're going to
dive just a little deeper because we
talked about photos we've talked about
airline ticket prices kind of very
specific you get one specific number but
let's look at some more things that are
probably more in home more common right
now speaking of in home this young
gentleman is entering his room of course
makes a comment like we all do we walk
into a room this room is dark isn't it
let's see what happens when i enter it
the sensors in my room detect my
presence and switch on the lights this
is an example of non-memory machines
okay you know it senses you it doesn't
have a memory whether you've gone in or
not some of the new models start running
a prediction as to whether you're in the
room or not when you show up when you
don't so they turn things on before you
come down the stairs in the morning
especially if you're trying to save
energy you might have one of those fancy
thermostats which starts guessing when
you get up in the morning so it doesn't
start the heater until it knows you're
going to get up so here he comes in here
and this is one of the examples of uh
smart machine and that is one of the
many applications of artificial
intelligence one of the things we're
developing here in our homes okay bye
abruptly he leaves leaving his nice
steaming cup of coffee there on the
table and when he leaves the sensors
detect he's gone and turn off the lights
let's watch some tv did someone say tv
the sound sensors on the tv detect my
voice and turn on the tv sounds kind of
strange but with the google dongle and a
google home mini you can actually do
just that you can ask it to play a movie
downstairs on your downstairs tv true
also with the amazon fire stick and all
the different artificial intelligent
home appliances that are coming out
pretty amazing time to be alive and in
this industry here you have one more
application of artificial intelligence
and you can probably think of dozens of
others that are right now on the cutting
edge of development so let's jump into
my favorite part which is a use case
predict if a person has diabetes and in
the medical domain i mean if you read
any of these they say predictive
predictive person has diabetes but in
the medical domain we would want to
restate this as what is the risk is a
person a high risk of diabetes should
just be something on their radar to be
looking out for and we'll be helping out
with the use case there we are with a
cup of coffee again i forgot to shave as
you can see we'll start with the problem
statement the problem statement is to
predict if a person has diabetes or not
and we might start with this prediction
statement but if you were actually using
this in real case again you would say
your higher risk of diabetes would be
the proper way to present that to
somebody if you ran their test data
through here but that's very domain
specific which is outside of the problem
statement as far as the computer
programmers involved so we have a look
at the features these are the things
that have been recorded and they already
have this data from the hospitals one of
them would be number of times pregnant
obviously if you're a guy that would be
zero glucose concentration so these are
people who've had their glucose measured
blood pressure age age is a big factor
an easy thing to look at insulin level
so if someone's on insulin they probably
have diabetes otherwise they wouldn't be
taking insulin but that would affect
everything else and we add that in there
if they're if they're using insulin
let's start off with the code so we're
going to start off by importing parts of
our data set and if we're going to do
this let's jump into one of our favorite
tools we're going to use the anaconda
jupiter notebook so let me flip over
there and we'll talk just briefly about
that and then we'll look over this code
so here we are in the jupyter notebook
and
this is an inline editor which is just
really cool for messing with python on
the fly you can do demos in it it's very
visual you can add pieces of code it has
cells so you can run each cell
individually you can delete them but you
can tell the cell to be a comment so
that instead of running it it just skips
over it there's all kinds of cool things
you can do with jupiter notebook we're
not going to go into that we're actually
going to go with the tensorflow and you
do have to import all the different
modules in your python now if you're in
a different python ide that's fine it'll
work in just about any of your python
ides and i'll point out the one
difference in code when we get to that
which is the inline for doing our graph
and in this code we're going to go
through we're going to load our data up
we're going to explore it we're going to
label it and then we'll use the
tensorflow and then we'll get down to
the end where we're going to take a look
at how good the model is does it work so
let's start with the top part here and
let me go ahead and let's paste that
code in there i've added a line in at
the top i've added the folder because i
didn't put it in the same folder as the
program that's running you don't need to
worry too much about that but if you
have a folder issue or says file doesn't
exist you probably have it in the wrong
folder or you need to add the folder
path and then we're going to import
pandas and let me just one of the cool
things since it's in internet chrome we
can just do that control plus and zoom
right in there and we have the import
pandas as pd so go ahead and draw a line
of there you can see that the pandas as
pd add a little drawing thing in there
to make it easier to see pandas is a
data set it's a really nice package you
can add into your python usually it's
done as pandas as pd that's very common
to see the pd here let's circle that
it's basically like an excel spreadsheet
it adds columns it adds some headers it
has a lot of functionality to look at
your data and the first thing we're
going to do with that is we're going to
come down here and we're going to read
this is a csv it's a csv file you can
open up the file on your computer if you
want if you need access to the file you
can either search it and download it
from the main thing or type a note in
down below on the youtube video and
simply learn will help you get that file
also and that's true of any questions
you have on this you can add comments
down there and somebody at simplylearn
actually keeps an eye on that and we'll
try to answer those questions for you i
put in the full path you don't have to
if you have your data file saved in the
same folder you're running your program
in and this is just a csv file comma
separated variables and with the pandas
we can read it in there and we're going
to give it put it right in a variable
called diabetes and then finally we take
diabetes and you'll see diabetes.head
this is a pandas command and it's really
nice because it just displays the data
for us let me go ahead and erase that
and so we go up to the run button up
here in our jupiter notebook which runs
a script in this that's a cell we're in
and you can see with thediabetes.head
since it's a pandas data frame it prints
everything out nice and neat for us and
this is really great and if i go ahead
and do a control minus i can get it all
to fit on the same screen and this is
the first five lines when you do the
head of the data it just prints out the
first five lines in programming of
course we start with zero so we have
zero one two three and four there we go
we have yeah here we go we start with
zero we have zero one two three and four
we have our titles going across the top
and of course the first column is number
of pregnancies glucose concentration for
the second one blood pressure
measurements of triceps as we keep going
you'll see you can guess what most of
these things are group i'm not sure this
is probably the test group i didn't look
it up to see specifically what that is
anytime you start exploring data and for
this example we don't really need to get
too much in detail you want to know the
domain what does this information mean
are we duplicating information going in
but that's beyond the scope of this for
right now though we're just going to
look at this data and we're going to
take apart the different pieces of this
data so let's jump in there and take a
look at what the next set of code is so
in our next setup or our next step we
gotta start looking at cleaning the data
we gotta start looking at these
different columns and how are we gonna
bring them in which columns are what i'm
gonna jump ahead a little bit and also
as we look at the columns we're going to
do our import our tensorflow as tf
that's a common import that's our
tensorflow model tensorflow was
developed by google and then they put it
into open source so that it's free for
everybody to use which is always a nice
thing so let's take a look at what these
two steps look like in our jupiter
notebook so let's paste this code in
here and this is something that happens
when you're messing with data is you'll
repeat yourself numerous times we
already have diabetes head so i'm going
to put the little pound sign which tells
python that this is just going to be a
comment we're not going to run it a
second time in here we have diabetes dot
columns and then diabetes columns to
norm equals diabetes columns to
norm.apply lambda x let's talk about
that but let me first run that and let's
see that comes out with that and then
let's put the next set of code in also
and i'm going to run that let me just
hit the run button it doesn't really
have an output but we did a lot of stuff
here so let's go over what we did on
this so i've turned on my drawing
implement to help go through all this
there's a lot going on here the first
thing is we have all of our columns up
here all of our column names let me just
highlight that and draw a circle around
that like we did earlier and we want to
look at just specific columns and we're
going to start let me change the color
on this so it really sticks out i'll use
like a blue i'm going to look at these
columns and we're not going to do age
class or group we're going to look at
those in a different way and i'll
explain in a little bit what that's
about so we're looking at number of
pregnancies
glu basically anything that can be read
as a float number and you might say age
could be read as a float number we're
going to address that differently
because when you're doing statistics we
usually take the ages and we group them
into buckets and we'll talk about that
and so we're going to take these columns
and we're going to do what they call
normalize them call them to normalize
what is normalize if you're using the sk
learn module one of their neural
networks they call it scaling or scalar
this is in all of these neural networks
what happens is if i have two pieces of
data and let's say
one of them is in this case zero to six
and one of them is in insulin level is
zero to maybe point two would be a very
high level i don't know what they
actually go to a neural network will
look at this six and it'll go zero to
six and as you get into zero six here's
an eight even a higher number it will
weight those heavier and so it'll skew
the results based more on the number of
pregnancies than based on the insulin or
based on the blood pressure so we want
to level the playing field we want these
values to all be in the same area we do
that by normalizing it here and we use a
lambda function this is always a kind of
a fun thing we take the diabetes it's a
panda set up and let me just erase all
that so we can go down here put it back
to red and we take our diabetes which is
a panda data set and we only want to
look at the columns to normalize because
that's what we built we built a list of
those columns and we're going to apply
a lambda function and you'll see lambda
and all kinds of python programming it
just means it's a function we put x in
and whatever is outside of the x over
here it then takes that and returns that
value so
the new value is going to be whatever x
is minus x min again it's a pandas data
set so we can get by with that which is
really cool makes it easy to read so we
take x we look for the minimum value of
x and then we divide that by the maximum
value x minus the x min or the width and
what this essentially does is if you're
going from 0
to 15 it's going to divide by 15 and
then we subtract it let's make this 2
instead of 0 or 20 uh 20 to 115 there we
go first off we set this to 0 so we
subtract x min so right off the bat the
minimal value is going to be zero and
then we divide it by the difference here
x min minus x max or x max minus x min
this basically sets all the values
between zero to one and that's very
important if we want to make sure that
it's not going to be a skew in the
results if it's not going to weight the
values one direction or the other zero
to one that's what this is doing and
again there's like so many different
ways to scale our data this is the most
basic scale standard scaling and it's
the most common and we spelled it out in
the lambda you can there's actual um
modules that do that uh but lambda is
just it's such an easy thing to do and
you can see really see what we're doing
here so now we've taken these columns
we've scaled them all and changed them
to a zero to one value we now need to
let the program know the tensorflow
model that we're going to create we need
to let it know what these things are so
to do that i create a variable called
number pregnancy keep it simple and
we've imported the tensorflow as tf one
line of code brings our tensorflow in
for us awesome love python so you get
number of pregnancies and tf.feature
column.numeric column we can tell it's a
numeric column so it knows that this is
a float value zero to one and then
number underscore pregnant so we're
taking that column and we've reshaped
that column from zero to one and no that
doesn't mean you have a point one
pregnancy it just means zero point one
equals one or something number pregnant
so we're just mapping this data so
tensorflow knows what to do with it and
we go through all of these we go through
all the way up to again we're not doing
age let me just separate age down here
these have all been adjusted age we're
gonna handle differently we still put it
as a numerical column because it is so
let me just circle age and group we
didn't even touch group yet we're going
to look at group and h and we're going
to do some special stuff with that class
we're going to look at last why because
this is whether they have diabetes or
not that's what we're testing for so
this is our history we know these people
have diabetes or not and we want to find
out we want to create a model and then
we want to test that model predicting
whether somebody new has diabetes or not
so here i am still with my cup of coffee
working away refill number three let's
explore both the categorical group which
is going to be the a b c and d on the
end and also the age we're going to talk
about those a little bit more and then
we're going to combine all those
features and we'll jump into splitting
the data although that's kind of the
next step but we'll put that all
together what are we doing with the age
and what are we doing with the group
down there so let's flip on over and
take a look at our
jupiter notebook so the first thing is
let's put this new set of code in here
and run it and let's talk about what
we're doing on this set of code in um i
actually want to go one more step
forward on the next set of code or part
of it there we go and i can go and just
run that well we have it that's fine
let's just scroll up a little bit here
and let's go through what we just did
with this set of code if we go back up
here to the top part we have group b c b
b c we learned from the header so when i
come down here we're going to create a
signed group and let me get my drawing
pad out so we're looking at this first
one up here assigned group tf feature
column categorical column with
vocabulary list that is a mouthful this
is saying that this is a categorical
list in this case we have a b c d you
see this a lot in tensorflow a lot of
times tensorflow is used to analyze text
or logs error logs and they're just full
of all this information and they take
these in this case a b c d but in other
cases it'd be words and they create
numbers out of them so it has zero this
is one column this is another column
this is another column this is another
column and it's just this way of being
able to look at this in a different
light and assigning them different
values you really don't want to assign
this a float value first thought might
be let's assign this 0 to 3 0 1 2 3 for
a b c d but if you did that it would try
to add 1 plus 2 to get 3 as part of its
math and functions and that just isn't
true c does not equal a plus b c is just
a categorical name it could have been
the frank group and laura's group in a
bids group but it's not you know these
are they're not float numbers so very
important you have that distinction in
your data the next step we're looking at
is our map plot and we're going to do
this this is a cool useful tool we're
going to import map plot library dot pi
plot as plt that's standard import and
this next line here is really important
we're doing the matplot library we want
it to be inline that's because we're in
a jupyter notebook remember i told you
before that if you're running this in a
different ide you might get a different
result
this is the line you need if you want to
see the graph on this page and then we
do diabetes we're going to look at just
the age and dot hist bins equals 20.
what the heck is that well it turns out
that because this is remember it's a
pandas there's our pd pandas as pd
because this is a pandas panda
automatically knows to look for the
matplot library and a hist just means
it's going to be a histogram and we're
going to separate it into 20 bins and
that's what this graph is here so when i
take the diabetes and i do a histogram
of it it produces this really nice graph
we can see that at 22 most of the
participants in this probably around
174 of the people that were
recorded were of this age bracket
they're right here in this this first
column here and as they get further and
further down they have less and less and
less until when you're at 80 you can
actually see down here there's almost
none in a couple of these categories and
this is important to know because when
you're doing census you know the older
the the group is the more the people
have passed away so you're going to have
this in any of your senses as you take
you're always going to have a much
larger group in the younger crowd and
then it gets lower and lower as they get
older and i mentioned the word buckets
here we go we're going to create an age
bucket we're going to put people in
buckets can you imagine people sitting
in buckets kind of a funny way of
looking at it this just makes it easier
for us to separate it when i go to the
doctor's office i don't want to be told
well your age 22 this is you know you'll
get a decent one at 22.
here we are back to my cup of coffee i
told you coffee was an underlying theme
these next couple steps are very
specific to tensorflow up until now we
had some tensorflow as we set the
categories up but you'd have to set that
up with any model you use to make sure
they're set correctly they'd be set up a
little differently but we run input
functions and in tensorflow this allows
for some really cool things to happen
and this is why tensorflow is so
predominant in a lot of areas so let's
take a look at these next couple lines
of code here we're going to create the
input function and we're going to go
ahead and create the model and let me go
ahead and put these codes in here i went
ahead and split it up so it's different
lines so we can talk a little bit about
that and then the actual model and let
me go ahead and run this so we can see
what that looks like and in my
particular environment it just prints
out a little bit of information about
the model not too worried about looking
at that but we do want to take a closer
look at what we did here so we've
created an input function and again this
is very specific to tensorflow with the
input function we have our train we have
our x equals x train and our y equals y
train because we want to train it with a
particular information but we have these
other settings in here these two
settings and the number of epics is how
many times it's going to go over our
training model epic means large that
means all the data so we're going to go
over it a thousand times that's actually
a huge overkill for this amount of data
usually it only needs probably about 200
but you know when we're putting it
together and you're trying things out
you just kind of throw the numbers in
there and then you go back and fine-tune
it sometimes the batch size is really
important this is where tensorflow does
some really cool things if you're
processing this over a huge amount of
data and you try to batch everything at
once you end up with a problem this
means we're only going to read 10 lines
at a time through our data so each one
of those rows of testing they've done
we're only going to look at 10 of them
at a time and put that through our model
and train it and then shuffle
self-explanatory we're just moving we're
just randomly selecting which data and
what order we go in that way if there's
like you know five in a row that are
kind of weighted one way and vice versa
it mixes them up and then finally we
create our model so the model goes in
there and goes okay i have a
tf.estimator.linearclassifier
we're going to put in the feature
columns equals feature columns we
defined all our columns up above and
then we have in classes equal two and
that just means we have our out result
is zero or one you have diabetes or you
don't have diabetes or in this case we
actually call it high risk of diabetes
and then i put one more line of code in
there which i forgot we've set up our
model we set up our feature columns now
we need to actually train it
model.train you'll see this
so common in so many different neural
network models this is like a standard
what's different though is we have to
feed it the function remember we created
this function with all this information
on it and then we have steps in uh steps
similar to number of batches and batch
size it's more like a individual lines
we step through a thousand is a lot more
common for steps than epics but steps is
used you probably leave this out in this
particular example and let's go ahead
and run this all together because it has
a site when we start training it we get
a different output so here we go i've
run it it's given me the information
from when i created the model and now it
just starts going through and we get
this information tensor loss equals
global step all kinds of stuff going on
here and if you're following this it's
just going through the steps and
training it it gives you information you
could dig deep into here but for this
particular setup we're not going to go
too deep on what's going on just know
that we've trained our model this model
now has the information we need in it to
start running predictions so as we sip
our next um take our next step of coffee
or maybe it's tea or
if you're one of those strange late
night workers maybe it's a sip of wine
we go into the next step and we actually
want to run some predictions on here but
we don't want to run the training we
want to run the test on there we want to
take our test data and see what it did
and so that's what we're going to do
next is we're going to run the test
through and actually get some answers so
if you were actually deploying it you
would pull the answers out of the data
it's bringing back let's take a look at
that in our jupyter notebook so here we
go let's paste it in there i'm going to
go ahead and run it and you'll see that
as it goes it's actually putting the
answers out if you remember correctly
well we'll walk through this here in
just a second but it goes through and it
runs each line and it gives you a
prediction for each line one at a time
and prints them out so let's take a look
and see what that actually looks like
let's start with this first part we've
created another function this is just
like the other function except for
x equals x test and there's no y why is
there no why because we don't know what
the answer is on this yet we don't want
to tell it the answer we wanted to guess
what the answer is so we can evaluate
that and see how good it did on that 33
percent of the data so this is our x
test batch size is 10 again so if we
were watching this roll down here we
would see that it actually processes it
10 lines at a time it's only going to go
through once it goes through all the x
test data one time we don't need to have
it predict multiple times and shuffle
equals false
very important we set the shuffle to
false because if we were tracking this
and actually giving people answers we'd
want to make sure it connects to the
right person so they get the right
results of course we're just doing this
to evaluate it so let's take a look down
here what a put out and as i scroll down
to my jupiter notebook we have some
information as far as a tensorflow
running and then the actual output and
if we look at the output we know by this
first bracket in python it's an array we
know um by this squiggly bracket
that this is a dictionary so that this
is a label the dictionary has logistic
probabilities class ids classes and so
this whole first part let me redo that
this whole first part is one
output and we know that because there is
the bracket there and there is this
bracket here for the dictionary and it's
a dictionary of terms so if i pulled
this out i looked at object 0 in here i
would go down to and let me just find it
here it is classes remember how we
define classes we define classes as our
answer and so it's guessing our
tensorflow says based on all the
information you gave me i'm guessing
this first entry of our first test data
is high risk diabetes uh oh go get
tested change your diet watch what
you're eating you know high risk one and
if we go down far enough we can see down
here is another one where classes equal
zero i skipped a couple because they're
all ones up here the b
this particular output b
in front of the one means it's a binary
output it only comes out as zero or one
and there's a lot of other information
in here you can dig deep into tensorflow
and explain these different numbers
that's way beyond the scope of what
we're working on today so the basics of
it though is you get an output and we
have an output of whether the person has
diabetes or not well in this case it's
high risk of diabetes or not so now that
we've run our predictions take a sip of
coffee a little short break and we say
well what do we need to do well we need
to know how good was our predictions we
need to evaluate our model so if you're
going to publish this to a company or
something like that they want to know
how good you did let's take a look at
what that looks like in the code so
let's paste that in here and
just real quick go back over this by now
this function should look very uh this
is we're going to call it eval input
function it should be pretty
straightforward here we have our tf
estimator inputs pandas input function
and then we have our x test our y test
because we this time we want to give it
the answer so it has something to see
how good it did on batch is 10
processing 10 at a time we're only going
once through the data we're not
shuffling it although it doesn't really
matter with this and then we're going to
do results equals
model.evaluate and we put our evaluation
function in there this should all look
familiar because we're repeating the
same thing it's very similar with a
couple different changes as far as what
we're feeding it and the fact that we're
doing an evaluation let's see what that
looks like when we run it and we go up
here to our run model you'll see
warnings on some of these because i
didn't install this on its own install
so a lot of it is temporary files
because i'm using the jupyter notebook
instead of setting it up on a regular
machine and we get our output and we'll
go ahead and just look at this output
real quick and then we'll flip over and
from here you'll see that it generates
an accuracy a baseline average loss the
mean gives you a precision prediction it
gives you all kinds of information on
here so let's flip over and see what's
important and we'll look at the slide
here we are in this slide and this
should be exciting because we just about
wrapped up our whole tensor flow and
tensorflow is one of the more
complicated models out there so give
yourself a pat on the back for getting
all the way through this when we look at
this output we have an accuracy of
0.7165
that's really what we want to look at
that means that we have an accuracy if
you're just truncating it of 71 percent
that's quite good for our model you know
given a small amount of data we came up
with a 71 percent of letting people know
they're high risk or not with diabetes
so we created a model that can predict
if a person has diabetes based on some
previous records of people who were
diagnosed with diabetes and we've
managed to have an accuracy of 71
percent which is quite good the model
was implemented on python using
tensorflow again pat yourself on the
back because tensorflow is one of the
more complicated scripts out there it's
also one of the more diverse and useful
ones let's look at another example of
machine learning based on the amount of
rainfall how much would be the crop
yield so we here we have our crops we
have our rainfall and we want to know
how much we're going to get from our
crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary height where categorical
would be a description the color a dog's
breed gender categoricals limited to
very specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why we multiple linear
regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance i'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and x being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever x is
m in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y 2
minus y 1 and x 2 minus x 1. and finally
we have c which is the coefficient of
the line or where it happens to cross
the zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math that
you're going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the xy points and create
all the information you need so in the
top half you can see where we've broken
that down into pieces and as it goes
through the first two points it computes
the squared value of x the squared value
of y and x times y and then it takes all
of x and adds them up all of y adds them
up all of x squared adds them up and so
on and so on and you can see we have the
sum of equal to 15 the sum is equal to
20 all the way up to x times y where the
sum equals 66. this all comes from our
formula for calculating a straight line
where y equals the slope times x plus
the coefficient c so we go down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum of x times
y which we computed one line at a time
there and that's just the 66 and take
all that and you subtract it from the
sum of x times the sum of y and those
have both been computed so you have 15
times 20. and on the bottom we have the
number of lines times the sum of x
squared easily computed as 86 for the
sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values and we're going to go ahead and
plot them we're going to predict them so
y equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see why what we actual
values were and you can see why predict
it you can easily see where we take y
minus y predicted and we get an answer
what is the difference between those two
and if we square that y minus y
prediction squared we can then sum those
squared values that's where we get the
0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the way
down until we have a summation equals
2.4 so the sum of squared errors for
this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have well we'll start with
the simple linear regression where we
had y equals m plus x plus c and we're
trying to find the value of y now with
multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just x we have x1 x2 x3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
m1 times x1 plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it it's such
a visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber signed map plot
library inline that is only because i'm
doing an inline ide my interface in the
anaconda jupiter notebook requires i put
that in there or you're not going to see
the graph when it comes up let's go
ahead and run this it's not going to be
that interesting so we're just setting
up variables in fact it's not going to
do anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies dot csv you're
going to have to change this to fit
whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that i have companies equals
pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the i location
and because this is companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is or we have a colon minus
one and we want the values set into
there so x is no longer a data set a
pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carries
return i don't know about you but i'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of 136
thousand eight hundred ninety seven
dollars and eighty cents so on so on it
helps to create the profit of a hundred
ninety two thousand hundred 261 and 83
cents that makes no sense to me
whatsoever no pun intended so let's flip
back here and take a look at our next
set of code where we're going to graph
it so we can get a better understanding
of our data and what it means so at this
point we're going to use a single line
of code to get a lot of information so
we can see where we're going with this
let's go ahead and paste that into our
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization and again
we're using sns which is pandas as you
can see we imported the map plot library
dot pi plot as plt which then the
seaborn uses and we imported the seaborn
as sns and then that final line of code
helps us show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file in other means and that's the matte
plot library in line with the amber sign
at the beginning so here we come down to
the single line of code seaborn is great
because it actually recognizes the panda
data frame so i can just take the
companies dot core for coordinates and i
can put that right into the seaborn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one uh we have the columns and
the rows we have r and d spending we
have administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r and d spending is
going to be the same as rnd spending and
the same thing with administration costs
so right down the middle you get this
dark row or dark um diagonal row that
shows that this is the highest
corresponding data that's exactly the
same and as it becomes lighter there's
less connections between the data so we
can see with profit obviously profit is
the same as profit and next it has a
very high correlation with r d spending
which we looked at earlier and it has a
slightly less connection to marketing
spending and even less to how much money
we put into the administration so now
that we have a nice look at the data
let's go ahead and dig in and create
some actual useful linear regression
models so that we can predict values and
have a better profit now that we've
taken a look at the visualization of
this data we're going to move on to the
next step instead of just having a
pretty picture we need to generate some
hard data some hard values so let's see
what that looks like we're going to set
up our linear regression model in two
steps the first one is we need to
prepare some of our data so it fits
correctly and let's go ahead and paste
this code into our jupyter notebook and
what we're bringing in is we're going to
bring in the sklearn pre-processing
where we're going to import the label
encoder and the one hot encoder to use
the label encoder we're going to create
a variable called label encoder and set
it equal to capital l label capital e
encoder this creates a class that we can
reuse for transferring the labels back
and forth now about now you should ask
what labels are we talking about let's
go take a look at the data we processed
before and see what i'm talking about
here if you remember when we did the
companies dot head and we printed the
top five rows of data we have our
columns going across we have column 0
which is r and d spending column 1 which
is administration
column 2 which is marketing spending and
column 3 is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or a one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
is just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look at what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if i go ahead
and just do row 0 you'll see i have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why
because the computer has automatically
transformed our header into the setup
and it's automatically transferred all
these different variables so when we did
the encoder the encoder created two
columns and what we need to do is just
have the one because it has both the
variable and the name that's what this
piece of code does here let's go ahead
and paste this in here and we have x
equals x colon comma one colon all this
is doing is removing that one extra
column we put in there when we did our
one hot encoder and our label encoding
let's go ahead and run that and now we
get to create our linear regression
model and let's see what that looks like
here and we're going to do that in two
steps the first step is going to be in
splitting the data now whenever we
create a predictive model of data we
always want to split it up so we have a
training set and we have a testing set
that's very important otherwise we'd be
very unethical without testing it to see
how good our fit is and then we'll go
ahead and create our multiple linear
regression model and train it and set it
up let's go ahead and paste this next
piece of code in here and i'll go ahead
and shrink it down a size or two so it
all fits on one line so from the sklearn
module selection we're going to import
train test split and you'll see that
we've created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models
you usually see that a capital x and you
see the train and the test and the
lowercase y what this is is x is our
data going in that's our rnd span our
administration our marketing and then y
which we're training is the answer
that's the profit because we want to
know the profit of an unknown entity so
that's what we're going to shoot for in
this tutorial the next part train test
split we take x and we take y we've
already created those x has the columns
with the data in it and y has a column
with profit in it and then we're going
to set the test size equals point two
that basically means twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're gonna put them off to
the side so since we're using a thousand
lines of data that means that 200 of
those lines we're going to hold off to
the side to test for later and then the
random state equals zero we're going to
randomize which ones it picks to hold
off to the side we'll go ahead and run
this it's not overly exciting so it's
setting up our variables but the next
step is the next step we actually create
our linear regression model now that we
got to the linear regression model we
get that next piece of the puzzle let's
go ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn
linear underscore model we're going to
import linear regression now i don't
know if you recall from earlier when we
were doing all the math let's go ahead
and flip back there and take a look at
that do you remember this where we had
this long formula on the bottom and we
were doing all this summarization and
then we also looked at setting it up
with the different lines and then we
also looked all the way down to multiple
linear regression where we're adding all
those formulas together all of that is
wrapped up in this one section so what's
going on here is i'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor dot fit in this case we do
x train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict x test going in and this gives
us y predict now because i'm in jupiter
inline i can just put the variable up
there and when i hit the run button it
will print that array out i could have
just as easily done print
why predict so if you're in a different
ide that's not an inline setup like the
jupyter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side it's going to produce
200 answers this is what it says the
profit are for those 200 predictions but
let's don't stop there let's keep going
and take a couple look we're going to
take just a short detail here and
calculating the coefficients and the
intercepts this gives us a quick flash
at what's going on behind the line we're
going to take a short detour here and
we're going to be calculating the
coefficient and intercepts so you can
see what those look like what's really
nice about our regressor we created is
it already has a coefficients for us we
can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient underscore when i run this
you'll see our coefficients here and if
we can do the regressor coefficient we
can also do the regressor intercept and
let's run that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into where it's coming from you can see
the formula down here where y equals m1
times x1 plus m2 times x2 and so on and
so on plus c the coefficient so these
variables fit right into this formula y
equals slope 1 times column one variable
plus slope two times column two variable
all the way to the m into the n and x to
the n plus c the coefficient or in this
case you have minus eight point eight
nine to the power of two et cetera et
cetera times the first column and the
second column and the third column and
then our intercept is the minus 1 0 3 0
0 9 point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now i told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning i said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look what that looks like
in code and so we're going to use this
from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the r2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 percent correct but
you do want that in the upper 90s oh and
higher shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression what is a
decision tree let's go through a very
simple example before we dig in deep
decision tree is a tree shaped diagram
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision or current or reaction
let's start with a simple question how
to identify a random vegetable from a
shopping bag so we have this group of
vegetables in here and we can start off
by asking a simple question is it red
and if it's not then it's going to be
the purple fruit to the left probably an
eggplant if it's true it's going to be
one of the red fruits is the diameter
greater than 2 if false is going to be a
what looks to be a red chili and if it's
true it's going to be a bell pepper from
the capsicum family so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression when we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
in the different parts we're going to be
using we'll start with entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of uh
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went to
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node leaf node carries the
classification or the decision so it's
the final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root node the topmost decision node is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals all get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with a gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base two of
the same the percentage of that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case it's yellow fence two over
eight two elephants over a total of
eight times log base two two over eight
plus one monkey over total of eight log
base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers log base two
over eight and if we plug that into our
computer or calculator i obviously can't
do logs in my head we get an entropy
equal to 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we'll
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human is probably pretty
easy to split it let's see if you're
right if you guessed the color yellow
you're correct let's say the condition
that gives us the maximum gain is yellow
so we will split the data based on the
color yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has de decreased
considerably however we still need some
splitting of both the branches to attain
an entropy value equal to zero so we
decided to split both the nodes using
height as the condition since every
branch now contains single label type we
can say that entropy in this case has
reached the least value and here you see
we have the giraffes the tigers the
monkey and the elephants all separated
into their own groups this tree can now
predict all the classes of animals
present in the dataset with a hundred
percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for his bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupiter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with very complicated machine
learning tools you almost always see the
numpy come in for your num your number
it's called number python it has your
mathematics in there in this case we
actually could take it out but generally
you'll need it for most of your
different things you work with and then
we're going to use pandas as pd that's
also a standard the pandas is a data
frame setup and you can liken this to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn import tree and that's just
the basic tree function is needed for
the decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're gonna get a warning let's see what
that looks like so the first thing we
had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this is very lengthy setup on here where
i stored the
data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head this is one of
the nice things when we did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
our print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and we run that
let's just take a closer look at that
let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas do such a wonderful job of making
this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you wanna start with
the zero position and that is what the
data head does it pulls the first five
rows of data puts in a nice format that
you can look at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet or open office cal or trying
to look at a
word doc where it's all scrunched
together and hard to read you can now
get a nice open view of what you're
working with we're working with a shape
of a thousand long five wide so we have
five columns and we do the full data
head you can actually see what this data
looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to
train and build our data tree and to do
that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines in the database so it's all the
data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no and that's whether the
loan went default or not so we want to
start with one if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so it's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropy called decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play with in
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three now the max depth
if you remember above when we were doing
the different graphs of animals means
it's only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves is five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits i'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have to
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use and
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our sample is
how good of our tree does at predicting
the loan payments and finally since
anaconda jupiter notebook works as a
command line for python we can simply
put the y predict e n to print it i
could just as easily have put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported um
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
did we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit's going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not let us dig deep into the
theory of exactly how it works
and let's look at what is a random
forest random forest or random decision
forest is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as the final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switched from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well it goes hmm
orange or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes those decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set 1 and a data set 2 we just
split it in 2 and if you look at these
new
data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one whatever comes in
there it's going to sort that data and
it's going to say okay if this data goes
this direction it's probably an apple
and if it goes into the other direction
it's probably a lemon so that brings us
up to information gain it is the measure
of decrease in the entropy after the
data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals uh decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
uh definitions we'll look at the leaf
node and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision
we should have a name for the nodes
above it and they call those decision
nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this bowl was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
three three one three three one and we
have a label apple lemon grapes apple
lemon grapes and how do we split the
data we have to frame the conditions to
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty high
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left for this branch so no further
splitting is required for this node
however this node on the right it still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if i split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color
is yellow it's going to go to the right
bowl and if it's false it's going to go
to the left bowl so the entropy in this
case is now zero so now we have three
bowls with zero entropy there's only one
type of data in each one of those bowls
so we can predict a lemon with a hundred
percent accuracy and we can predict the
apple also with 100 accuracy along with
our grapes up there so we've looked at
kind of a basic tree
in our forest but what we really want to
know is how does a random forest work as
a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this
just like we did in the example this
tree looks at the diameter if it's
greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter this one when
they created it if you look at that
first bowl it has a lot of red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right and then it looks
at the shape false or true and so on and
so on and tree three is the diameter
equal to one and it came up with this
because there's a lot of cherries in
this bowl so that would be the biggest
split on there is is the diameter equal
to one that's going to drop the entropy
the quickest and as you can see it
splits it into true if it goes false and
they've added another category does it
grow in the summer and if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees you can see them
all in one image so this would be three
completely different trees categorizing
a fruit and let's take a fruit now let's
try this and this fruit if you look at
it we've blackened it out you can't see
the color on it so it's missing data
remember one of the things we talked
about earlier is that a random forest
works really good if you're missing data
if you're missing pieces so this fruit
has an image but maybe the person had a
black and white camera when they took
the picture and we're going to take a
look at this and it's going to have they
put the color in there so ignore the
color down there but the diameter equals
3 we find out it grows in the summer
equals yes and the shape is a circle and
if you go to the right you can look at
what one of the decision trees did this
is the third one
is the diameter greater than equal to
three is the color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value it'd say true and
it go to the right tree two classifies
it as cherries is the color equal red
is the shape a circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess that if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry uh
when you add that all together the
majority of the vote says orange so the
answer is it's classified as an orange
even though we didn't know the color and
we're missing data on it i don't know
about you but i'm getting tired of fruit
so let's switch and i did promise you
we'd start looking at a case example and
get into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupyter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sk learn module so
sklearn dot ensemble import random
fourth classifier and then we want to
bring in two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the other modules that we
bring in and one is going to be pandas
we're going to import pandas as pd pd is
a common term used for pandas and pandas
is basically creates a data format for
us
where when you create a pandas data
frame it looks like an excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful because it plays nice
with all the other modules in there and
then we have numpy which is our numbers
python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our np and we're going to
go ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupiter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the imports
and i'm going to paste the code down
here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at the bigger picture and i'm going
to go print i'm just going to change
this for a moment and we're going to
print all of iris and see what that
looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label and this
label pulls up whatever information
comes after it so feature names which we
actually used over here under columns is
equal to an array of sepal length sepal
width petal length petal width these are
the different names they have for the
four different columns and if you scroll
down far enough you'll also see data
down here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head it will print the
first five lines of the data set in
there along with the headers if you have
it in this case we have the column
header set to iris features and in here
you'll see that we have 0 1 2 3 4 in
python most arrays always start at zero
so when you look at the first five it's
going to be zero one two three four not
one two three four five so now we've got
our iris data imported into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code
we're going to take a look at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupyter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here and
before i run it
i want to look at a couple things going
on so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target
now these are both in the pandas setup
on here so in pandas we can do either
one i could have just as easily done
iris and then in brackets target
depending on what i'm working on both
are acceptable
let's go ahead and run this code and see
how this changes and what we've done is
we've added the target from the iris
data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're gonna add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you where you where
that's different where you can alter
that and do it slightly differently but
let's go ahead and put this into our
script up to that now and here we go
we're going to put that down here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1. and we're going to do
it for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved and we're
going to use that to train it and then
the other 25 we're going to hold off to
the side and use that to test it later
on so let's flip back on over and see
what the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 percent and train
25 percent in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sipa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupyter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features and the shorthand is you just
put features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupyter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and veracolor
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there looks at the
fact that there's only three of them so
when i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
uh we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
0 is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is a
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set
let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y this does the same thing it treats
this as a variable and prints it out but
if you're actually running your code
that wouldn't be the case and what is
printed out is it shows us all the
different variables we can change and if
we go down here you can actually see in
jobs equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features is auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the endnotes
remember we have the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is limiting the process and
making sure we don't overwhelm a system
and there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false warm start
is if you're programming it one piece at
a time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit our train our features and our
target y so now we have our training
model
what's next if we're going to create a
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here so you can
see what features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2 and we're going to
put those in and we're going to predict
what our
new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts zero zero zero one two one one
two two two and and uh again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing predict and we've
added underscore proba for probability
so there's our
clf.predict probability so we're running
it just like we ran it up here but this
time with this we're going to get a
slightly different result and we're only
going to look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a one for setosa it predicts
a zero for virginica and it predicts a
zero for versa color and so on and so on
and so on and let's um you know what i'm
going to change this just a little bit
let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote
and we have two equal votes it's going
to go with the first one so it says uh
setosa gets zero votes virginica gets
point five votes versus color gets point
five votes but let's just go with the
virginica since these two are equal and
so on and so on down the list you can
see how they vary on here so now we've
looked at both how to do a basic predict
of the features and we've looked at the
predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to it a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we'll go
ahead and run it again clf dot predict
test features remember that returns the
zeros the ones and the twos and then
we're going to set that equal to
predictions so this time we're actually
putting it in a variable
and when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and i went ahead and
did uh predictions through 25 let's just
do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test
model and then we come down here we look
at test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says setosa satoshi satosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what are forest is
doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm gonna because i'm on the
jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're gonna create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas and
we're doing a cross tab this function
takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versa color this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
accurate so we have a 93 accuracy with
our model i did want to add one more
quick thing in here on our scripting
before we wrap it up so let's flip back
on over to my script in here we're going
to take this line of code from up above
i don't know if you remember it but
predicts equals the iris dot target
underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
let's take a detour and see if we can
connect us to the human experience and
find out why support vector machine so
in this example last week my son and i
visited a fruit shop dad is that an
apple or a strawberry so the question
comes up what fruit do they just pick up
from the fruit stand after a couple of
seconds you could figure out that it was
a strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and already labeled as such
we already have a bunch of apples we
know our apples and are labeled as such
then once we train our model that model
then can be given the new data and the
new data is this image in this case you
can see a question mark on it and it
comes through and goes it's a strawberry
in this case we're using the support
vector machine model svm is a supervised
learning method that looks at data and
sorts it into one of two categories and
in this case we're sorting the
strawberry into the strawberry site at
this point you should be asking the
question how does the prediction work
before we dig into an example with
numbers let's apply this to our fruit
scenario we have our support vector
machine we've taken it and we've taken
labeled sample of data strawberries and
apples and we draw on a line down the
middle between the two groups this split
now allows us to take new data in this
case an apple and a strawberry and place
them in the appropriate group based on
which side of the line they fall in and
that way we can predict the unknown as
colorful and tasty as the fruit example
is let's take a look at another example
with some numbers involved and we can
take a closer look at how the math works
in this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set a female where
you have their height and weight 174 65
174 88 and so on and we'll need a sample
data set of the male they have a height
179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's go
ahead and put this on a graph so we have
a nice visual so you can see here we
have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw on two lines through the data in
the middle that separates them in from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls vm so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1d view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1d input and
transfer it to a two-dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1d when transferred to a 2-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an svm for this type of data set
here you can see we have a two
dimensional data set where the data is
in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and document so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the regulation
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be overfitted to a
very specific instance or it's going to
be biased to a high or low value with
the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms these three
advantages of the support vector machine
make it a very powerful tool to add to
your repertoire of machine learning
tools now we did promise you a used case
study we're actually going to dive in to
some python programming and so we're
going to go into a problem statement and
start off with the zoo so in the zoo
example we have family members going to
the zoo when we have the young child
going dead is that a group of crocodiles
or alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father is sitting here
thinking how can i turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support vector machine segregate the two
groups i don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements and data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
gonna find that there's only two lines
of code that actually create it and the
rest of it is done so quick and fast
that it's all here in the first page and
we'll show you what that looks like as
far as our data cause we're gonna create
some data i talked about creating data
just a minute ago and so we'll get into
the creating data here and you'll see
this nice correction of our two blobs
and we'll go through that in just a
second and then the second part is we're
going to take this and we're going to
bump it up a notch we're going to show
you what it looks like behind the scenes
but let's start with actually creating
our setup i like to use the anaconda
jupiter notebook because it's very easy
to use but you can use any of your
favorite python editors or setups and go
in there but let's go ahead and switch
over there and see what that looks like
so here we are in the anaconda python
notebook or anaconda jupiter notebook
with python we're using python 3. i
believe this is 3.5 but it should be
work in any of your 3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go and put our
code in there and one of the things i
like about the jupiter notebook is i go
up to view and i'm going to go ahead and
toggle the line numbers on to make it a
little bit easier to talk about and we
can even increase the size because this
is edited in this case i'm using google
chrome explorer and that's how it opens
up for the editor although anyone any
like i said any editor will work now the
first step is going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as np and matplot library dot pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python we need that
because part of the platform we're using
uses that for the numpy array and i'll
talk about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus the standard python array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np for numpy the map plot library
is how we're going to view our data so
this has uh you do need the np for the
sklearn module but the map plot library
is purely for our use for visualization
and so you really don't need that for
the svm but we're going to put it there
so you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're going to i'm going to
jump one ahead to line number four
that's the sklearn.datasets.com
import and make blobs and i told you
that we were going to make up data and
this is a tool that's in the sk learning
to makeup data i personally don't want
to go to the zoo get in trouble for
jumping over the fence and probably get
eaten by the crocodiles or alligators as
i work on measuring their snouts and
width and length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your your setup and you're not sure
about what data you're going to put in
there you can create this blob and it
makes it real easy to use and finally we
have our actual svm the sklearn import
svm on line three so that covers all our
imports we're going to create remember i
use the make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital x and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40. so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random state equals 20.
so which each each group is going to
have 20 different pieces of data in it
and the way that looks is that we'll
have under x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x and y will be 0 1 that's the two
different centers so we have yes or no
in this case alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual sk learner the
svm is in two lines of code and we see
it right here with clf equals svm dot
svc kernel equals linear and i set sql
to 1 although in this example since we
are not regularizing the data because we
want to be very clear and easy to see i
went ahead you can set it to a thousand
a lot of times when you're not doing
that but for this thing linear because
it's a very simple linear example we
only have the two dimensions and it'll
be a nice linear hyperplane will be a
nice linear line instead of a full plane
so we're not dealing with a huge amount
of data and then all we have to do is do
clf dot fit x comma y and that's it clf
has been created and then we're going to
go ahead and display it and i'm going to
talk about this display here in just a
second but let me go ahead and run this
code and this is what we've done is
we've created two blobs you'll see the
blue on the side and then kind of an
orangish
on the other side that's our two sets of
data they represent one represents
crocodiles and one represents alligators
and then we have our measurements in
this case we have like the width and
length of the snout and i did say i was
going to come up here and talk just a
little bit about our plot and you'll see
plt that's what we imported we're going
to do a scatter plot that means we're
just putting dots on there and then look
at this notation i have the capital x
and then in brackets i have a colon
comma 0. that's from numpy if you did
that in a regular array you'll get an
error in a python array you have to have
that in a numpy array it turns out that
our make blobs returns a numpy array and
this notation is great because what it
means is the first part is the colon
means we're going to do all the rows
that's all the data in our blob we
created under capital x and then the
second part has a comma 0. we're only
going to take the first value and then
if you notice we do the same thing but
we're going to take the second value
remember we always start with 0 and then
one
so we have column zero and column one
and you can look at this as our x y
plots the first one is the x plot and
the second one is the y plot so the
first one is on the bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and
10 and then the second one x of the one
is the 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 going up the left
hand side s equals 30 is just the size
of the dots we can see them it says real
tiny dots and then c map equals plt.cm.
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
uh fit was done in two lines of code a
lot of times there'll be a third line
where we regularize the data we set it
between like minus one and one and we
reshape it but for this it's not
necessary and it's also kind of nice
because you can actually see what's
going on and then if we wanted to we
wanted to actually run a prediction
let's take a look and see what that
looks like and to predict some new data
and we'll show this again as we get
towards the end of digging in deep you
can simply assign your new data in this
case i am giving it a width and length 3
4 and a width of length 5 6. and note
that i put the data as a set of brackets
and then i have the brackets inside and
the reason i do that is because when
we're looking at data it's designed to
process a large amount of data coming in
we don't want to just process one line
at a time and so in this case i'm
processing two lines and then i'm just
going to print and you'll see clf dot
predict new data so the clf and the dot
predict part is going to give us an
answer and let's see what that looks
like and you'll see 0 1 so predicted the
first one the 3 4 is going to be on the
one side and the 5 6 is going to be on
the other side so one came out as an
alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation for the setup but really we
want to dug in and see what it's going
on behind the scenes and let's see what
that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
and we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here that
we go through a few steps and i'll move
this over to our editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that and
show you how not to redo that and then
we're going to go in there and add in
those lines we're going to see what
those lines look like and how to set
those up and finally we're going to plot
all that on here and show it and you'll
get a nice graph with the what we saw
earlier when we were going through the
theory behind this where it shows the
support vectors and the hyperplane and
those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 has plot show
and we're going to talk about that here
in just a second but let's scroll down
to a new line down here and i'm going to
paste that code in and you'll see that
the plot show has moved down below let's
scroll up a little bit and if you look
at the top here of our new section one
two three and four is the same code we
had before and let's go back up here and
take a look at that we're going to fit
the values on our svm and then we're
going to plot scatter it and then we're
going to do a plot show so you should be
asking why are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is very standard used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt it can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit zero x limit
one comma thirty and we've done the same
thing for the y space and then we're
gonna go in here and we create a mesh
grid and this is a numpy command so
we're back to our numbers python let's
go through what these numpy commands
mean with the line space and the mesh
grid we've taken x x small s x x equals
n p line space and we have our x limit 0
and our x limit 1 and we're going to
create 30 points on it and we're going
to do the same thing for the y axis now
this has nothing to do with our
evaluation it's all we're doing is we're
creating a grid of data and so we're
creating a set of points between 0 and
the x limit we're creating 30 points and
the same thing with the y and then the
mesh grid loops those all together so it
forms a nice grit so if we were going to
do this say between the limit 0 and 10
and do 10 points we would have a 0 0 1 1
0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on you can
just imagine a point at each corner one
of those boxes and the mesh grid
combines them all so we take the yy and
the xx we created and creates the full
grid and we've set that grid into the y
y coordinates and the x x coordinates
now remember we're working with number
and python we like to separate those we
like to have instead of it being x comma
1 you know x comma y
and then x2 comma y2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital yy and a
column of x's capital xx with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value z and the
z equals the clf that's our that's our
support vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a dot
decision function we're going to put the
x y in there so here we have all this
data we're going to put that x y in
there that data we're going to reshape
it and you'll see that we have the x dot
shape in here this literally takes the
xx resets it up connected to the y and
the z value lets us know whether it is
the left hand side is going to generate
three different values the z value does
and it'll tell us whether that data is a
support vector to the left the
hyperplane in the middle or the support
vector to the right so it generates
three different values for each of those
points and those points have been
reshaped so they're right on a line on
those three different lines so we've set
all of our data up we've labeled it to
three different areas and we've reshaped
it and we've just taken 30 points in
each direction if you do the math you
have 30 times 30 so it's 900 points of
data and we separated between the three
lines and reshaped it to fit those three
lines we can then go back to our map
plot library we've created the ax and
we're going to create a contour and
you'll see here we have contour capital
xx capital yy these have been reshaped
to fit those lines z is the labels so
now we have the three different points
with the labels in there and we can set
the colors equals k and i told you we
had three different labels but we have
three levels of data the alphas just
makes it kind of see through so it's
only 0.5 of the value in there so when
we graph it the data will show up from
behind it wherever the lines go and
finally the line styles this is where we
set the two support vectors to be dash
dashed lines and then a single one is
just a straight line that's what all
that setup does and then finally we take
our ax dot scatter we're going to go
ahead and plot the support vectors but
we've programmed it in there so that
they look nice like the dash dash line
and the dashed line on that grid and you
can see here when we do the clf dot
support vectors we are looking at column
zero and column one and then again we
have the s equals one hundred so we're
gonna make them larger and the line
width equals one face colors equals none
let's take a look and see what that
looks like when we show it and you can
see we get down to our end result it
creates a really nice graph we have our
two support vectors and dashed lines and
they have the near data so you can see
those two points or in this case the
four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth knn is really a
fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning
by now we all know machine learning
models make predictions by learning from
the past data available so we have our
input values our machine learning model
builds on those inputs of what we
already know and then we use that to
create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now
unless they live a place where there's
not many cats or dogs so if we look at
the sharpness of the claws the length of
the ears and we can see that the cat has
a smaller ears and sharper claws than
the other animals its features are more
like cats it must be a cat
sharp claws length of ears and it goes
in the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to 3 we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors we're going
to say this is a square and if we put k
equals a 7 we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around and you can see as the k changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get he's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using like this case
squares and triangles if it's even you
want to make your k value odd that helps
it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use knn when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate
is going to be a normal weight so
majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so recap of knn positive integer
k is specified along with a new sample
we select the k entries in our database
which are closest to the new sample we
find the most common classification of
these entries this is the classification
we give to the new sample so as you can
see it's pretty straightforward we're
just looking for the closest things that
match what we got so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in a use
case in python so let's dive into the
predict diabetes use case so use case
predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight um eight columns with a
particular attribute and then the ninth
column which is the outcome is whether
they have diabetes as a data scientist
the first thing you should be looking at
is insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes that's why
they're taking it and that could cause
issue in some of the machine learning
packages but for a very basic setup this
works fine for doing the k n n and the
next thing you notice is it didn't take
very much to open it up um i can scroll
down to the bottom of the data there's
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different uh
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments like create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case it's going
to open up chrome because that's my
default that i use and since the script
is pre-done you'll see i have a number
of windows open up at the top the one
we're working in and since we're working
on the k n predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not let's go and put
that title in there
and i'm also going to go up here and
click on cell actually we want to go
ahead and first insert a cell below and
then i'm going to go back up to the top
cell and i'm going to change the cell
type to markdown that means this is not
going to run as python it's a markdown
language so if i run this first one it
comes up in nice big letters which is
kind of nice remind us what we're
working on and by now you should be
familiar with doing all of our imports
we're going to import the pandas as pd
import numpy is np pandas is the pandas
data frame and numpy is a number array
very powerful tools to use in here so we
have our imports so we've brought in our
pandas our numpy our two general python
tools and then you can see over here we
have our trained test split by now you
should be familiar with splitting the
data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so that they're
all uniform between -1 and 1. and then
the actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full
length on there we can also do a quick
length of the data set that is a simple
python command len for length we might
even let's go ahead and print that we'll
go print and if you do it on its own
line link that data set in the jupyter
notebook it'll automatically print it
but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i use i always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame pandas
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose
any of those you'd be dead so not a
really good factor if they don't if they
have a zero in there because they didn't
have the data and we'll take a look at
that because we're going to start
replacing that information with a couple
of different things and let's see what
that looks like so first we create a
nice list as you can see we have the
values talked about glucose blood
pressure skin thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the nan
numpy nan is what that stands for is
none doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing the
zero with a numpy none there's no data
there that's what that says that's what
this is saying right here so put the
zero in and we're going to place zeros
with no data so if it's a zero that
means the person's well hopefully not
dead hope they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the
integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip n a's we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip n a so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the npn with the means why did we do
that we could have actually just taken
this step and gone right down here and
just replaced 0 and skip anything were
except you could actually there's a way
to skip zeros and then just replace all
the zeros but in this case we want to go
ahead and do it this way so you could
see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see you skipped a bunch
in the middle because that's what it
does if you have too many lines in
jupiter notebook it'll skip a few and go
on to the next in a data set let me go
and remove this
and we'll just zero out that
and of course before we do any
processing before proceeding any further
we need to split the data set into our
train and testing data that way we have
something to train it with and something
to test it on and you're going to notice
we did a little something here with the
pandas database code there we go my
drawing tool we've added in this right
here
of the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column nine
here it is right up here we put it in
here is outcome well that's not part of
the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here 0 this is
actually 0 to 7 it doesn't include the
last one and then we go down here to y
which is our answer and we want just the
last one just column 8 and you can do it
this way with this particular notation
and then if you remember we imported the
train test split that's part of the
sklearn right there and we simply put in
our x and our y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you seeded i'd have
to look that up and then the test size
test size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any print out other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scal the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is 1 to 6 we're going to set that
all so that all the data is between -1
and 1 that's what that standard scalar
does keeps it standardized and we only
want to fit the scalar with the training
set but we want to make sure the testing
set is the x test going in is also
transformed so it's processing it the
same so here we go with our standard
scalar we're going to call it sc
underscore x for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our x train
equals sc underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the x
train variable and then our x test we're
also going to transform it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're gonna go and run
this if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key
columns that shouldn't be zero and we
replace that with the means of those
columns that way that they fit right in
with our data models we've come down
here we split the data so now we have
our test data and our training data and
then we've taken and we've scaled the
data so all of our data going in no no
we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import math we
do math dot square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train before we do this let's go
ahead and do import math and do math
square root length of y test and when i
run that we get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11 so
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the is the
most common one and it works quite well
it's important to evaluate the model
let's use the confusion matrix to do
that and we're going to use the
confusion matrix wonderful tool and then
we'll jump into the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix why
test y predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do let's
just do p r e d
predicted across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here and that column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero is the 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the f1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our f1 score
the f1
takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives
where if we go ahead and just do the
accuracy account and that's what most
people think of is it looks at just how
many we got right out of how many we got
wrong so a lot of people when you're a
data scientist and you're talking to
other data scientists they're going to
ask you what the f1 score the f score is
if you're talking to the general public
or the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics in running
an sk learn and running the knn the k
nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent tells us it is a pretty fair fit
in the model welcome to the session on
k-means clustering so what is k-means
clustering
k-means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm in this case you
don't have labeled data unlike in
supervised learning so you have a set of
data and you want to group them and as
the name suggests you want to put them
into clusters which means objects that
are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if k
is equal to two there will be two
clusters if k is equal to three three
clusters and so on and so forth that's
what the k stands for and of course
there is a way of finding out what is
the best or optimum value of k for a
given data we will look at that so that
is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received data of a
lot of players from maybe all over the
country or all over the world and this
data has information about the runs
scored by the people ordered by the
player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
run scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to two and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from this centroid and the
distance from this centroid this point
is taken and the distance is found from
this centroid and the center and so on
and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine the
central point or the actual centroid for
these two clusters so we have this one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned
to the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning the centroid
is repeated till the repositioning stops
which means that the algorithm has
converged and we have the final cluster
with the data points and the centroids
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c d e f we start by
combining b and c from one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add b c to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top-down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have abcdef we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
into a b c d
e f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k-means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between k
mains and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k-means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells
how similar
some objects are so the similarity is
measured using what is known as distance
measure and what are the various types
of distance measures there is euclidean
distance there is manhattan distance
then we have squared euclidean distance
measure and cosine distance measure
these are some of the distance measures
supported by k-means clustering let's
take a look at each of these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure
it's nothing but the square of the
euclidean distance as the name suggests
so instead of taking the square root we
leave the square as it is and then we
have manhattan distance measure in case
of manhattan distance it is the sum of
the distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign that many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares
as a measure to find the optimum number
of clusters that can be formed for a
given data set so we create clusters or
we let the system create clusters of a
variety of numbers may be
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss that's taken as the optimum value
of k so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to 1 which means all the
data points are in a single cluster the
within s value will be very high because
they are probably scattered all over the
moment you split it into two there will
be a drastic fall in the within ss value
that's what is represented here but then
as the value of k increases the decrease
the rate of decrease will not be so high
it will continue to decrease but
probably the rate of decrease will not
be high so that gives us an idea so from
here we get an idea for example the
optimum value of k should be either 2 or
3 or at the most 4 but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they've
been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned
or repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated
from these centroids now remember it's
not necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is
the repetitive process iterative process
and if the centroid doesn't change once
the centroid stops changing that means
the algorithm has converged and this is
our final cluster with this as the
centroid c1 and c2 as the centroids
these data points as a part of each
cluster so i hope this helps in
understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of these newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two
and three so we again calculate the
distance of x one
from the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence so
let's take a detailed look at each of
these steps so we randomly pick k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step 2
we assign each data point to the closest
center so what we do we calculate the
distance of each x value from each c
value so the distance between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two
we now have
all the points all the data points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values they need
not be equally distributed by the way
based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assign them randomly so now in step 3 we
actually calculate the centroid of each
group which means the original point
which we thought was the centroid will
shift to the new position which is the
actual centroid for each of these groups
okay and we again calculate the distance
so we go back to step two which is what
we calculate again the distance of each
of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in
python notebook using pattern notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
walmart wants to open a chain of stores
across the state of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity's sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual k-means clustering
process
so we will assign
each of these points to the centroids
and then check whether they are
the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance in a assign each of
the points data points to the centroids
and then go through this iterative
process till the whole process converges
and finally we get an output like this
so we have four distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
the centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart find the
best locations for their stores in
florida so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how k
means clustering is used and even there
is a small implementation of k-means
clustering as well okay so let's get
started okay so this block is basically
importing the various libraries that are
required like matplotlib and numpy and
so on and so forth which would be used
as a part of the code then we are going
and creating blobs which are similar to
clusters now this is a very neat feature
which is available in scikit-learn make
blobs is a nice feature which creates
clusters of data sets so that's a
wonderful functionality that is readily
available for us to create some test
data kind of thing okay so that's
exactly what we are doing here we are
using make blobs and we can specify
how many clusters we want so centers we
are mentioning here so it will go ahead
and so we just mentioned four so it will
go ahead and create some test data for
us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually
provides
now from here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of k-means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to
train the model here there is no real
training kind of thing but that's the
call okay so we are calling fit and what
we are doing here we are just passing
the data so x has these values the data
that has been created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster one
this is two three and so on or i will
actually start from zero cluster 0 1 2
and 3 maybe and then for each of the
observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from 0 to 3 so
there are four clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3. so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the game so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically
create an instance and you mention how
many customers you want by specifying
this parameter and underscore clusters
and that is also the value of k and then
pass the data to get the values now the
next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code
at each step what it is doing and then
we will see a couple of more examples of
how k-means clustering can be used in
maybe some real life examples real-life
use cases all right so in this case here
what we are doing is basically
implementing the k-means clustering and
there is a function or a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid
is the closest and accordingly we assign
the data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position with the the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is uh done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case
also with that is actually convergence
right so for example the change is
0.0001 we can consider that as
convergence otherwise what will happen
is this will either take forever or it
will be never ending so that's a small
flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned this is not
the most sophisticated implementation
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data x and the
number of clusters which is four
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of a implementation of k means
clustering
and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real-life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters of
only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors and now we
need to bring it down to 16 colors so we
use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though
the image quality is definitely reduced
a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let me load that
and this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and this is the shape of
this image which is basically what is
the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is 427 pixel by 640 pixel
and then there are three layers which is
this three basically is for rgb which is
red green blue so color image will have
that right so that is the shape of this
now what we need to do is data let's
take a look at how data is looking so
let me just create a new cell and show
you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix and
each one has about four for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are large the numbers are a large so we
need to normalize them to between zero
and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and one and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide china
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here and take a look
at how data is looking all right so this
is how data is looking and now you see
this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between zero and 1.
this is one of the things we need to do
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k-means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time-consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini-batch k-mean so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look
so this is red against green and this is
red against blue there is
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything like
that now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look uh how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost it pretty
much looks like the original image yes
we can see that for example here there
is a little bit it appears a little
dullish compared to this one right
because we kind of took off some of the
finer details of the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors
and also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16 and then we render the
image once again and we will see that
the color the quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is uh even more intricate and has
probably much complicated color schema
so this is the image now once again we
can take a look at the shape which is
427 by 640 by 3
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big so we will
much bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a two
dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see
this looks much richer in color but at
the same time and this probably doesn't
have as we can see it doesn't look as
rich as this one but nevertheless the
information is not lost the shape and
all that stuff and this can be also
rendered on a slightly a device which is
probably
not that sophisticated okay so that's
pretty much it so we have seen two
examples of how color compression can be
done uh using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering ever wondered how google
translates an entire web page to a
different language in a matter of
seconds or your phone gallery groups
images based on their location all of
this is a product of deep learning but
what exactly is deep learning deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
which in turn is a subset of artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence is
a technique that enables a machine to
mimic human behavior machine learning is
a technique to achieve ai through
algorithms trained with data and finally
deep learning is a type of machine
learning inspired by the structure of
the human brain in terms of deep
learning this structure is called an
artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done using machine learning
we'd have to tell the machine the
features based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stim on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine
now let's dive into the working of
neural networks
here we have three students each of them
write down the digit nine on a piece of
paper
notably they don't all write it
identically the human brain can easily
recognize the digits
but what if a computer had to recognize
them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits
each number is present as an image of 28
times 28 pixels
now that amounts to a total of 784
pixels
neurons the core entity of a neural
network is where the information
processing takes place
each of the 784 pixels is fed to a
neuron in the first layer of our neural
network
this forms the input layer
on the other end we have the output
layer with each neuron representing a
digit with the hidden layers existing
between them the information is
transferred from one layer to another
over connecting channels each of these
has a value attached to it and hence is
called a weighted channel
all neurons have a unique number
associated with it called bias
this bias is added to the weighted sum
of inputs reaching the neuron
which is then applied to a function
known as the activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the neuron gets activated
every activated neuron passes on
information to the following layers
this continues up till the second last
layer
the one neuron activated in the output
layer corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support when most
people converse with customer support
agents the conversation seems so real
they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze mri images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality apple tesla and nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations the first as we discussed
earlier is data while deep learning is
the most efficient way to deal with
unstructured data a neural network
requires a massive volume of data to
train let's assume we always have access
to the necessary amount of data
processing this is not within the
capability of every machine and that
brings us to our second limitation
computational power training in neural
network requires graphical processing
units which have thousands of cores as
compared to cpus and gpus are of course
more expensive and finally we come down
to training time deep neural networks
take hours or even months to train the
time increases with the amount of data
and number of layers in the network some
of the popular deep learning frameworks
include tensorflow pytorch keras deep
learning 4j cafe and microsoft cognitive
toolkit considering the future
predictions for deep learning and ai we
seem to have only scratched the surface
in fact horus technology is working on a
device for the blind that uses deep
learning with computer vision to
describe the world to the users
replicating the human mind at the
entirety may be not just an episode of
science fiction for too long the future
is indeed full of surprises and that is
deep learning for you in short what is
deep learning deep learning is like a
subset of what is known as a high level
concept called artificial intelligence
you must be already familiar must have
heard about this term artificial
intelligence so artificial intelligence
is like the high level concept if you
will and in order to implement
artificial intelligence applications we
use what is known as machine learning
and within machine learning a subset of
machine learning is deep learning
machine learning is a little bit more
generic concept and deep learning is one
type of machine learning if you will and
we will see a little later in maybe the
following slides a little bit more in
detail how deep learning is different
from traditional machine learning but to
start with we can mention here that deep
learning uses one of the differentiators
between deep learning and traditional
machine learning is that deep learning
uses neural networks and we will talk
about what are neural networks and how
we can implement neural networks and so
on and so forth as a part of this
tutorial so a little deeper into deep
learning deep learning primarily
involves working with complicated
unstructured data compared to
traditional machine learning with where
we normally use structured data in deep
learning the data would be primarily
images or voice or maybe text file so
and it is large amount of data as well
and deep learning can handle complex
operations it involves complex
operations and the other difference
between traditional machine learning and
deep learning is that the feature
extraction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists we data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as i mentioned one of
the secret
sources of deep learning is neural
networks let's see what neural networks
is neural networks is based on our
biological
neurons the whole concept of deep
learning and artificial intelligence is
based on human brain and human brain
consists of billions of tiny stuff
called neurons and this is how a
biological neuron looks and this is how
an artificial neuron looks so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has
billions of biological neurons and we
are trying to simulate the human brain
using artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see what exactly
weights in biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic
units is a perceptron so what is a
perceptron a perceptron can be
considered
as one of the fundamental
units of neural networks it can consist
at least one neuron but sometimes it can
be more than one neuron but you can
create a perceptron with a single neuron
and it can be used to perform certain
functions it can be used as a basic
binary classifier it can be trained to
do some basic binary classification and
this is how a basic perceptron
looks like and this is nothing but a
neuron you have inputs x 1 x 2 x 2 x n
and there is a summation function and
then there is what is known as an
activation function and based on this
input what is known as the weighted sum
the activation function either gets
gives an output like a zero or a one so
we say the neuron is either activated or
not so that's the way it works so you
get the inputs these inputs are each of
the inputs are multiplied by a weight
and there is a bias that gets added and
that whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted if it is wrong if there is
an error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjusts the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth so that's what is known as
the training process of a neuron or a
neural network there's a concept called
perceptron learning so perceptron
learning is again one of the very basic
learning processes the way it works is
somewhat like this so you have all these
inputs like x1 to xn and each of these
inputs is multiplied by a weight and
then that sum this is the formula of the
equation so that sum w i x i
sigma of that which is a sum of all
these product of x and w is added up and
then a bias is added to that the bias is
not dependent on the input but are the
input values but the bias is common for
one neuron however the bias value keeps
changing during the training process
once the training is completed the
values of these weights w1 w2 and so on
and the value of the bias gets fixed so
that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this w i x i
summation plus b
is passed through activation function
and then the neuron gets either fired or
not and based on that there will be an
output that output is compared with the
actual or expected value which is also
known as labeled information this is the
process of supervised learning so the
output is already known and that is
compared and thereby we know if there is
an error or not and if there is an error
the error is fed back and the weights
and biases are updated accordingly till
the error is reduced to the minimum so
this iterative process
is
known as perceptron learning or
perceptron learning rule and this error
needs to be minimized so till the error
is minimized
this iteratively the weights and biases
keep changing and that is what is the
training process so the whole idea is to
update the weights and the bias of the
perceptron till the error is minimized
the error need not be zero the error may
not ever reach zero but the idea is to
keep changing these weights and bias so
that the error is minimum the minimum
possible that it can have so this whole
process is an iterative process and this
is the iteration continues till either
the error is zero which is
unlikely situation or it is the minimum
possible within these given conditions
now in 1943 two scientists warren
mccollux and walter pitts came up with
an experiment where they were able to
implement the logical functions like and
or and nor using neurons and that was a
significant
breakthrough in a sense so they were
able to come up with the most common
logical gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical gates which could take two
inputs like a and b and then
give a corresponding result so for
example in case of an and gate a
and b and then the output is a b in case
of an or gate it is a plus b and so on
and so forth and they were able to do
this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these gates
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for xor and we will
see why that is in a little bit so this
is how an and gate works the inputs a
and b the output should be fired or the
neuron should be fired only when both
the inputs are one so if you have zero
zero the output should be zero for zero
one it is again zero one zero again zero
and one one the output should be
one so how do we implement this with a
neuron so it was found that by changing
the values of weights it is possible to
achieve this logic so for example if we
have equal weights like 0.7 0.7 and then
if we take the sum of the weighted
products so for example 0.7 into 0 and
then 0.7 into 0 will give you 0 and so
on and so forth and in the last case
when both the inputs are 1 you get a
value which is greater than 1 which is
the threshold so only in this case the
neuron gets activated and the output is
there is an output in all the other
cases there is no output because the
threshold value is 1. so this is
implementation of an and gate using a
single perceptron or a single neuron
similarly an or gate in order to
implement an or gate in case of an or
gate the output will be one if either of
these inputs is one so for example zero
one will result in one or other in all
the cases it is one except for zero zero
so how do we implement this using a
perceptron once again if you have a
perceptron with weights for example one
point two now if you see here if in the
first case when both are zero the output
is zero in the second case when it is 0
and 1 1.2 into 0 is 0 and then 1.2 into
1 is 1. and in the second case similarly
the output is 1.2 in this last case when
both the inputs are 1 the output is 2.4
so during the training process these
weights will keep changing and then at
one point where the weights are equal to
w1 is equal to 1.2 and w2 is equal to
1.2 the system learns that it gives the
correct output so that is implementation
of or gate using a single neuron or a
single layer perceptron now xor gate
this was one of the challenging ones
they tried to implement an xor gate with
a single level perceptron but it was not
possible and therefore in order to
implement an xor so this was like a a
roadblock in the progress of
neural network however subsequently they
realized that this can be implemented an
xor gate can be implemented using
a multi-level perceptron or mlp so in
this case there are two layers instead
of a single layer and this is how you
can implement an xor gate so you will
see that x1 and x2 are the inputs and
there is a hidden layer and that's why
it is denoted as h3 and h4 and then you
take the output of that and feed it to
the output at o5 and provide a threshold
here so we will see here that this is
the numerical calculation so the weights
are in this case for x1 it is 20 and
minus 20 and once again 20 and minus 20.
so these inputs are fed into h3 and h4
so you'll see here for h3 the input is 0
1 1 1 and for h4 it is 1 0 1 1 and if
you now look at the output final output
where the threshold is taken as one if
we use a sigmoid with the threshold one
you will see that in these two cases it
is zero and in the last two cases it is
one so this is an implementation of xor
in case of x or only when one of the
inputs is 1 you will get an output so
that is what we are seeing here if we
have either both the inputs are 1 or
both the inputs are 0 then the output
should be 0 so that is what is an
exclusive arcade so it is exclusive
because only one of the inputs should be
1 and then only you will get an output
of 1 which is satisfied by this
condition so this is a special
implementation xor gate is a special
implementation of perceptron now that we
got a good idea about perceptron let's
take a look at what is the neural
network so we have seen what is a
perceptron we have seen what is a neuron
so we will see what exactly is a neural
network so neural network is nothing but
a network of these neurons and they are
different types of neural networks there
are about five of them these are
artificial neural network convolutional
neural network then recursive neural
network or recurrent neural network deep
neural network and deep belief network
so and each of these types of neural
networks have a special you know they
can
solve special kind of problems for
example convolutional neural networks
are very good at performing image
processing and image recognition and so
on whereas rnn are very good for speech
recognition and also text analysis and
so on so each type has some special
characteristics and they can they're
good at performing certain special kind
of tasks what are some of the
applications of deep learning deep
learning is today used extensively in
gaming you must have heard about alphago
which is a game created by a startup
called deepmind which got acquired by
google and alphago is an ai which
defeated the human world champion lee
sedol in this game of go so gaming is an
area where deep learning is being
extensively used and a lot of
research happens in the area of gaming
as well in addition to that nowadays
there are neural networks a special type
called generative adversarial networks
which can be used for synthesizing
either images or music or text and so on
and they can be used to compose music so
the neural network can be trained to
compose a certain kind of music and
autonomous cars you must be familiar
with google google's self-driving car
and today a lot of automotive companies
are investing in this space and deep
learning is a core component of this
autonomous cars the cars are trained to
recognize for example the road
the lane markings on the road
signals
any objects that are in front any
obstruction and so on and so forth so
all this involves deep learning so
that's another major application and
robots we have seen several robots
including sofia you may be familiar with
sophia who was given a citizenship by
saudi arabia and there are several such
robots which are very human-like and the
underlying technology in many of these
robots is deep learning medical
diagnostics and health care is another
major area where deep learning is being
used and within healthcare diagnostics
again there are multiple areas where
deep learning and image recognition
image processing can be used for example
for cancer detection as you may be aware
if cancer is detected early on it can be
cured and one of the challenges is in
the availability of specialists who can
diagnose cancer using these diagnostic
images and various scans and and so on
and so forth so the idea is to train
neural network to perform some of these
activities so that the load on the
cancer specialist doctors or oncologists
comes down and there is a lot of
research happening here and there are
already quite a few applications that
are claimed to be performing better than
human beings in this space can be
lung cancer it can be breast cancer and
so on and so forth so health care is a
major area where deep learning is being
applied let's take a look at the inner
working of a neural network so how does
an artificial neural network let's say
identify can we train a neural network
to identify the shapes like squares and
circles and triangles when these images
are fed so this is how it works any
image is nothing but it is a digital
information of the pixels so in this
particular case let's say this is an
image of 28 by 28 pixel and this is an
image of a square there's a certain way
in which the pixels are lit up and so
these pixels have a certain value maybe
from 0 to 256 and 0 indicates that it is
black or it is dark and 256 indicates it
is completely it is white or lit up so
that is like an indication or a measure
of the how the pixels are lit up and so
this is an image is let's say consisting
of information of
784 pixels so all the information what
is inside this image can be kind of
compressed into this 784 pixels the way
each of these pixels is lit up provides
information about what exactly is the
image so
we can train neural networks to use that
information and identify the images so
let's take a look how this works so each
neuron the value if it is close to one
that means it is white whereas if it is
close to zero that means it is black now
this is a an animation of how the
solving works so these pixels one of the
ways of doing it is we can flatten
this image and take this complete 784
pixels and feed that as input to our
neural network the neural network can
consist of probably several layers there
can be a few hidden layers and then
there is an input layer and an output
layer now the input layer takes these
784 pixels as input the values of each
of these pixels and then you get an
output which can be
of three types or three classes one can
be a square a circle or a triangle now
during the training process there will
be initially obviously you feed this
image and it will probably say it's a
circle or it will say it's a triangle so
as a part of the training process
we then send that error back and the
weights and the biases of these neurons
are adjusted till it correctly
identifies that this is a square that is
the whole training mechanism that
happens out here
now let's take a look at a circle same
way
so you feed these 784 pixels there is a
certain pattern in which the pixels are
lit up
and the neural network is trained to
identify that pattern
and during the training process once
again it would probably initially
identify it incorrectly saying this is a
square or a triangle and then that error
is fed back
and the weights and biases are adjusted
finally till it finally gets the image
correct
so that is the training process so now
we will take a look at
same way a triangle
so now if you feed another image which
is consisting of triangles so this is
the training process now we have trained
our neural network to classify these
images into
a triangle or a circle and a square so
now this neural network can
identify these three types of objects
now if you feed another image and it
will be able to identify whether it's a
square or a triangle or a circle now
what is important to be observed is that
when you feed a new image it is not
necessary that
the image or the the triangle is exactly
in this position
now the neural network actually
identifies the patterns so even if the
triangle is let's say positioned here
not exactly in the middle but maybe at
the corner or in the side it would still
identify that it is a triangle and that
is the whole idea behind pattern
recognition so how does this training
process work this is a quick view of how
the training process works so we have
seen that a neuron consists of inputs it
receives inputs and then there is a
weighted sum which is nothing but this x
i wi summation of that plus the
bias and this is then fed to the
activation function and that in turn
gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed these images when you send
maybe a square it will identify it as a
triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have zero
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights w1 w2 up to wn keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values it
could be 0.5 0.25 0.35 and so on it
could be positive or it could be
negative and the value that is coming
here is the pixel value as we have seen
it can be anything between 0 to 1 you
can scale it between 0 to 1 or 0 to 256
whichever way 0 being black and 256
being white and then all the other
colors in between so that is the input
so these are numerical values this
multiplication or the product w i x i is
a numerical value and the bias is also a
numerical value we need to keep in mind
that the bias is fixed for a neuron it
doesn't change with the inputs whereas
the weights are one per input so that is
one important point to be noted so but
the bias also keeps changing initially
it will again have a random value but as
a part of the training process the
weights the values of the weights w1 w n
and
the value of b
will change
and ultimately once the training process
is complete these values are fixed for
this particular neuron w1 w2 up to wn
and plus the value of the b is also
fixed for this particular neuron and in
this way there will be multiple neurons
and each there may be multiple levels of
neurons here and that's the way the
training process works so this is
another example of multi-layer so there
are two hidden layers in between and
then you have the input layer values
coming from the input layer then it goes
through multiple layers hidden layers
and then there is an output layer and as
you can see there are weights and biases
for each of these neurons in each layer
and all of them gets keeps changing
during the training process and at the
end of the training process all these
weights have a certain value and that is
a trained model and those values will be
fixed once the training is completed all
right then there is something known as
activation function neural networks
consists of one of the components in
neural networks is activation function
and every neuron has an activation
function and there are different types
of activation functions that are used it
could be a relu it could be sigmoid and
so on and so forth and the activation
function is what decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not so whether
the output should be 0 or 1 is decided
by the activation function and the
activation function in turn takes the
input which is the weighted sum you
remember we talked about w i x i plus b
that weighted sum is fed as an input to
the activation function and then the
output can be either a zero or a one and
there are different types of activation
functions which are covered in an
earlier video you might want to watch
all right so as a part of the training
process we feed the inputs the label
data or the training data and then it
gives an output which is the predicted
output by the network which we indicate
as y hat and then there is a labeled
data because we for supervised learning
we already know what should be the
output so that is the actual output and
in the initial process before the
training is complete obviously there
will be error so that is measured by
what is known as a cost function so the
difference between the predicted output
and the actual output is the error and
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so
and then
all the errors are added which can
sometimes be called as sum of squares
sum of square errors or sse and that is
then fed as a feedback in what is known
as backward propagation or back
propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function
is
minimum now there is a optimization
technique which is used here called
gradient descent optimization and this
algorithm
works in a way that the error which is
the cost function
needs to be minimized so there's a lot
of mathematics that goes behind this for
example they find the local minima the
global minima using the differentiation
and so on and so forth but the idea is
this so as a training process as as a
part of training the whole idea is to
bring down the error which is like let's
say this is the function
the cost function at certain levels it
is very high the cost value of the cost
function the output of the cost function
is very high so
the weights have to be adjusted in such
a way and also the bias of course that
the cost function is minimized so there
is this optimization technique called
gradient descent that is used and this
is known as the learning rate now
gradient descent
you need to specify what should be the
learning rate and the learning rate
should be optimal because if you have a
very high learning rate then the
optimization will not converge because
at some point it will cross over to the
side on the other hand if you have very
low learning rate then it might take
forever to convert so you need to come
up with the optimum value of the
learning rate and once that is done
using the gradient descent optimization
the error function
is reduced and that's like the end of
the training process all right so this
is another view of gradient descent so
this is how it looks this is your cost
function the output of the cost function
and that has to be minimized using
gradient descent algorithm and these are
like the parameters and weight could be
one of them so initially we start with
certain random values so cost will be
high and then the weights keep changing
and in such a way that the cost function
needs to come down and at some point it
may reach the minimum value and then it
may increase
so that is where the gradient descent
algorithm decides that okay it has
reached a minimum value and it will kind
of try to stay here this is known as the
global minima now sometimes these curves
may not be just for explanation purpose
this has been drawn in a nice way but
sometimes these curves can be pretty
erratic there can be some local minima
here and then there is a peak and then
and so on so the whole idea of gradient
descent optimization is to identify the
global minima and to find the weights
and the bias at that particular point so
that's what is gradient descent and then
this is another example so you can have
these multiple local minima so as you
can see at this point when it is coming
down it may appear like this is a
minimum value but then it is not this is
actually the global minimum value and
the gradient is an algorithm will make
an effort to reach this level and not
get stuck at this point so the algorithm
is already there and it knows how to
identify this global minimum and that's
what it does during the training process
now in order to implement deep learning
there are multiple platforms and
languages that are available but the
most common platform nowadays is
tensorflow and so that's the reason we
have uh this tutorial we've created this
tutorial for tensorflow so we will take
you through a quick demo of how to write
a tensorflow code using python and
tensorflow is
an open source platform created by
google so let's just take a look at the
details of tensorflow and so this is a
library a python library so you can use
python or any other languages it's also
supported in other languages like java
and r and so on but python is the most
common language that is used so
it is a library for
developing
deep learning applications especially
using neural networks and it consists of
primarily two parts if you will so one
is the tensors and then the other is the
graphs or the flow that's the way the
name that's the reason for this kind of
a name called tensorflow so what are
tensor sensors are like
multi-dimensional
arrays if you will that's one way of
looking at it so
usually you have a one dimensional array
so first of all you can have what is
known as a scalar which means a number
and then you have a one dimensional
array something like this which means
this like a set of numbers so that is a
one dimension array then you can have a
two dimensional array which is like a
matrix
and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three dimensional
array but tensorflow can handle many
more dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional arrays that is the
strength of tensorflow and which makes
computation deep learning computation
much faster and that's the reason why
tensorflow is used for developing deep
learning applications so tensorflow is a
deep learning tool and this is the way
it works so the data basically flows in
the form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually
execute that particular graph in the
form of what is known as a session you
will see this in the tensorflow code as
we move forward so all the data is
managed or manipulated in tensors and
then the processing happens using these
graphs there are certain terms called
like for example ranks of a tensor the
rank of a tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just a one number the rank is
supposed to be zero and then it can be a
one dimensional
vector in which case the rank is
supposed to be one and then you can have
a two-dimensional vector typically like
a matrix then in that case we say the
rank is two and then if it is a
three-dimensional array then rank is
three and so on so it can have more than
three as well so it is possible that you
can store
multi-dimensional arrays in the form of
tensors so what are some of the
properties of tensorflow i think today
it is one of the most popular
platform tensorflow is the most popular
deep learning platform or library
it is open source
it's developed by google developed and
maintained by google but it is open
source one of the most important things
about tensorflow is that it can run
on cpus as well as gpus
gpu is a graphical processing unit just
like cpus central processing unit now in
earlier days gpu was used for primarily
for
graphics and that's how the name has
come and
one of the reasons is that it cannot
perform generic activities very
efficiently like cpu
but it can perform
iterative actions or computations
extremely fast and much faster than a
cpu so they are really good for
computational activities and in deep
learning there is a lot of iterative
computation that happens so in the form
of matrix multiplication and so on so
gpus are very well suited for this kind
of computation and tensorflow supports
both gpu as well as cpu and there's a
certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we go into the
code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tensorflow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is uh just a suggestion
but if you are already familiar with how
tensorflow works then probably yeah you
can go straight into the neural networks
part so in this tutorial we will take
the use case of recognizing handwritten
digits this is like a hello world of
deep learning and this is a nice little
mnist database is a nice little database
that has images of handwritten digits
nicely formatted because very often in
deep learning and neural networks we end
up spending a lot of time in preparing
the data for training and with mnist
database we can avoid that you already
have the data in the right format which
can be directly used for training and
mnist also offers a bunch of
built-in utility functions that we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and
a large part of them
are for training then you have test just
like in any machine learning process and
then you have validation and all of them
are labeled so you have the images and
their label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are
handwritten
images collected from a lot of
individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have handwritten these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is mnis
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our
tensorflow is we will feed this data
especially the training data along with
the label information and
the data is basically these images are
stored in the form of the pixel
information as we have seen in one of
the previous slides all the images are
nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler
neural network configurations called
softmax and for simplicity what we will
do is
we will flatten
these pixels so instead of taking them
in a two-dimensional arrangement we just
flatten them out so for example it
starts from here it is a 28 by 28 so
there are
784 pixels so pixel number one starts
here it goes all the way up to 28 then
29 starts here and goes up to 56 and so
on and the pixel number 784 is here so
we take all these pixels flatten them
out and feed them like one single line
into our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a softmax layer what it does is
once it is trained it will be able to
identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is trained
properly and
if you feed
a number nine like this
then this particular neuron gets
activated so you get an output from this
neuron let me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine let's
say this has been trained and now if
you're feeding a number nine this will
get
activated now let's say you fade one to
the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed two this neuron
will get activated and so on i hope you
get the idea so this is one type of a
neural network or an activation function
known as soft max layer so that's what
we will be using here this is one of the
simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so
this is how the code would look we will
go into our lab environment in the cloud
and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks
and let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupyter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf df
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and
once you do this tf is tensorflow is
available as an object in the name of tf
and then you can run its methods and
accesses its attributes and so on and so
forth and mnist database is actually an
integral part of tensorflow and that's
again another reason why we as a first
step we always use this example mnist
database example so you just simply
import mnist database as well using this
line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just
use a pen to show what exactly it is so
when you do this one hot true what
happens is each label is stored in the
form of an array of
10 digits and let's say the number is
8 okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position 0 this is
at position 1 position 2 and so on and
so forth let's say this is position 7
then this is position 8 that will be 1
because our input is 8 and again
position 9 will be 0 okay so one hot
encoding this one hot encoding true will
kind of
load the data in such a way that the
labels are in such a way that only one
of the digits has a value of one and
that indicates so based on which digit
is one we know what is the label so in
this case the eighth position is one
therefore we know this sample data the
value is eight similarly if you have a
two here let's say then the labeled
information will be somewhat like this
so you have your labels so you have this
as 0 the 0th position the first position
is also 0 the second position is 1
because this indicates number two and
then you have third as zero and so on
okay so that is the significance of this
one hot true all right and then we can
check how the data is uh looking by
displaying the data and as i mentioned
earlier this is pretty much in the form
of digital form like numbers so all
these are like pixel values so you will
not really see an image in this format
but there is a way to
visualize that image i will show you in
a bit and
this tells you how many images are there
in each set so the training there are 55
000 images in training and in the test
set there are 10 000 and then validation
there are five thousand so all together
there are seventy thousand
images all right so let's uh move on and
we can
view the actual
image by uh using the matplotlib library
and this is how you can view this is the
code for viewing the images and you can
view them in color or you can view them
in grayscale so the c map is what tells
in what way we want to view it and what
are the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel values so these are
the max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is one because
this is a scaled value so 1 means it is
white and 0 means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your you remember these are your weights
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and
each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are
this is a
matrix
of
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784 matrix because there
are 10 neurons
and similarly there are biases now
remember i mentioned
bias is only one per neuron so it is not
one per input unlike the weights so
therefore there are only 10 biases
because there are only 10 neurons in
this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensorflow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables or at the
most variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication tf you
remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmal function so
that is what is being used here in this
case so we are using the matrix
multiplication of tensorflow so that you
multiply your input values x with w
right this is what we were doing x w
plus b you're just adding b and this is
in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf
dot nn soft max cross entropy with
logits is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer we discussed about this in a
couple of slides uh earlier and for that
you need to specify the learning rate
you remember we saw that there was a
slide somewhat like this and then you
define what should be the learning rate
how fast you need to come down that is
the learning rate and this again needs
to be tested and tried and to find out
the optimum level of this learning rate
it shouldn't be very high in which case
it will not converge or shouldn't be
very low because it will in that case it
will take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kickstart the training process
and so far we've been creating the graph
and in order to actually execute that
graph we create what is known as a
session and then we run that session and
once the training is completed we
specify how many times how many
iterations we want it to run so for
example in this case we are saying
thousand steps so that is a exit
strategy in a way so you specify the
exit condition so training will run for
thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques
shown here so let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can install tensorflow on your
local machine as well i'm showing this
demo on our existing cloud but you can
also install tensorflow on your local
machine and there is a separate video on
how to set up your tensorflow
environment you can watch that if you
want to install your local environment
or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
google cloud amazon or cloud labs any of
these you can use and run and try the
code okay so it has got started
we will login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial uh code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and uh so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walkthrough
in the slides as well now you will see
the actual code in action so the first
thing we need to do is import tensorflow
and then we will import the data and we
need to adjust the data in such a way
that the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately
and if we just check what is the type of
the data so you can see that this is a
data sets python
data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
training images there are
55 000 then there are test images 10 000
and then validation images 5000 now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use
matplotlib for this
and
if we take a look at the shape now shape
gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55 000
and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just uh
one image and just see
what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is
black so that's why you will mostly see
zero say that it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
the values are between zero and one okay
so this is what you're seeing so certain
locations there are some values and then
other locations there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called i
am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately you will be
able to see the different images now i
can change the values in this position
so which image we are looking at right
so we can say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
5 000
right so
5000 has 3
similarly you can just say 5 what is in
5 as 8
what is in 50
again 8 so basically by the way if
you're wondering how i'm executing this
code shift enter
in case you're not familiar with jupiter
notebooks shift enter is how you execute
each cell individual cell and if you
want to execute the entire program you
can go here and say run all
so that is how
the score gets executed
and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create one
placeholder and we create two variables
which is for the weights and biases
these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has
784 by 10 actual values okay so
one for this 10 is for each neuron there
are 10 neurons and 784 is for the pixel
values inputs that are given which is 28
into 28
and the biases as i mentioned
one for each neuron so there will be 10
biases they are stored in a variable by
the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value
so this is another placeholder we had x
as one placeholder and white underscore
true as a second placeholder and this
will have values in the form of
10 digit 10 digit arrays
and
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define all of this in the form of
a graph so up to here remember what we
have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to
view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who
let's say have done
maybe spark programming to some extent
will be able to easily understand this
but even in spark the the programming
the code itself is pretty
straightforward behind the scenes the
execution happens slightly differently
but in tensorflow even the code has to
be written in a completely different way
so the code doesn't get executed uh in
the same way as you have written so that
that's something you need to understand
and a little bit of practice is needed
for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating the variables and feeding
the variables and
rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and
the graph that's all defining maybe the
what kind of a network you want to use
for example we want to use a softmax and
so on so you have created the variables
how to load the data loaded the data
viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution in
tensorflow so the first step for
doing any execution in tensorflow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to
run this piece of code always so you
need to basically create what is known
as a node for initializing so this is a
node you still are not yet executing
anything here you just created a node
for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf.session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a with loop so you have a width
tf dot session as says and with the
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid
till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf dot session as says you say says
dot run init now says dot run will
execute
a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run cess is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf dot
session so an instance of the session
gets created and we are calling that
says and then we run a node within that
one of the nodes in the graph so one of
the nodes here is init
so we say run that particular node and
that is when the initialization of the
variables happens now what this does is
if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w
is a variable and b is a variable so any
variables that we created you have to
run this code you have to run the
initialization of these variables
otherwise you will get an error okay so
that is the that's what this is doing
then
we within this width block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for a
thousand steps and perform
the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about 50 000 images but it cannot
get all the images in one shot because
it will take up a lot of memory and
performance issues will be there so this
is a very common way of
performing deep learning training you
always do in batches so we have maybe 50
000 images but you always do it in
batches of 100 or maybe
500 depending on the size of your
system and so on and so forth so in this
case we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next patch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of 100 images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously they
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the w's and b's
get
updated till it reaches thousand
iterations in this case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria so here it is it just says
that okay this particular image was
wrongly predicted so you need to update
your weights and biases that's the
feedback given to each neuron and that
is run for 1000 iterations and typically
by the end of this thousand iterations
the model would have learned to
recognize these handwritten images
obviously it will not be hundred percent
accurate okay so once that is done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then test the accuracy of these
models by using the test data set right
so this is what we are trying to do here
the code may appear a little complicated
because if you're seeing this for the
first time you need to understand uh the
various methods of tensorflow and so on
but it is basically comparing the output
with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is
calculated as well so this is the
accuracy and that is what we are trying
to see how accurate the model is in
predicting these numbers or these digits
okay so let us run this this entire
thing is in one cell so we will have to
just run it in one shot it may take a
little while let us see
and
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model is around 91
okay now which is pretty good for such a
short exercise within such a short time
we got 90 percent accuracy however in
real life this is probably not
sufficient so there are other ways in to
increase the accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyper parameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and
so that this accuracy can be increased
beyond 90 percent let's look at the
different types of artificial neural
networks and this is like the biggest
area growing is how these all come
together let's see the different types
of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so
here's a human brain i feel sorry for
that poor guy so we have a feed for
forward neural network simplest form of
a they call it a a n a neural network
data travels only in one direction input
to output this is what we just looked at
so as the data comes in all the weights
are added it goes to the hidden layer
all the weights are added it goes to the
next hidden layer all the weights are
added and it goes to the output the only
time you use the reverse propagation is
to train it so when you actually use it
it's very fast when you're training it
it takes a while because it has to
iterate through all your training data
and you start getting into big data
because you can train these with a huge
amount of data the more data you put in
the better train they get the
applications vision and speech
recognition actually they're pretty much
everything we talked about a lot of
almost all of them used this form of
neural network at some level radial
basis function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a center point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watched
the sesame street as a kid that dates me
so it brings things together and this is
a great way if you don't have the right
training model you can start finding
things that are connected you might not
have noticed before applications power
restoration systems they try to figure
out what's connected and then based on
that they can fix the problem if you
have a huge power system cajon and
self-organizing neural network vectors
of random dimensions are input to
discrete map comprised of neurons so
they basically find a way to draw they
call them they say dimensions or vectors
or planes because they actually chop the
data in one dimension two dimension
three dimension four five six to keep
adding dimensions and finding ways to
separate the data and connect different
data pieces together applications used
to recognize patterns and data like in
medical analysis the hidden layer saves
its output to be used for future
prediction recurrent neural networks so
the hidden layers remember its output
from last time and that becomes part of
its new input you might use that
especially in robotics or flying a drone
you want to know what your last change
was and how fast it was going to help
predict what your next change you need
to make is to get to where the drone
wants to go applications text-to-speech
conversation model so i talked about
drones but you know just identifying on
lexis or google assistant or any of
these they're starting to add in i'd
like to play a song on my pandora and
i'd like it to be at volume 90
so you now can add different things in
there and it connects them together the
input features are taken in batches like
a filter this allows a network to
remember an image in parts convolution
neural network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know you ever seen
that on google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so that
it can do a face recognition on each
person applications used in signal and
image processing in this case i use
facial images or google picture images
as one of the options modular neural
network it has a collection of different
neural networks working together to get
the output so wow we just went through
all these different types of neural
networks and the final one is to put
multiple neural networks together i
mentioned that a little bit when we
separated people in a larger photo in
individuals in the photo and then do the
facial recognition on each person so one
network is used to separate them and the
next network is then used to figure out
who they are into the facial recognition
applications still undergoing research
this is a cutting edge you hear the term
pipeline and there's actual in python
code and in almost all the different
neural network setups out there they now
have a pipeline feature usually and it
just means you take the data from one
neural network and maybe another neural
network or you put it into the next
neural network and then you take three
or four other neural networks and feed
them into another one so how we connect
the neural networks is really just
cutting edge and it's so experimental i
mean it's almost creative in its nature
there's not really a science to it
because each specific domain has
different things it's looking at so if
you're in the banking domain it's going
to be different than the medical domain
then the automatic car domain and
suddenly figuring out how those all fit
together is just a lot of fun and really
cool so we have our types of artificial
neural network we have our feed forward
neural network we have a radial basis
function neural network we have our
cohenon self organizing neural network
recurrent neural network convolution
neural network and modular neural
network where it brings them all
together and no the colors on the brain
do not match what your brain actually
does but they do bring it out that most
of these were developed by understanding
how humans learn and as we understand
more and more of how humans learn we can
build something in the computer industry
to mimic that to reflect that and that's
how these were developed so exciting
part use case problem statement so this
is where we jump in this is my favorite
part let's use the system to identify
between a cat and a dog if you remember
correctly i said we're going to do some
python code and you can see over here my
hair is kind of sticking up over the
computer cup of coffee on one side and a
little bit of old school a pencil and a
pen on the other side yeah most people
now take notes
i love the stickies on the computer
that's great that's that is my computer
i have sticky notes on my computer in
different colors so not too far from
today's programmer so the problem is is
we want to classify photos of cats and
dogs using a neural network and you can
see over here we have quite a variety of
dogs in the pictures and cats and you
know just sorting out it is a cat it's
pretty amazing and why would anybody
want to even know the difference between
a cat and a dog okay you know why well i
have a cat door it'd be kind of fun that
instead of it identifying instead of
having like a little collar with a
magnet on it which is what my cat has
the door would be able to see oh that's
the cat that's our cat coming in oh
that's the dog we have a dog too that's
a dog i want to let in maybe i don't
want to let this other animal in because
it's a raccoon so you can see where you
could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little startup company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python i am
actually in python
3.6 it's always nice to tell people the
version of python because it does affect
sometimes which modules you load and
everything and we're going to start by
importing the required packages i told
you we're going to do this in karass so
we're going to import from karas models
sequential from the cross layers
conversion 2d or conv 2d max pooling 2d
flatten and dents and we'll talk about
what each one of these do in just a
second but before we do that let's talk
a little bit about the environment we're
going to work in and in fact let me go
ahead and open a uh the website cross's
website so we can learn a little bit
more about cross so here we are on the
cross website and it's a k-e-r-a-s dot
io that's the official website for cross
and the first thing you'll notice is
that cross runs on top of either
tensorflow
cntk and i think it's pronounced thanos
or thiano what's important on here is
that tensorflow and the same is true for
all these but tensorflow is probably one
of the most widely used currently
packages out there with the cross and of
course you know tomorrow this is all
going to change it's all going to
disappear and they'll have something new
out there so make sure when you're
learning this code that you understand
what's going on and also know the code i
mean look when you look at the code it's
not as complicated once you understand
what's going on the code itself is
pretty straightforward and the reason we
like cross and the reason that people
are jumping on it right now is such a
big deal is if we come down here let me
just scroll down a little bit we talk
about user friendliness modularity easy
extensibility work with python python is
a big one because a lot of people in
data science now use python although you
can actually access cross other ways if
we continue down here is layers and this
is where it gets really cool when we're
working with cross you just add layers
on remember those hidden layers we're
talking about and we talked about the
relu
activation you can see right here let me
just up that a little bit in size there
we go that's big i can add in an r e l u
layer and then i can add in a soft max
layer in the next instance we didn't
talk about soft max so you could do each
layer separate now if i'm working in
some of the other kits i use i take that
and i have one setup and then i feed the
output into the next one this one i can
just add hidden layer after hidden layer
with the different information in it
which makes it very powerful and very
fast to spin up and try different setups
and see how they work with the data
you're working on and we'll dig a little
bit deeper in here and a lot of this is
very much the same so when we get to
that part i'll point that out to you
also now just a quick side note i'm
using anaconda with python in it and i
went ahead and created my own package
and i called it the cross python 36
because i'm in python36 anaconda is cool
that way you can create different
environments real easily if you're doing
a lot of different experimenting with
these different packages probably want
to create your own environment in there
and the first thing as you can see right
here there's a lot of dependencies a lot
of these you should recognize by now if
you've done any of these videos if not
kudos for you for jumping in today pip
install numpy scipy the scikit-learn
pillow and h5py are both needed for the
tensorflow and then putting the cross on
there and then you'll see here and pip
is just a standard installer that you
use with python you'll see here that we
did pip install tensorflow since we're
going to do cross on top of tensorflow
and then pip install and i went ahead
and used the github
so git plus get and you'll see here
github.com this is one of their releases
one of the most current release on there
that goes on top of tensorflow you can
look up these instructions pretty much
anywhere this is for doing it on
anaconda certainly you'd want to install
these if you're doing it in ubuntu
server setup you'd want to get i don't
think you need the h5py and ubuntu but
you do need the rest in there because
they are dependencies in there and it's
pretty straightforward and that's
actually in some of the instructions
they have on their website so you don't
have to initially go through this just
remember their website on there and then
when i'm under my
anaconda navigator which i like you'll
see where i have environments and on the
bottom i created a new environment and i
called it cross python 36 just to
separate everything you can say i have
python 30.5 and python36 i used to have
a bunch of other ones but it kind of
cleaned house recently and of course
once i go in here i can launch my
jupyter notebook making sure i'm using
the right environment that i just set up
this of course opens up my in this case
i'm using google chrome and in here i
could go and just create a new document
in here and this is all in your browser
window when you use the anaconda do you
have to use anaconda in jupyter notebook
no you can use any kind of python editor
whatever setup you're comfortable with
and whatever you're doing in there so
let's go ahead and go in here and paste
the code in and we're importing a number
of different settings in here we have
import sequential that's under the
models because that's the model we're
going to use as far as our neural
network and then we have layers and we
have conversion 2d max pooling 2d
flatten dense and you can actually just
kind of guess at what these do we're
talking we're working in a 2d photograph
and if you remember correctly i talked
about how the actual input layer is a
single array it's not in two dimensions
it's one dimension all these do is these
are tools to help flatten the image so
it takes a two-dimensional image and
then it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the cross do
it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this has just
imported these packages for us to use
jupiter is nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and i'll go
ahead and also zoom in there a little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee
if you're familiar with my other videos
you'll notice i'm always sipping coffee
i always have a my case latte next to me
an espresso so the next step is to go
ahead and initialize we're going to call
it the cnn or classifier neural network
and the reason we call it a classifier
is because it's going to classify it
between two things it's going to be cat
or dog so when you're doing
classification you're picking specific
objects you're specific it's a true or
false yes no it is something or it's not
so first thing we're going to create our
classifier and it's going to equal
sequential so their sequential setup is
the classifier that's the actual model
we're using that's the neural network so
we call it a classifier and the next
step is to add in our convolution and
let me just do a
shrink that down in size you can see the
whole line and let's talk a little bit
about what's going on here i have my
classifier and i add something what am i
adding well i'm adding my first layer
this first layer we're adding in is
probably the one that takes the most
work to make sure you have it set
correct and the reason i say that this
is your actual input and we're going to
jump here to the part that says input
shape equals 64 by 64 by 3. what does
that mean well that means that our
picture is coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64 by 64 pixels and
each pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches i mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that karass
knows what your shape is coming in here
and it knows what's coming out and so
that really sets the stage most
important thing is that input shape
matches your data coming in and you'll
get a lot of errors if it doesn't you'll
go through there and picture number 55
doesn't match it correctly and guess
what it does it usually gives you an
error and then the activation if you
remember we talked about the different
activations on here we're using the relu
model like i said that is the most
commonly used now because one it's fast
doesn't have the added calculations in
it it just says here's the value coming
out based on the weights and the value
going in and
from there you know it's uh if it's over
one then it's good or over zero it's
good if it's under zero then it's
considered not active and then we have
this conversion 2d what the heck is
conversion 2d i'm not going to go into
too much detail in this because this has
a couple of things it's doing in here a
little bit more in depth than we're
ready to cover in this tutorial but this
is used to convert from the photo
because we have 64 by 64 by three and
we're just converting it to
two-dimensional kind of setup so it's
very aware that this is a photograph and
that different pieces are next to each
other and then we're going to add in a
second convolutional layer that's what
the c-o-n-v stands for 2d so these are
hidden layers so we have our input layer
and our two hidden layers and they are
two-dimensional because we're doing with
a two-dimensional photograph and you'll
see down here that on the last one we
add a max pooling 2d and we put a pool
size equals 2 2. and so what this is is
that as you get to the end of these
layers one of the things you always want
to think of is what they call mapping
and then reducing wonderful terminology
from the big data we're mapping this
data through all these layers and now we
want to reduce it to only two sets in
this case it's already in two sets
because it's a 2d photograph but we had
you know two dimensions by we actually
have 64 by 64 by three so now we're just
getting it down to a two by two just the
two dimension two dimensional instead of
having the third dimension of colors and
we'll go ahead and run these we're not
really seeing anything in our run script
because we're just setting up this is
all set up and this is where you start
playing because maybe you'll add a
different layer in here to do something
else to see how it works and see what
your output is that's what makes cross
so nice is i can with just a couple
flips of code put in a whole new layer
that does a whole new processing and see
whether that improves my run or makes it
worse and finally we're going to do the
final setup which is to flatten
classifier add a flattened setup and
then we're going to also add a layer a
dense layer and then we're going to add
in another dense layer and then we're
going to build it we're going to compile
this whole thing together so let's flip
over and see what that looks like and
we've even numbered them for you so
we're going to do the flattening and
flatten is exactly what it sounds like
we've been working in a two-dimensional
array of picture which actually is in
three dimensions because of the pixels
the pixels have a whole nother dimension
to it of three different values and
we've kind of resized those down to two
by two but now we're just going to
flatten it i don't want to have multiple
dimensions being worked on by tensor and
by keras i want just a single array so
it's flattened out and then step four
full connection so we add in our final
two layers and you could actually do all
kinds of things with this you could
actually leave out this some of these
layers and play with them you do need to
flatten it that's very important then we
want to use the dents again we're taking
this and we're taking whatever came into
it so once we take all those different
the two dimensions or three dimensions
as they are and we flatten it to one
dimension we want to take that and we're
going to pull it into units of 128 they
got that you just say where did they get
2128 from you could actually play with
that number and get all kinds of weird
results but in this case we took the 64
plus 64 as 128. you could probably even
do this with 64 or 32. usually you want
to keep it in the same multiple whatever
the data shape you're already using is
in and we're using the activation the
relu just like we did before and then we
finally filter all that into a single
output and it has how many units one why
because we want to know whether true or
false it's either a dog or a cat you
could say one is dog zero is cat or
maybe you're a cat lover and it's one is
cat and zero is dog if you love both
dogs and cats
you're gonna have to choose and then we
use the sigmoid activation if you
remember from before we had the relu and
there's also the sigmoid the sigmoid
just makes it clear it's yes or no we
don't wanna any kind of in-between
number coming out and we'll go ahead and
run this and you'll see it's still all
in setup and then finally we want to go
ahead and compile and let's put the
compiling our classifier neural network
and we're going to use the optimizer
atom and i hinted at this just a little
bit before where does atom come in where
does an optimizer come in well the
optimizer is the reverse propagation
when we're training it it goes all the
way through and says error and then how
does it readjust those weights there are
a number of them atom is the most
commonly used and it works best on large
data most people stick with the atom
because when they're testing on smaller
data see if their model is going to go
through and get all their errors out
before they run it on larger data sets
they're going to run it on atom anyway
so they just leave it on atom most
commonly used but there are some other
ones out there you should be aware of
that that you might try them if you're
stuck in a bind or you might blur that
in the future but usually atom is just
fine on there and then you have two more
settings you have loss and metrics we're
not going to dig too much into loss or
metrics these are things you really have
to explore cross because there are so
many choices this is how it computes the
error there's so many different ways to
on your back propagation and your
training so we're using the atom model
but you can compute the error by
standard deviation standard deviation
squared they use binary cross entropy
i'd have to look that up to even know
what that is there's so many of these a
lot of times you just start with the
ones that look correct that are most
commonly used and then you have to go
read the cross site and actually see
with these different losses and metrics
and what different options they have so
we're not going to get too much into
them other than to reference you over to
the cross website to explore them deeper
but we are going to go ahead and run
them and now we've set up our classifier
so we have an object classifier and if
you go back up here you'll see that
we've added in step one we added in our
layer for the input we added a layer
that comes in there and uses the relu
for activation and then it pulls the
data so this is even though these are
two layers the actual neural network
layer is up here and then it uses this
to pull the data into a two by two so
into two dimensional array from a three
dimensional array with the colors then
we flatten it so there's our outer
flattened and then we add another dense
what they call dense layer this dense
layer goes in there and it downsizes it
to 128 it reduces
it so you can look at this as we're
mapping all this data down the
two-dimensional setup and then we
flatten it so we map it to a flattened
map and then we take it and reduce it
down to 128 and we use the relu again
and then finally we reduce that down to
just a single output and we use the
sigmoid to do that to figure out whether
it's yes no true false in this case cat
or dog and then finally once we put all
these layers together we compile them
that's what we've done here and we've
compiled them as far as how it trains to
use these settings for the training back
propagation so if you remember we talked
about training our setup and when we go
into this you'll see that we have two
data sets we have one called the
training set and the testing set and
that's very standard in any data
processing is you need to have that's
pretty common in any data processing is
you need to have a certain amount of
data to train it and then you got to
know whether it works or not is it any
good and that's why you have a separate
set of data for testing it we already
know the answer but you don't want to
use that as part of the training set so
in here we jump into part two fitting
the classifier neural network to the
images and then from cross let me just
zoom in there i always love that about
working with jupiter notebooks you can
really see we're going to come in here
we do the cross pre-processing and image
and we import image data generator so
nice of course it's such a high-end
product right now going out and since
images are so common they already have
all this stuff to help us process the
data which is great and so we come in
here we do train data gin and we're
going to create our object for helping
us train it for reshaping the data so
that it's going to work with our setup
and we use an image data generator and
we're going to rescale it and you'll see
here we have one point which tells us
it's a float value on the rescale over
255. where does 255 come from well
that's the scale in the colors of the
pictures we're using their value from 0
to 255. so we want to divide it by 255
and it'll generate a number between 0
and 1. they have shear range and zoom
range horizontal flip equals true and
this of course has to do with if the
photos are different shapes and sizes
like i said it's a wonderful package you
really need to dig in deep to see all
the different options you have for
setting up your images for right now
though we're going to stick with some
basic stuff here and let me go ahead and
run this code and again it doesn't
really do anything because we're still
setting up the pre-processing let's take
a look at this next set of code and this
one is just huge we're creating the
training set so the training set is
going to go in here and it's going to
use our train data gen we just created
dot flow from directory it's going to
access in this case the path data set
training set that's a folder so it's
going to pull all the images out of that
folder now i'm actually running this in
the folder that the data sets in so if
you're doing the same setup and you load
your data in there and you're doing this
make sure wherever your jupyter notebook
is saving things to that you create this
path or you can do the complete path if
you need to you know see colon slash etc
and the target size the batch size and
class mode is binary so the class is
we're switching everything to a binary
value back size what the heck is batch
size well that's how many pictures we're
going to batch through the training each
time and the target size 64 by 64.
little confusing but you can see right
here that this is just a general
training and you can go in there and
look at all the different settings for
your training set and of course with
different data we're doing pictures
there's all kinds of different settings
depending on what you're working with
let's go ahead and run that and see what
happens and you'll see that it found 800
images belonging to one classes so we
have 800 images in the training set and
if we're going to do this with the
training set we also have to format the
pictures in the test set now we're not
actually doing any predictions we're not
actually programming the model yet all
we're doing is preparing the data so
we're going to prepare a training set
and the test set so any changes we make
to the training set at this point also
have to be made to the test set so we've
done this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so i'm going to do the same
thing with that i'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale 1 over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found 2
000 images that's about right we're
using twenty percent of the images as
test and eighty percent to train it and
then finally we've set up all our data
we've set up all our layers which is
where all the work is is uh cleaning up
that data and making sure it's going in
there correctly and we're actually going
to fit it we're going to train our data
set and let's see what that looks like
and here we go let's put the information
in here and let's just take a quick look
at what we're looking at with our fit
generator we have our classifier dot fit
generator that's our back propagation so
the information goes through forward
with a picture and it says oh you're
either right or you're wrong and then
the air goes backward and reprograms all
those weights so we're training our
neural network and of course we're using
the training set remember we created the
training set up here and then we're
going steps per epic so it's 8 000 steps
epic means that that's how many times we
go through all the pictures so we're
going to rerun each of the pictures and
we're going to go through the whole data
set 25 times but we're going to look at
each picture during each epic 8 000
times so we're really programming the
heck out of this and going back over it
and then they have validation data
equals test set so we have our training
set and then we're gonna have our test
set to validate it so we're gonna do
this all in one shot and we're gonna
look at that and they're gonna do 200
steps for each validation and we'll see
what that looks like in just a minute
let's go ahead and run our training here
and we're going to fit our data and as
it goes it says epic one of 25 you start
realizing that this is going to take a
while on my older computer it takes
about 45 minutes i have a dual processor
now we're processing uh 10 000 photos
that's not a small amount of photographs
to process so if you're on your laptop
in which i am it's going to take a while
so let's go ahead and go get our cup of
coffee and a sip and come back and see
what this looks like so i'm back you
didn't know i was gone that was actually
a lengthy pause there i made a couple
changes and let's discuss those changes
real quick and why i made them so the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and insert a cell above
and let's paste the original code back
in there and you'll see that the
original thing was steps per epic 8 000
25 epics and validation steps 2 000 and
i changed these to 4 000 epics or 4 000
steps per epic
10 epics and just 10 validation steps
and this will cause problems if you're
doing this as a commercial release but
for demo purposes this should work and
if you remember our steps per epic
that's how many photos we're going to
process in fact let me go ahead and get
my drawing pin out and let's just
highlight that right here well we have 8
000 pictures we're going through so for
each epic i'm going to change this to
four thousand and cut that in half so
it's going to randomly pick 4 000
pictures each time it goes through an
epic and the epic is how many processes
so this is 25 and i'm just going to cut
that to 10. so instead of doing 25 runs
through 8 000 photos each which you can
do the math of 25 times 8 000. i'm only
going to do 10 through 4 000. so i'm
going to run this 40 000 times through
the processes and the next thing i know
that you'll you'll want to notice is
that i also change the validation step
and this would cause some major problems
in releasing because i dropped it all
the way down to 10. what the validation
step does is it says we have 2 000
photos in our trainings are in our
testing set and we're going to use that
for validation well i'm only going to
use a random 10 of those to validate so
not really the best settings but let me
show you why we did that let's scroll
down here just a little bit and let's
look at the output here and see what
that what's going on there so i've got
my drawing tool back on and you'll see
here it lists a run so each time it goes
through an epic it's going to do 4 000
steps and this is where the 4000 comes
in so that's where we have we have epic
one of 10 4 000 steps it's randomly
picking half the pictures in the file
and going through them and then we're
going to look at this number right here
that is for the whole epic and that's
seconds and if you remember correctly
you divide that by 60 you get minutes if
you divide that by 60 you get hours or
you can just divide the whole thing by
60 times 60 which is 3600. if 3600 is an
hour this is roughly 45 minutes right
here and that's 45 minutes to process
half the pictures so if i was doing all
the pictures we're talking an hour and a
half per epic times 36 or no 25 they had
25 up above 25. so that's roughly a
couple days a couple days of processing
well for this demo we don't want to do
that i don't want to come back the next
day plus my computer did a reboot in the
middle of the night so we look at this
and we say okay let's we're just testing
this out my computer that i'm running
this on is a dual core processor runs .9
gigahertz per second for a laptop you
know what's good about four years ago
but for running something like this is
probably a little slow so we cut the
times down and the last one was
validation we're only validating it on a
random 10 photos and this comes into
effect because you're going to see down
here where we have accuracy value loss
value accuracy and loss those are very
important numbers to look at so the 10
means i'm only validating across 10
pictures that is where here we have
value this is acc is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the epic what's our accuracy into
the epic what is it looking at in this
tutorial we're not going to go so deep
but these numbers are really important
when you start talking about these two
numbers reflect bias that is really
important let me just put that up there
and bias is a little bit beyond this
tutorial but the short of it is is if
this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down and
the value accuracy continues to go up
that means there's a bias that means i'm
memorizing the photos i'm looking at i'm
not actually looking for what makes a
dog a dog what makes a cat a cat i'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the cross
neural network is a lot of built-in
features like this that make that really
easy to track so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next set of code so here
we are into part three we're going to
make a new prediction and so we're going
to bring in a couple tools for that and
then we have to process the image coming
in and find out whether it's an actual
dog or cat we can actually use this to
identify it and of course the final step
of part three is to print prediction
we'll go ahead and combine these and of
course you can see me there adding more
sticky notes to my computer screen
hidden behind the screen and
last one was don't forget to feed the
cat and the dog
so let's go and take a look at that and
see what that looks like in code and put
that in our jupiter notebook all right
and let's paste that in here and we'll
start by importing numpy as np numpy is
a very common package i pretty much
import it on any python project i'm
working on another one i use regularly
is pandas they're just ways of
organizing the data and then np is
usually the standard in most machine
learning tools as a return for the data
array although you can use the standard
data array from python and we have cross
pre-processing import image fish that
all look familiar because we're going to
take a test image and we're going to set
that equal to in this case cat or dog
one as you can see over here and you
know let me get my drawing tool back on
so let's take a look at this we have our
test image we're loading and in here we
have test image one and this one hasn't
data hasn't seen this one at all so this
is all new hope let me shrink the screen
down let me start that over so here we
have my test image and we went ahead and
the cross processing has this nice image
set up so we're going to load the image
and we're going to alter it to a 64 by
64 print so right off the bat we're
going to cross is nice that way it
automatically sets it up for us so we
don't have to redo all our images and
find a way to reset those and then we
use also to set the image to an array so
again we're all in pre-processing the
data just like we pre-processed before
with our test information and our
training data and then we use the numpy
here's our numpy that's uh from our uh
right up here important numpy as in p
expand the dimensions test image axes
equals zero so it puts it into a single
array and then finally
all that work all that pre-processing
and all we do is we run the result we
click on here we go result equals
classifier predict test image and then
we find out well what is the test image
and let's just take a quick look and
just see what that is and you can see
when i ran it it comes up dog and if we
look at those images there it is cat or
dog image number one that looks like a
nice floppy eared lab
friendly with his tongue hanging out
it's either that or a very floppy eared
cat i'm not sure which but coordinator
software says it's a dog and we have a
second picture over here let's just see
what happens when we run the second
picture we can go up here and change
this uh from dog image one to two we'll
run that and it comes down here and says
cat you can see me highlighting it down
there as cat so our process works we are
able to label a dog a dog and a cat a
cat just from the pictures there we go
cleared my drawing tool and the last
thing i want you to notice when we come
back up here to when i ran it you'll see
that has an accuracy of 1 and the value
accuracy of 1. well the value accuracy
is the important one because the value
accuracy is what it actually runs on the
test data remember i'm only testing it
on i'm only validating it on a random 10
photos and those 10 folders just happen
to come up one now when they ran this on
the server it actually came up about 86
percent this is why cutting these
numbers down so far for a commercial
release is bad so you want to make sure
you're a little careful of that when
you're testing your stuff that you
change these numbers back when you run
it on a more enterprise computer other
than your old laptop that you're just
practicing on or messing with and we
come down here and again you know we had
the validation of cat and so we have
successfully built a neural network that
could distinguish between photos of a
cat and a dog imagine all the other
things you could distinguish imagine all
the different industries you could dive
into with that just being able to
understand those two difference of
pictures what about mosquitoes could you
find the mosquitoes that bite versus
mosquitoes that are friendly it turns
out the mosquitoes that bite us are only
four percent of the mosquito population
if even that maybe two percent there's
all kinds of industries that use this
and there's so many industries that are
just now realizing how powerful these
tools are just in the photos alone there
is a myriad of industries sprouting up
and i said it before i'll say it again
what an exciting time to live in with
these tools and that we get to play with
welcome to tensorflow
2.0 tutorial
what's in it for you we're going to
cover today deep learning frameworks
what is tensorflow features of
tensorflow tensorflow applications how
tensorflow works
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0 tensorflow 2.0
architecture and then we'll go over a
tensorflow demo where we roll up our
sleeves and dive right into the code
so let's start with deep learning
frameworks to start with this chart
doesn't even do the filled
justice because it's just exploded
these are just some of the major
frameworks out there there's keras which
happens to sit on tensorflow so they're
very integrated there's
tensorflow uh pie torches out there cafe
theano uh dl4j
and chainer these are just a few of the
deep learning frameworks we're talking
about neural networks if you're just
starting out never seen a neural network
you can go into python in the
scikit and do the neural network in
there which is probably the most
simplest version i know but the most
robust version out there the most top of
the ladder as far as the technology
right now is tensorflow and that of
course is changing from day to day and
some of these
are
better for different purposes
so let's dive into tensorflow let's see
what is tensorflow what is tensorflow
tensorflow is a popular open source
library released in 2015 by google brain
team for building machine learning and
deep learning models
it is based on python programming
language and performs numerical
computations using data flow graphs to
build models so let's take a look at
some of the features of tensorflow it
works efficiently with multi-dimensional
arrays
if you've ever played with any of the
simpler packages of neural networks
you're going to find that you have to
pretty much flatten them and make sure
your your stuff is set in a flat model
tensorflow works really good so we're
talking pictures here where you have
x and y coordinates where the picture is
and then each pixel has three or four
different channels that's a very
complicated array a very
multi-dimensional array it provides
scalability of computation across
machines and large data sets
this is so new right now
and you might think that's a minor thing
but when python is operating on one
computer and it has a float value
and it truncates it differently on each
computer you don't get the same results
and so your training model might work on
one machine and then another it doesn't
this is one of the things that
tensorflow
addresses and does a very good job on
it supports fast debugging and model
building
this is why i love tensorflow
i can go in there and i can build a
model with different layers each layer
might have different properties
they have like the convolutional neural
network which you can then sit on top of
a regular neural network with reverse
propagation there's a lot of tools in
here and a lot of options and each layer
that it goes through can utilize those
different options and stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard to visualize the
model tensorboard is pretty uh recent
but it's a really nice tool to have you
when you're working with other people or
showing your
clients or the
shareholders in the company
you can give them a nice visual model so
they know what's going on what are they
paying for and let's take a glance at
some of the different uses or
applications for tensorflow when we talk
about tensorflow applications
uh clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science i like to
use data science as probably a better
term this is the programming side
and it's really the sky is a limit
we can look at face detection language
translation fraud detection video
detection
there are so many different things out
there that tensorflow can be used for
when you think of neural networks
because tensorflow is a neural network
think of complicated chaotic data this
is very different than if you have a set
numbers like you're looking at the stock
market you can use this on the stock
market but if you're doing something
where the numbers are very clear
and not so chaotic as you have in a
picture then you're talking more about
linear regression models
and different regression models when
you're looking at that when you're
talking about these really complicated
data patterns
then you're talking neural networks in
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are after all that is what
tensor
that's what this is named after so we
talk about tensors in tensorflow
tensorflow is derived from its core
component known as a tensor a tensor is
a vector or a matrix of n dimensions
that represent all types of data and you
can see here we have the scalar which is
just a single
number you have your vector which is two
numbers uh might be a number in a
direction you have a simple matrix and
then we get into the tensor
i mentioned how a picture is a very
complicated tensor because it has your x
y coordinates and then each one of those
pixels has three to four channels for
your different colors
and so each image coming in would be its
own tensor
and
in tensorflow tensors are defined by a
unit of dimensionality called as rank
and you can see here we have our
scalar which is a single number that has
a rank of 0 because it has no real
dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point
and then you have your vector which
would be a single list of numbers
so that's a rank one
matrix would have rank two and then as
you can see right here as we get into
the full tensor it has a rank three
and so
the next step is to understand how a
tensorflow works
and if you haven't looked at
the basics of a neural network in
reverse propagation that is the basics
of tensorflow and then it goes through a
lot of different options and properties
that you can build into your different
tensors
so a tensorflow performs computations
with the help of data flow graphs it has
nodes that represent the operations in
your model and if you
look at this you should see a neural
network going on here we have our inputs
bc and d
and you might have x equals b plus c y
equals d minus 4
a equals x times y and then you have an
output
and so
even though this isn't a neural network
here it's just a simple set of
computations going across
you can see how the more complicated it
gets the more because you can actually
one of the tensors is a neural network
with reverse propagation
but it's not limited to that there's so
much more you can do with it and this
here is just a basic
flow of computations of the data going
across and you can see we can plug in
the numbers uh b equals four c equals
three d equals six
and you get x equals four plus three
so x equals seven y equals six minus
four so y equals two and finally a
equals seven times two or a equals
fourteen like i said this is a very
simplified version of how tensorflow
works each one of these layers can get
very complicated
but tensorflow does such a nice job that
you can spin different setups up very
easily and test them out so you can test
out these different models to see how
they work now tensorflow has gone
through two major stages
we had the original tensorflow release
of 1.0 and then they came out with the
2.0 version and the 2.0 addressed so
many things out there that the 1.0
really needed so we start talking about
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0 i guess you
would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2
we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if i want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit
x train y train and then your validation
data your x value y value and your epics
and your batch size all that goes into
the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic that's
what they mean by the eager so if you
see the first part you're like what the
heck is all the session thing going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into 2.0 it's just nice and clean
if you remember from the beginning i
said cross
on our list up there
and cross is the high level api in
tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow 2.0 it has incorporated cross
as tf.caras cross provides a number of
model building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project and
we'll hopefully touch base a little bit
more on this sequential being the most
common uh form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other so everything's going in a
sequential order
functional
is where you can split the layers so you
might have your input coming in one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together
and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or a neural basic
reverse propagation neural network and
then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing
is the most complicated as you're
building your own models and you can
subclass your own models into cross so
very powerful tools here this is all the
stuff that's been coming out currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at is it
in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to predefine that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as
the more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of and here we
have
a little bit more on the scope of this
and you can see how tensorflow 1 asks
you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope that's not even necessary in
tensorf 2.0 so you'd have to do one
before you do do what you see the code
in 2.0 in 2.0 you just create your model
it's a sequential model then you can add
all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version
and then we have the last two which is
our api cleanup and the autograph
in the api cleanup tensorflow 1 you
could build models using tf gans tf app
tf contrib tf flags etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
tf app your tf flags your tf logging are
all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our tf function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow 1
0 the python functions were limited and
could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of tf
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things
graph is what are all those lines that
are connecting different objects so if
you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using in
neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented api so this is
what you're working with you have your
tf cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your tf layers tf losses
tf metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers you can
your losses your metrics all of that is
so built into tensorflow makes it really
easy to use and then you can get down to
your low level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction we do a
linear regression model and then go to
the other where it does a
neural network and maybe each neural
network has a different activation set
on it and then it comes together into
another layer which is another neural
network so you can build these really
complicated models and at the low level
you can put in your own apis you can
move that stuff around and most recently
we have the tf code can run on multiple
platforms
and so you have your cpu
which is
basically like on the computer i'm
running on i have eight cores and 16
dedicated threads i hear they now have
one out there that has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models
neural network kind of setup
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture
we have
you can see on the left this is usually
where you start out with and 80 of your
time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your pre-made estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on
once you have all that set up you have
your distribution strategy where are you
going to run it are you going to be
running it on just your regular cpu are
you going to be running it with the gpu
added in
like i have a pretty high-end graphics
card so it actually grabs that gpu
processor and uses it or do you have a
specialized tpu set up in there that you
paid extra money for
it could be if you're
in later on when you're distributing the
package you might need to run this on
some really high processors because
you're processing at a server level for
uh let's say net you might be processing
this at a a distribute you're
distributing it not the distribution
strategy but you're distributing it into
a server where that server might be
analyzing thousands and thousands of
purchases done
every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a to give them a
recommendation or a suggestion so they
can buy more stuff off your website or
maybe you're looking for
data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about all those fun things we're talking
about saved model this is we were
talking about that earlier where it used
to be when you did one of these models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your
machine in the office and then you need
to distribute it and so we have our
tensorflow serving cloud on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi a little
breakout board there in fact they just
came out with a new one that has a
built-in there's this little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model on to that
talking about an affordable way to beta
test a new product you have the
tensorflow js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of end points and now they also have
other language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c java go
c sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at
three specific pieces of tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow in
tensorflow constants are created using
the function constant in other words
they're going to stay static the whole
time whatever you're working with the
syntax for constant
value d type 9 shape equals none name
constant verify shape equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals t f
dot constant
5.2 name equals x uh d type is a float
that means that we're never going to
change that 5.2 it's going to be a
constant value and then we have our
variables in tensorflow variables in
tensorflow are in memory buffers that
store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones you could also
do constants this way by the way you can
create a an array of ones for your
constants i'm not sure why you'd do that
but you might need that for some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is two
three which is then going to create a
nice two by three
array that's filled with ones and then
of course you can go in there and
they're variables so you can change them
it's a tensor so you have full control
over that and then you of course have
sessions in tensorflow
a session in tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about all that
information then goes through all those
arrows and whatever computations they
have that take it to the next node and
you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf if we do x
equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf.ad x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer with tf
session as session you can do a session
run init
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then i'll use specifically the jupiter
notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work uh whatever
platform you choose whether you're in a
notebook
the jupiter lab which is just the
jupiter notebook but with tabs for
larger projects we're going to stick
with jupiter notebook
pycharm whatever it is you're going to
use in here you know you have your
spider and your qt console for different
programming environments the thing to
note
it's kind of hard to see but i have my
main
pi 3 6.
right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version 3 6.
if you have python version 37 or 38
you're probably going to get some errors
in there
might be that they've already updated
and i don't know it now you have an
older version
but you want to make sure you're in
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and
pip in your
tensor flow or if you're in anaconda you
can do a conda install tensorflow to
make sure it's in your package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what i'm working
on making it really easy to just um
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick
no errors yay no errors i
do that whenever i do my imports because
i unbearably will have opened up a new
environment and forgotten to install
tensorflow into that environment uh or
something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know uh what
version we're working with
and we can do that simply by
using the version command in tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and
you know it always confuses me because
sometimes you do tf.version for one
thing you do tf dot underscore version
underscore for another thing uh this is
a double underscore in tensorflow for
pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array um a
equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the array
right in there 4 3 6 1. we can run this
and now that is what a is equal to and
if we want to just double check that
remember we're in jupiter notebook where
you can just put the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print
otherwise you'd surround it in print and
you can see it's a tf tensor it has the
shape the type and the and the array on
here it's a two by two array and just
like we can create a constant we can go
and create a variable and this is also
going to be a two by two array and if we
go ahead and print the v out we'll run
that
and sure enough there's our tf variable
in here
then we can also let's just go back up
here and add this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
we'll have b tf constant
and if we go and print out v and b
i'm going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here you'll see
right here when i print them both out
what happens it only prints the last one
unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and surround v with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have
we have the three one five two which is
a variable and this is just a flat
constant so it comes up as a tf tensor
shape two kind of two and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the v and
with the constant we have a lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
so those are a couple of things to note
in here
and just like any other array in math
we can do like a concatenate or
concatenate the different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated you just do a tf.concat
values and there's our a b axes on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so let's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six one four five it's
concatenated the two together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axis equals one this means
we're doing the columns um so if you had
a longer array like right now we have an
array that is like you know has a shape
one whatever it is two comma two
um axis
zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows if we
had a shape let me just put the word
shape here
so you know what i'm talking about is
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spend a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes
axis one you know zero one two that's
going to be our columns uh and if you
can do columns then we also can do rows
and that is simply just changing the
concatenate
we'll just grab this one here and copy
it we'll do the whole thing over
ctrl copy
ctrl v and changes from axis one
to axis zero and if we run that
you'll see that now we concatenate by
row as opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output this really you want to look
at the output sometimes just to make
sure your eyes are looking at it
correctly and it's in the format i find
visually looking at it is almost more
important than
understanding what's going on because
conceptually your mind just just too
many dimensions sometimes
the second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array
so tensorflow is utilizing numpy as part
of their format as far as python is
concerned
and so you can treat you can treat this
output like a numpy array because it is
just that it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up uh more than
you would think is filling uh one of
these with zeros or ones and so you can
see here we just create a tensor
tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
jupiter so i just type out tensor and i
run this you can see i have a nice
array of the shape three comma four of
zeros one of the things i want to
highlight here is integer 32. if i go to
the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how we have float 16 float 32
float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32 the reason for this
is that we want to control how many bits
are used in the precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform
so what would happen is i might run it
on this computer where python goes does
a float to indefinite however long it
wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer
and so we need to control whether it's a
tf float 16 in this case we did an
integer 32
we could also do this as a float
so if i run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32 bit precision
you'll see zero point whatever and then
to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would i
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform
set of ones or zeros you're dealing with
a lot of bias so be very careful about
starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros
on the other hand i use this for masking
you can do a lot of work with masking
you can also have it might be that
one tenser row is masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as a as the tensor
learns so it's another form of control
but in general
you see zeros and ones you usually are
talking about a mask over another array
and just like in uh numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four maybe we
want to swap that to four comma three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
ctrl v
let me run that
and you'll see that the the order of
these is now switched instead of four
across now we have three across and four
down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform
and we'll go ahead and just take off
well we'll go and leave that we're going
to run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71 and then instead of having
this one it rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you fill a lot of times you
fill these with random numbers and so
this is the random dot uniform is one of
the ways to do that
now i just talked a little bit about
this float 32 and all these data types
one of the things that comes up of
course is
recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these to integers
because of the project we're working on
um i know one of the projects i've
worked on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
round it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points um in
which case you have a lot of different
options you can multiply by 100 and then
round it off or whatever you want to do
there's a lot or then converted to an
integer was one way to round it off
uh kind
of a cheap and dirty trick
uh so we can take this and we can take
this same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor
and then we're going to go ahead and
print
our
tensor
let me just do a quick copy and paste
and when i'm actually programming i
usually type out a lot of my stuff just
to double check it
in doing a demo
copy and paste works fine but sometimes
be aware that copy and paste can copy
the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took
a float 32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it just
converts it right down to a integer
value
that's our integer 32 set up and
remember we talked about
a little bit about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axes zero axis one
one of the things that is important to
be able to do is to take one of these
variables
we'll just take this last one tensor as
integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a
equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a out and we run
this
you'll see that's the same array but
we've flipped it so that our columns and
rows are flipped this is
the same as reshaping so when you
transpose you're just doing a reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of roll down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a transform
so we come down here it's all done for
you and so there are so many times you
have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here and just like numpy you can
also do multiple your different math
functions we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v 4 comma 2.
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a 2 by 2 array
but instead
we're going to do just a 2 by 1 array
and the code for that is your tf dot mat
mole
so matrix multiplier and we have a times
v and if we go ahead and run this up
let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen the matrix math
this is
5 times 4 plus 8 times 2
3 times 4 plus 9 times 2
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the matrix or your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things
is to note is that just like in
numpy you have all of your different
math so we have our tf math
and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
oh let's do some multiplication that's
always good we'll stick with our
av
our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here uh we
have the four two and the five eight
three nine and it produces uh 2032 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have 4 times
5 is 20 4 times 8 is
32 that's where those numbers come from
we can also quickly create an identity
matrix
which is basically um your main values
on the diagonal being ones and zeros
across the other side
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a dot shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print
we'll do rows
and we'll do columns
and if we run this
you can see we have three rows uh two
columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity matrix
the script for that
got a wrong button there the script for
that looks like this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup we can actually see the
full tensorflow in use for that let's go
back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because i like to do that
hopefully made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being
a series of numpy arrays you got your
math equations and different things that
go into them
we're going to start building a full
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how uh kara sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports uh date times warning scipy
scipy is your
math so the back end scientific math
warnings because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions newer versions
and so sometimes when you get warnings
you want to go ahead and just suppress
them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup and of course date
time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as pd
numpy is your
numbers array
which of course tensorflow is integrated
heavily with
seaborn for our graphics and the seaborn
as sns is going to be set on top of our
matplot library which we import as mpl
and then of course we're going to import
our matplot library pi plot as plt and
right off the bat we're going to set
some graphic colors
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style you can look this all up there's
when you get into matplot library into
seaborn there are so many options in
here it's just kind of nice to make it
look pretty when we start the
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
and then we're going to take we have our
mplrc we're going to put a patch add
color dim gray line width again this is
all part of our graphics here
in our setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns so we don't want to
display more than 50.
and then our map plot library is going
to be inline this is a jupiter notebook
thing the matplot library inline then
warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings that way when they come up we
don't have to worry about them
not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then we want to go ahead and do is
we want to go ahead and import
our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under keras now remember cross
kind of sits on tensorflow so when we're
importing cross and the sequential model
we are in effect importing
tensorflow underneath of it
we just brought in the math probably
should have put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential
now if you remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick uh recall on that and
so in cross
we have sequential functional and
subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier and if you remember from here we
have a sequential where it's going
one tensorflow layer at a time you go
kind of look at think of it as going
from left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in but it
goes in one direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential and then we have our layers
and let's talk a little bit about these
layers this is where cross and
tensorflow
really are happening this is what makes
them so nice to work with is all these
layers are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dents
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers um activation
layer weight layer waste there's a lot
of stuff in here we had the relu which
is the basic activation that was listed
up here for layer activations you can
change those
and here we have our core layers and our
dense layers we have an input layer a
dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long term short term memory
layer and of course you can even do your
own custom layers in cross there's a
whole functionality in there if you're
doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do
this is why cross is so popular it's
open source and you have all these tools
right at your fingertips so from cross
we're just going to import a couple
layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer
and then of course from
sk learn our scikit we want to go ahead
and do our min max scalar standard
scalar for pre editing our
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv
and let's go ahead and take a quick look
at that this is in open office it's just
a standard you know like we can do excel
whatever you're using for your
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
a number of columns a number of rows it
actually goes down to like 8 000
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down probably not something we're
going to work with
the second row
is bendung i'm guessing that's a
reference for the profile
if we scroll to the bottom which i'm not
going to do because it takes forever to
get back up they're all the same
the same thing with the status the
status is the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
um here is the jam which i'm going to
guess is the time stamp on there so we
have a date and time
we have our o3 co no2 reading so2 no co2
voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4 pm 10
without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
this i can guess is like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality as far as
an area in a region and what's going on
with our date timestamps on there and so
code wise we're going to read this into
a pandas data frame so our data frame df
is a nice abbreviation commonly used for
data frames equals pd.read csv and then
our the path to it just happens to be on
my d drive
uh separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the bandung
the
date we have a timestamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic
pandas printing out the top five rows we
could easily have done
three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five for
pandas now i talk about this all the
time so i know i've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our date time it's come in in two
columns
we have our date here and we have our
time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combined date
time that's our formula we're building
our we're going to submit our
pandas data frame
and the tab name when we go ahead and do
this
that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create
and then goes for iron range df
shape 0
so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab append df location i
and here is our date going in there and
then return the numpy array list tab d
types date time 64. that's all we're
doing we're just switching this to a
date time stamp and if we go ahead and
do df date time equals combine date time
and then i always like to
print we'll do df head
just we can see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this
we now have our setup on here and of
course it's added it on to the far right
here's our date time
you can see the formats changed
so there's our we've added in the date
time column and we've brought the date
over and we've taken this format here
and it's an actual variable with a 0 0 0
on here well that doesn't look good so
we need to also include the time part of
this and we want to convert it into
hourly data
so let's go ahead and do that
to do that to finish combining our date
time let's go ahead and create a
little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr forcing this into a date
time format and we can actually spend
hours just going through
these conversions how do you
pull it from the panda's data frame how
do you set it up um so i'm kind of
skipping through it a little fast
because i want to stay focused on
tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff is going to be reformatting these
things resetting them back up
uh so that it looks right on here and
you know it just takes time to get
through all that but that is usually
what the companies are paying you for
that's what the big
bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data so there's nothing in
there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a
second
data frame here let me just get rid of
the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time 03 co
so now this is in the same order
as it was before
and you'll see the date time
now has our 0 0
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together so there's a lot more
manageable and in the format we want and
in the right sequential order
and if we go back to
there we go our air quality
you can see right here we're looking at
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at
and so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation
uh minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
numbers also in there
so you can get a quick look at a glance
describing the data or descriptive
analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable and we'll see
right here q1 we can simply do the
quantile 0.25 percent
which should match
our 25 percent up here and we'll be
looking at the min the max
and we're just going to do this is
basically we're breaking this down for
each uh different
variable in there
one of the things that's kind of fun to
do
we're going to look at that in just a
second let me get put the next piece of
code in here
clean out some of our
we're going to drop a couple thing our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values and
the first row is just our titles so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here and so this right
here as we look at our different
quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows we're going to go ahead
and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each
column individually and so we'll
just create a q1 q3 min max min iqr max
iqr
and calculate the quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing uh the math that
they did up here but we're splitting it
apart that's all this is
and
this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project i would probably spend
days and days going through
what these different values mean
one of the biggest data science uh
things we can look at that's important
is uh use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now uh we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our o3 so we've broken it down
we have our q1 5.88 q3 10.37 if we go
back up here here's our 5 8 we've
rounded it off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go uh q1 minus
1.5 times iqr and the iqr is your q3
minus q1 so that's the difference
between our two different quarters this
is all
data science
as far as the hard math
we're really not we're actually trying
to focus on cross and tensorflow you
still got to go through all this stuff i
told you 80
of your programming is going through and
understanding what the heck
uh happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey um
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and it usually in this case is going to
show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outliers found
minimum value high outliers found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project just to
find the outliers because you want to
know crime detection what are we looking
for we're looking for the outliers what
doesn't fit a normal business deal and
then we'll go ahead and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness
so we have if your max is greater than
iqr print outlier is found what we want
to do is we want to start cleaning up
these outliers and so we want to convert
we'll do create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max
underscore iqr min iqr equals mini iqr
so this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in python and if x is greater than the
max iqr and x is less than the min iq
are x equals
null we're going to set it to null why
because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that series so that you can look at just
the outlier and then we're going to
convert the nand hum again we have x
max iqr is 100
min iqr is men iqr
if x is greater than max iqr and x is
less than min iqr again we're going to
return a null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals x
and you can see as we go through the
code if i equals
our hum
then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column
uh then we're going to go ahead and
convert do the
run a map on there and convert the non
hum
you can see here it's this is just clean
up
we run we found out that humidity
probably has some weird values in it
we have our outliers
that's all this is
and so when we go ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers
and we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06
outliers have been interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like
these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate left and linears it's
going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
same thing with this up here with the
df2i interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep
we're not actually talking about
tensorflow we're just trying to get all
our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
we run through this you can see down
here that we have our outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data
how do we know that
some of it's just looking at the data
playing with it until you start
understanding what's going on let's take
the temp value
and we're going to go ahead and use a
logarithmic function on the temp value
and
it's interesting because it's like how
do you how do you heck do you even know
to use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain specific
we're talking about being an expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not what i go look at i
don't look at air care data in fact this
is probably the first air care data set
up i've looked at but the experts come
in there and they come to you and say
hey in data science this is a
exponentially variable variable on here
so we need to go ahead and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts data analytics a lot of times
you're talking about somebody who is a
data analysis might be all the way using
a phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it so when we're looking at
this we're looking at something they've
sent to me and they said hey
domain air care
this needs to be this is a skew because
the data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
we have our uh we'll do a distribution
df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the log temp so we can put them
side by side
and we'll just go ahead and do a quick
histogram and this is kind of nice plot
of figure figure size here's our plt
from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas
and this is a chart you would send back
to your data analysis and say hey is
this what you wanted this is how the
data is converting on here as a data
science scientist the first thing i note
is we've gone from a 10 20 30 scales at
2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been uh
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 of the data make
sure it's an integer you don't want to
take a slice as a float value give you a
nice error
uh and we'll have our train size at 75
percent and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set and then we can
simply do train comma test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size
and then if we go and print this let me
just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
that are going to be for our
setup on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
um that was from up here that's what we
called the logarithmic
value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do a converted an array of
values into a data set matrix we're
going to create a little um
set up in here we create our data set
our data set's going to come in we're
going to do a look back of one so we're
going to look back one piece of data
going backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back minus one
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it let
me go ahead and just put that code in
here
so we're going to do a look back one
here's our train x our train y
and it's going to be adding the data on
there and then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go
and we run this piece of code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x 1296 comma 1
shape of y train y
test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the x comes in
and we're only having a single value at
out
we want to predict what the next one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for what are we looking for well we
want to look back one that's the um what
we're going to train the data with is
yesterday's data yesterday says hey the
humidity was at
97 percent what should today's humidity
be at if it's 97 yesterday is it going
to go up or is it going to go down today
if 97 does it go up to 100 what's going
on there uh and so our
we're looking forward to the next piece
of data which says hey tomorrow's is
going to you know today's humidity is
this this is what tomorrow's humidity is
going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically
x plus 1 or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x data
we're only dealing with the one column
but you need to have it in a shape that
has it by the columns so you have the
two different numbers and since we're
doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here
now this is going to run into a problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer
so we're going to add another reshape on
here let me just go down here and put it
into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features
we're only looking at one feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on uh so we're
going to do is we're going to add one
more
level on here instead of being 12.99 one
we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape one
and this could have depends again on how
far back in the long short term memory
you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is and you can see the
new shape is now one uh
1299 one one
versus the 1299 one and then the other
part of the shape 432 one one again this
is our tr our x in and of course our
test x and then our y is just a single
column because we're just doing one
output that we're looking for
so now we've done our 80 percent um you
know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network
and if we're going to do that the first
thing we need is we're going to need to
go ahead and create a model and we'll do
this sequential model
and if you remember sequential means it
just goes in order that means we have if
you have two layers the layers go from
layer one to layer two or layer zero to
layer one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together
we're doing just sequential on here and
then we decided to do the long short
term memory
and we have our input shape uh which it
comes in again this is what all this
switching was we could have easily made
this one two three or four going back as
far as the end number on there we just
stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from um what kind
of models do we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there
because we're going to do two models and
the next model is going to go ahead and
we're going to do dent so we have model
equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
when we did the imports oops there we go
our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an lstm now just about every
tensorflow model uses dents
your dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error or it does reverse propagation to
program the model
so any of your neural networks you've
already looked at that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where do you find these
models what kind of models do you have
available and so for that let's go to
the cross website
which is the cross dot io
if you go under api slash layers and i
always have to do a search
just search for karas api layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates
relu which is like your smaller arrays
or if you're doing convolutional neural
networks the convolution usually uses a
relu
your sigmoid all the way up to soft mac
soft plus all these different choices as
far as how those are set up and what we
want to do is we want to go ahead and if
you scroll down here you'll see your
core layers and here is your dense layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing
image categorizing so trying to find
objects in a picture that kind of thing
we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually you bring them down into
a single layer although you can still do
like global max pulling 3d and there is
just i mean this list just goes on and
on uh there's all kinds of different
things hidden in here as far as what you
can do and it changes you know you go in
here and you just have to do a search
for what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on
long short term memory is a big one
because this is when we start talking
about text
what if someone says the what comes
after the uh the cat and the hat
a little kid's book there
starts programming it and so you really
want to know not only
what's going on but it's going to be
something that has a history the history
behind it tells you what the next one
coming up is now once we've built all
our different you know we built our
model we've added our different layers
we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together if you do a
the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might become linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things
so we're going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which we'll use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any uh
scikit from python
you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model
uh so what are we doing in here we're
going to send in our train x our train y
um we're going to decide how many epics
we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this
i'm guessing it'd probably be about two
or three hundred probably do just fine
our batch size
so how many different uh when you
process it this is the math behind it
if you're in data analytics
you might try to know what this number
is as a data scientist where i haven't
had the phd level math that says this is
why you want to use this particular
batch size you kind of play with this
number a little bit
you can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2. i'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbose means i think that's actually
the default on there if i remember
correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it
the big ones are your epic and your
batch size those are what we're looking
for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times
through all the data so if you have a
huge data set this is the point where
you're kind of wondering oh my gosh is
this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this
um you know this is running rather
quickly through all 500 iterations
but yeah a terabyte of data we're
talking something closer to days week
you know even with a
3.5 gigahertz machine in in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will print
the process on there more across
multiple um processors and multiple
computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error or 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.0888 and 0.8089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
you know if you're retraining the stuff
over and over again it's kind of good to
know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing of course if
you're going to build a model
uh we want to go ahead and run a
prediction on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set
and our test set or the
we have the
train x and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test x and our test y going in there uh
so we can test to see how good it did
uh when we come in here we have um
you'll see right here we go ahead and do
our train predict equals
model predict train x
and test predict model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction we know it has
a certain amount of error and we want to
compare the error we have on what we
programmed it with with the error we get
when we run it on new data that's never
seen the model's never seen before and
one of the things we can do we go ahead
and invert the predictions
this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals an np
exponential m1 the train predict and
then train y equals the exponential m1
for train y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test y
um
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches and then we want to
go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error
so we have our train score
which is your math square root times the
mean square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
this is just feeding the data through so
we can compare it and the same thing
with the test
and let's take a look at that because
really
the code makes sense if you're going
through it line by line you can see
we're doing but the answer really helps
to zoom in
so we have a train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score
then we've over trained something's
really wrong at that point you got to go
back and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model it's the test score
that you're showing people this is what
it did on my test data that the model
had never seen before this is how good
my model is
and a lot of times you actually want to
put together like a little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction the standard deviation
of data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i have to go back
and we're
up here if you remember we did the
square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
uh
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
and along with
putting a formal print out of there
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise and so at this point we
really want to put it in a graph so we
have something to display and with
displaying you remember that we're
looking at the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
np empty like data set train predict
plot
set it up with uh null values
yeah
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um
the
data groups as we like them
and then putting the data in there's
what's going on here
so we have our train predict plot
which is going to be our look back our
length
plus look back
we're just is going to equal train
train predict so we're creating this
basically we're taking this and we're
dumping the train predict into it so now
we have our nice train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting uh we're
going to continue more of that oops it
looks like i put it in here double no
it's just uh yeah they put it in here
double um didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
um this is where the problem was is
because
this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets
uh test
predict plot length prediction setup on
there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a time axis
always nice to have your time set on
there
set that to the time array
time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom and then we have a lot of
stuff going on here as far as setting up
our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here
our main plot we have two different
plots going on here
the ispu going up and the data and the
ispu here with all these different
settings on it
and so we look at this we have our
ax1 that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure plt
or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there
and so we take
and if you
go through the code piece by piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the
the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot that's what we just created
we're going to make that orange and
we'll label it train prediction
test predicts plot we're gonna make that
red and label it test prediction and so
forth um set our ticks up this actually
just put ticks time axes gets its ticks
the little little marks there going
along the axes that kind of thing and
let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction
you can see that it trains pretty close
to what the data is up there
i would also probably put a
like a little little time stamp and do
just right before and right after where
we go from train to test prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this is
is just the
test prediction on the right uh and it's
you know there's you'll see with the
original data set there's a lot of peaks
were missing and a lot of lows were
missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty does pretty good it's pretty
right on you can get a good idea what to
expect for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error that's the kind
of thing i put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe
weekly so you kind of get a nice kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces
all the tensorflows and that is to build
this sequential model and we're only
putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too hate wire on that and
that you kind of learn as you go again
it's domain knowledge
and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data
analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in and say this
is what we want to try
but i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times uh
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well as a data science i can run it
through the model in you know five
minutes instead of spending two weeks
doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientists is we do it from programming
side and a data analytics is going to
look for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course with any data
science putting out a pretty graph so
that your shareholders again we want to
take and
reduce the information down to something
people can look at and say oh that's
what's going on they can see stuff
what's going on as far as the dates and
the change in the ispu
in this video i will walk you through
the tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically we are
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example numpy
we need image i o date time and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some parts for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again it will go away all right and then
here onwards we do the model preparation
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use an existing neural network
model so we are not going to chain a new
one because that really will take a long
time and it needs a lot of computation
resources and so on and it is really not
required there are already models that
have been trained and in this case it is
the ssd with mobilenet that's the model
that we are going to use and
this model is trained to detect objects
and it is readily available as open
source so we can actually use this and
if you want to use other models there
are a few more models available so you
can click on this link here and
let me just take you there there are a
few more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as uh
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells we have downloaded and imported
the model and then once it is available
locally we will then load this into our
program all right so
we are loading this into memory and
you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
use for doing object detection in images
so this is where the actual detection
starts so here this is the path for
where the images are stored so this is
here once again we are reusing the code
which we wrote for detecting objects in
an image so this is the path where the
images were stored and this is the
extension and this was done for about
two or three images so we will continue
to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
like car so let me just show you so this
is in this object detection folder i
have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and
you know actually we will be reading the
video file but then we will be analyzing
it frame by frame and we will be reading
them at 10 frames per second that is the
rate we are mentioning here and
analyzing it and then annotating and
then writing it back so you will see
that we will have a video file named
something like this traffic underscore
annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code
and then we will come back and see the
annotated video this might take a little
while so i will pause the video after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so i think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play it some more and see
if it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and our application will
our network will detect that this is a
cat and uh even when the cat moves a
little bit in the other direction it
will continue to detect and show that it
is a cat okay so yeah so this is how the
original video is let's go ahead and
change our code to analyze this one and
see if it detects our network detects
this cat close this here we go and i'll
go back to my code all we need to do is
change this traffic to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
hourglasses come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see
yes
so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but
it is trying to detect something i think
it is saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and uh let's wait for some
time and see if it continues to detect
it when the cat turns around and moves
as well just in a little bit that's
going to happen and we will see there we
go and
in spite of turning the other way i
think our network is able to detect that
it is a cat so let me freeze and then
show here it is actually still continues
to detect it as a cat all right so
that's pretty much it i think that's the
only object that it detects in this
particular video okay so close this so
that's pretty much it so we're going to
dive right into what is cross we'll also
go all the way through this into a
couple of tutorials because that's where
you really learn a lot is when you roll
up your sleeves so we talk about what is
cross cross is a high level deep
learning api written in python for easy
implement implementation of neural
networks it uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pytorch
etc is back in to make computation
faster and this is really nice because
as a programmer there is so much stuff
out there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks
is really powerful it's really powerful
to
have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so crossworks by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a backend for fast
computation
while providing a user friendly and easy
to learn front-end
and you can see here we have the cross
api uh specifications and under that
you'd have like tf cross for tensorflow
thano cross and so on and then you have
your tensorflow workflow that this is
all sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to um dig us deeply into the heavy
end stuff while still having a very
robust package you can get up and
running rather quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it so the working principle of
cross
the working principle of karas is cross
uses computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical expressions
you see here we put them in blue they
have the expression expressing complex
problems as a combination of simple
mathematical operators
uh where we have like the percentage or
in this case in python that's usually
your left your remainder or
multiplication i might have the operator
of x
to the power of 0.3 and it uses useful
for calculating derivatives by using
back propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it
this makes it really easy to do that
without really having not banging your
head and having to hand write everything
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
and for solving complex problems specify
input and outputs and make sure all
nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models
so we look across models across model we
have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups this should look familiar
you should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code you can see how easy it
is
we have a layer that's dense
your layer one
as an activation now they're using the
relu in this particular example and then
you have your name layer one layer dense
relu name layer two and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model
and this is really where things are at
this is new make sure you update your
cross or you'll find yourself running
this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi-input and multi-output
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by 3.
you have your dense layers dense 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on
you have two different inputs
uh and one way you could think of this
is maybe one of those is a small image
and one of those is a full sized image
and
that feedback goes into you might feed
both of them into one note because it's
looking for one thing
and then only into one note for the
other one and so you can start to get
kind of an idea that there's a lot of
use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup
we have multiple information coming in
but the information is very different
even though it overlaps and you don't
want it to send it through the same
neural network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the data and
how you fork the models coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex models coming in
we have our image inputs which is a 32
by 32 by three or three channels or four
if you're having an alpha channel uh you
have your dense your layers dense is 64
activation using the relu very common
x equals dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10
x model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs outputs equals outputs name
equals minced model
so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at crust
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks uh but it's
always good to get on the same page and
for those people who don't fully
understand neural networks to dive into
them a little bit or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models
they're kind of uh when you first start
using them they're like a black box you
put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is
bad outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data examples set
with keras the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age
and you can think of this in today's
world with covid
uh what's going to happen on there and
we're going to go ahead and do an
example of that in our
live hands on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands-on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and open that up and
open up a jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your
setups i just like those for doing demos
and showing people especially
shareholders it really helps because
it's a nice visual so let me go and flip
over to our anacon and the anaconda has
a lot of cool two tools they just added
data lore and ibm watson studio clad
into the anaconda framework
but we'll be in the jupiter lab or
jupiter notebook i'm going to do a
jupiter notebook for this because i use
the lab for like large projects with
multiple pieces because it has multiple
tabs where the notebook will work fine
for what we're doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how jupiter helps our
jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new
create a new
3 and it creates an untitled python
we'll go ahead and give this a title and
we'll just call this a cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to just rename that
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is uh
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
i mentioned sklearn or your site kit if
you're installing sklearn the sklearn
stuff it's a
scikit you want to look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
um
doing data science if you if you're not
if you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then
just a note of what we're we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this this is kind of a fun thing you can
do we can change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 of participants are under 65
experience no side effects well 95
percent of participants over 65
experience side effects
so that's kind of where we're starting
at and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more complicated
information
and so we want to go ahead and generate
our setup
so we want to do for i and range and we
want to go ahead and create if you look
here we have random integers
train the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
uh let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data and if you if i mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from simplylearn they'll send you a copy
of this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our train samples of pen
[Music]
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time i was running a
thing on that had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on
a standard distribution error
and so what do i do i generate the data
on a standard distribution error to see
what it looks like and how my code
processes it since that was the baseline
i was looking for in this we're just
doing uh generating random data for our
setup on here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print um we'll do train
samples
and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like
and you can see the first five pieces of
data in our train samples is 49 85 41 68
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is and we generated
significantly more than that
um let's see 50 up here 1 000 yeah so
there's 1 000 here 1000 numbers we
generated and we could also if we wanted
to find that out we could do a quick
print the length of it
and
so or you could do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
so we could also print
do the same thing
labels
and let's change this to
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100
and they're labeled one zero one zero
one zero
i guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
wanna go ahead and take our train labels
and we'll convert it into a numpy array
and the same thing with our samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle
this is just a neat feature you can do
in numpy right here
put my drawing thing on which i didn't
have on earlier
i can take the data and i can shuffle it
uh so we have our so it's it just
randomizes it that's all that's doing
we've already randomized it so it's kind
of an overkill it's not really necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow and you
want to randomize it just to make sure
that that you know the input doesn't
follow a certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar uh
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
uh then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples so we're gonna go
ahead and fit and transform the data
so it's nice and scaled
and that is the age
so you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data uh
to zero and one otherwise you create a
bias
uh so if you have like a hundred creates
a bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated
if you actually start multiplying stuff
there's a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in jupiter notebook is that if you have
a variable you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line
it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.9195
0.791 so everything's between 0 and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
uh it really helps a lot to do these
kind of print ups halfway through you
never know what's going to go on there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data sent to
me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
be careful don't quote wikipedia on
these things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product
and then it became
uh
open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defactos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at
so when you see the tensorflow setup
it it's got like a huge following there
are some other setups like
the scikit under the sk learn has their
own little neural network
but the tensorflow is the most robust
one out there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup
on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow
uh and then we have the rest of this is
all cross here from number two down uh
we're gonna import from tensorflow the
cross connection
and then you have your tensorflow cross
models import sequential it's a specific
kind of model we'll look at that in just
a second if you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
uh and then we have from tensorflow
cross layers we're gonna import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom um
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize uh your data when you first
do it atoms as good as any atom is
usually there's a number of optimizer
out there there's about there's a couple
of main ones but atom is usually
assigned to bigger data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is a lot
of times you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the day at the end
of the story how good does your model do
and we'll go ahead and load all that and
then comes the fun part
i actually like to spend hours messing
with these things
and
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
um no we don't spend hours on four lines
of code that's not what we're talking
about when i say spend hours on four
lines of code
uh what we have here i'm going to
explain that in just a second we have a
model and it's a sequential model if you
remember correctly we mentioned the
sequential up here where it goes from
one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be your
input
it's going to be what they call dents
which is uh
usually it's just dense and then you
have your input and your activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape what's the activation
and this is where it gets interesting
because we have in here
uh relu
on two of these and softmax activation
on one of these
there are so many different options
for
what these mean
and how they function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things um
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just
some of it is just
almost like you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a
inverse tangent activation or the 10 h
activation
takes up a huge processing amount
so you don't see it a lot yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing word documents and
you're tokenizing the words
and so you'll see this shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
you'll crash the system it'll just take
too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax generates an interesting um
setup
where a lot of these when you talk about
rayleigh it lets me do this
rayleigh there we go relu has
a setup where if it's less than zero
it's zero
and then it goes up
and then you might have what they call
lazy
setup where it has a slight negative to
it so that the errors can translate
better same thing with softmax it has a
slight laziness to it so that errors
translate better all these little
details
make a huge difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like is you build
your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting
design setup oops i forgot the end of my
code here
the concept of build a file is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so that you can do
uh
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here
you can test your test out the quality
of your setup on there
and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go i just it was right above me there
we go we start doing your cross entropy
and stuff like that is you need a full
functional set of code so that when you
run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why
and then you can start swapping in these
models and so when i say spend a huge
amount of time on pre-processing data
it's probably 80 percent of your
programming time
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom everything's set and clear and
easy to read
so once we have our model built uh the
next thing we're going to want to do is
we're going to go ahead and train that
model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here this a lot of
times it's just paired with the model
because it's so straightforward
it's nice to
print out the model setup so you can
have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of
[Music]
the setup is your learning rate so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate is set
to 0.00
set to 0.01
depending on what you're doing
this learning rate can overfit and under
fit uh so you'd want to look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and under fitting that
are really worth reading once you get to
that point and understanding and we have
our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy
so this is going to tell keros how far
to go until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model we
want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
we have our scaled train samples
our train labels our validation split
in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
uh batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit most of the time though a
batch size is between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epics
and
for the verb rose of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss let's
see where was it compiled our data
there we go loss uh so it's looking at
the sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much
how how much does the um
error go down uh is the best way to look
at that and you can see here the lower
the number the better and just keeps
going down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end
and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if it made it all the way to one
but we also the loss is more important
because
it's a balance um you can have 100
accuracy and your model doesn't work
because it's over fitted
again you won't look up
overfitting and under fitting models
and we went ahead and went through 30
epics it's always fun to kind of watch
your code going
to be honest i
usually
the first time i run it i'm like oh
that's cool i get to see what it does
and after the second time of running it
i'm like i like to just not see that and
you can repress those of course in your
code
repress the warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now
so here we go we want to go ahead and
build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
but we'll go ahead and do a separate set
on here
and this is just what we did above
there's no difference as far as um
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here
the only difference is that
we already
did our scalar up here well it doesn't
matter because the the data is going to
be across the same thing but this should
just be just transformed down here
instead of fit transform
because you don't want to refit your
data on your
testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data
easy to mistake to make especially on an
example like this where we're not doing
um you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict
and we're going to do here's our x scale
data batch size 10 verbose
and now we have our predictions in here
and we could go ahead and do
a oh we'll print
predictions
and then i guess i could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our
age
and uh the prediction on this age versus
what is what we think it's going to be
but what we think is going to they are
going to have uh symptoms or not
and the first thing we notice is that's
hard to read because we really want a
yes no answer
uh so we'll go ahead and just round off
the predictions
using the arg max
the numpy arg max for prediction so it
just goes to 001
and
if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this
is no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms no symptoms
and just as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and
take a look at this there we go
confusion matrix is for accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the scikit the sk learn metrics
site kit being where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice matte plot library that makes a big
difference so it's always nice to
have a nice graph to look at a
picture is worth a thousand words
and then we'll go ahead and call it cm
for confusion matrix why true equals
test labels why predict rounded
predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting going over the different
plotting code
you can spend
like whole we have whole tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there
but we do have here is we're going to do
a plot confusion matrix there's our cm
our classes normalize false title
confusion matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have to the
nearest c map titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
matrix into a seaborn and real quick get
an output
it's worth knowing how to do all this uh
when you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders
you don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and uh let's go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our cm plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the
definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it
so our confusion matrix
our classes
title confusion matrix and let's just go
ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195
had side effects 200
no side effects that had side effects so
we predicted the 10 of them
who actually had side effects and that's
pretty good i mean i don't know about
you but you know that's five percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is uh divide these both by by
two and you get five out of a hundred uh
you can do the same kind of math up here
not as quick on the fly because it's 15
and 195 not an easily rounded number but
you can see here where they have 15
people
who predicted to have no
with the no side effects but had side
effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix are so important at the
end of the day
this is really where where you show uh
whatever you're working on comes up and
you can actually show them hey this is
how good we are or not how messed up it
is
so this was a uh i spent a lot of time
on some of the parts uh but you can see
here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
uh here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we can get a lot more complicated
let me flip back on over here because
we're going to do another uh demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with keras after creating our samples
and labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which has three
layers and this is what we did we had
our input layer our hidden layers and
our output layers and you can see the
input layer coming in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we used the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it uh learn on
training data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
here's our model that we created
summarized uh
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it
and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit our model and
put that information in here and it goes
through the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
matrix with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results a confusion matrix
breaks down the various
misclassifications
as well as correct classifications to
get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you can
see we have a nice printout of our
confusion matrix
uh with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative
so the blue ones
we want those to be the biggest numbers
because those are the better side and
then
we have our false predictions on here
as far as this one so i had no side
effects but we predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now
saving and loading models with keras
we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you're going to say oh that was a
lot of complication before well if you
broke it down we randomized some data we
created the um cross setup we compiled
it we trained it we predicted and we ran
our matrix
uh so we're going to dive into something
a lot a little bit more fun is we're
going to do a face mask detection with
cross so we're going to build a cross
model to check if a person is wearing a
mask or not in real time and this might
be important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask
and let's start with a little bit on the
data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again
if you want some of this information
contact simply learn and they can send
you some of the information as far as
people with and without masks so you can
try it on your own and this is just such
a wonderful example of this setup on
here
so before i dive into the mass detection
uh talk about being in the current with
covid and seeing if people are wearing
masks
this particular example i had to go
ahead and update to a python 3.8 version
uh it might run in a three seven i'm not
sure i haven't i kind of skipped three
seven and installed three eight
uh so i'll be running in a three python
three eight
and then you also want to make sure your
tensorflow is up to date
because the
they call functional
layers that's where they split if you
remember correctly from back
let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer
allows us to feed in the different
layers into different you know different
nodes into different layers and split
them a very powerful tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through
our next example which includes
multiple layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
end-to-end development of a product here
of course this is a very simplified
version and it'd be a lot more to it
you'd also have to do like recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code and we'll open up a new python
three oops python python3
it's working on it there we go
and then we want to go ahead and train
our mask we'll just call this train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
so it's it's uh
save mask train mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them
so we have in here
alt d there we go
i have something to draw with a little
bit here
we have our
image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
deals with how do we bring images in
because most images are like a
square grid and then each value in there
has three values for the three different
colors
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of working with that so you don't
have to do all the heavy listening and
figuring out what's going to go on
uh and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2d
this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them uh dropout's a cool thing
worth looking up
if you haven't when you as you get more
and more into cross and tensorflow
it will auto drop out certain notes that
way you'll get a better
the notes just kind of die and they find
that they actually create more of a bias
and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them
and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that huge array with the
three different colors and you find a
way to flatten it so it's just a one
dimensional array instead of a two by
two by three
uh dense input we did that in the other
one so that should look a little
familiar
oops there we go our input
our model again these are things we had
on the last one
here's our optimizer with our atom
um we have some pre-processing on the
input that goes along with bringing the
data in
more pre-processing with image to array
loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of work you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is is it does everything for you you're
not doing a lot of pre-processing you're
letting the software do the
pre-processing
and we're going to be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category 0 1 doesn't really
mean anything it's like true false
label binarizer the same thing
we're changing our labels around and
then there's our train test split
classification report
our our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit setup in tensorflow above
the path this is part of
opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in
this software especially the second
piece when we reload up the data and
hook it up to a video camera we're going
to do that on this round
um but this is part of the opencv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced
but the im utilities has to do with how
do you rotate pictures around and stuff
like that
and resize them and then the matplot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good we're
doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
initialize
we have the learning rate number of
epochs to train for and the batch size
and if you remember correctly we talked
about the learning rate uh to the
negative 4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that
variation depending on what you're doing
and how many epochs and they kind of
play with the epics
the epics is how many times we're going
to go through all the data
now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20 and 20 works
great the reason i have it for two is it
takes a long time to process
one of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though i'm on an eight
core processor uh with 16 dedicated
threads only one thread is running on
this no matter what so it doesn't matter
uh so it takes a lot longer to run even
though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
and then you have pictures with mess
they're just images of people with mass
on their face
uh and then we have the opposite let me
go back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of askew
because they tried to format them into
very similar uh setup on there so
they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross uh layers and importing
and dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
uh so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the
images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you it had
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we'll just create a
huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data at some
point
thankfully i have a 32 gig hard drive or
ram
even that
you could do with a lot less of that
probably under 16 or even 8 gigs would
easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we are going
to convert
the size of the image so it resizes all
the images that way our data is all
identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the one
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list we'll run that and
again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because
-10 to the end there we go
just so we can see where the other side
looks like we now have one that means
they have a mask one zero one zero so on
one being they have a mask and zero no
mask
and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
0 1
so 0
is
do they have a mask on 0 do they not
have a mask on one so this is the same
as what we saw up here without mask one
equals
um the second value is without mass so
with mass without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
uh
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual
linear value or regression values
they're not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our train x test x train y test y
train split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20
percent of it for testing
and the rest for
setting it up as far as training their
model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does augment mean well if i rotate
the data around and i zoom in i zoom out
i rotate it share it a little bit flip
it horizontally
fill mode as i do all these different
things to the data it
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples i have so if i
have all these perfect samples what
happens when we only have part of the
face or the face is tilted sideways or
all those little shifts cause a problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an augment
in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool thing and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
so you can better train your model and
so we go and run this and then we're
going to load
and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
i haven't run it myself because the guys
in the back did this
we take our base model and one of the
things we want to do is we want to do a
mobile net v2
and this what we this is a big thing
right here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row
so we want to make sure that that is not
the case
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the uh size of the pictures
and the weights for input shape
um so they'll switch things to defaults
to saying hey we're going to auto shape
some of this stuff for you you should be
aware that with this kind of imagery
we're already augmenting it by moving it
around and flipping it and doing all
kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pool size 77 head
model
head model flatten so we're flattening
the data
so this is all
processing and flattening the images and
the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
level in this processing it
and then we have our dents we've already
talked a little bit about a dense just
what you think about and then the head
model has a drop out
of 0.5
what we can do with a dropout
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model
it will use all the nodes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from performing so it's
really a cool feature in here they
discovered this a while back
we have another dense mode this time
we're using soft max activation
lots of different activation options
here softmax is a real popular one for a
lot of things
and so is the relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas
and why what their different uses are
and how they work when you first start
out you'll you'll use mostly the relu
and the softmax for a lot of them
just because they're some of the basic
setups it's a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers dot trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example but i
do this a lot when i'm working with
series and specifically in stock data i
wanted to iterate through the first set
of 30 data before it does anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics
and we go ahead and compile our loss is
going to be the binary cross entropy
which will have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model
so train the head of the network print
info training head run
now i skipped a little time because it
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're well it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so
anytime the train x and train y go in
there's some randomness going on there
and it's jiggling it around what's going
into our setup
of course we're batch sizing it so it's
going through whatever we set for the
batch values how many we process at a
time
and then we have the steps per epic
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our
test x and test y where we're sending
that in
and this again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is
our
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased
if you have a higher accuracy on your
testing
you know you've trained it and your
accuracy is higher on your actual test
data then something in there is probably
uh has a bias and it's over fitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epics again you could run this
through about 20
with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined model at the end
we're going to stop at 2 because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
these are predictions on our test x
to see what it thinks are going to be uh
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we'll go ahead and go
down here
and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
it's either 0 or 1 it's a
0 1 0 one so you have two outputs uh not
wearing uh wearing a mask not wearing a
mask and so we need to go ahead and take
that argument at the end and change
those predictions to a
zero or one coming out uh and then to
finish that off we want to go ahead and
let me just put this right in here and
do it all in one shot we want to show a
nicely formatted classification report
so we can see what that looks like on
here
and there we have it we have our
precision uh it's 97 with the mask
there's our f1 score support without a
mass 97 percent
um so that's pretty
high set up on there you know you three
people are going to sneak into the store
who are without a mask and
thinks they have a mask and there's
going to be three people with a mask
that's going to flag the person at the
front to go oh hey look at this person
you might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store
so there you have it and of course one
of the other cool things about this is
if someone's walking in to the store and
you take multiple pictures of them
um
you know this is just an it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're gonna this is just
cool i love doing this stuff uh so we're
gonna go ahead and take our model and
we're gonna save it
so model save mass detector.model we're
going to give it a name
we're going to save the format
in this case we're going to use the h5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved
so now i can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say i want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well i just
save the model they upload the model now
they can use it for whatever and then if
i get more information
and we start working with that
at some point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
real easy just to push that out to the
actual end user
uh here we have a nice graph you can see
the training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics
we only did the you know only shows just
the one epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the
scikit with sk learn neural networks
this is what they're talking about a
convergence
is our
loss and our accuracy come together and
also up here and this is why i'd run it
more than just two epochs as you can see
they still haven't converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new
python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
we have our
mobilenet v2 import pre-processing input
so we're still going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have our load model that's
where most of the stuff's going on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little opencv code at
you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out our numpy array our im
utilities which is part of
the opencv or cv2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we are going to go ahead and set
up on here
and then we're going to create
this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting uh so we're going to
detect and predict the mask we have
frame face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have a frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face and then set that up
so we know
what we're going to be processing
through our model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image frame
so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in literally
from my camera and we'll show you that
in a minute that little piece of code
that shoots that in here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape
uh so these is this is what's going on
here this is that model we just created
we're going to send that in there and
i'll show you in a second where that is
but it's going to be under face net and
then we go ahead and initialize our list
of faces the corresponding locations and
the list of predictions from our face
mask network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think um as far as looking for
different faces whatever the view of a
crowd of faces
um so we're looping through the
detections and the shapes going through
here
and probability associated with the
detection here's our confidence of
detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've set it remember zero to one so
0.5 would be our minimum confidence
probably is pretty good
[Music]
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an open cv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from simplylearn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
uh so we create a box around what's
gonna be hope is gonna be the face
extract the face roi convert it from bgr
to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order i don't know how many times i
forgot to check the order colors when
working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red
and we're going to resize it process it
frame it
face frame
setup again the face the cvt color we're
going to convert it
we're going to resize it
image to array pre-process the input
pin the face locate face start x dart y
and x
boy that was just a huge amount and i
skipped over a ton of it but the bottom
line is we're building a box around the
face
and that box because the open cv does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on it
and so that's what that's what all this
is doing on here and then finally we get
down to this where it says predictions
equals mass net dot predict faces batch
size 32.
uh so these different images where we're
guessing where the face is are then
going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk um
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously you're going to put
it in a different
path depending on where you have it or
however you want to do it and how you
saved it on the last one where we
trained it
then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals
cb2.dnn dot read net
prototext path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also
so this is pulling on all the different
pieces we need for our model
and then the next part
is we're going to create open up our
video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the open cv
the video set up
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
so we're going to go ahead and open up
our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos
is that when you start working with
images and videos it's all like right
there in front of you it's visual and
you can see what's going on
uh so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start
that means it's grabbing my main camera
i have hooked up
and then you know starting video you're
going to print it out
here's our video source equals 0 start
loop over the frames from the video
stream
oops a little redundancy there um let me
close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
from our visual
stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we return from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame
we're sending it the face net and the
mast net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location
predictions and then for our box
and predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
in predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label
no mask and create color if the label
equals mask l0225
and you know it's going to make a lot
more sense when i hit the run button
here
but we have the probability of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle in the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cv2 i am
show frame frame and then the key equals
cp2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much
so you're ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our
our model we've loaded it up into our
distributed
code here we've got it hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky headset on
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i'd
brought a mask into my office it's up at
the house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you could start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you have this really neat uh setup
saying hey do you have a mask on when
you enter a store or a public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the open cv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross
saving the model uploading the model and
then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see that the model
works we actually have this working
model that hooks into
the video camera
which is just pretty cool a lot of fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic uh
demo up above for just pulling in across
and then we went into a cross model
where we pulled in data to see whether
someone was wearing a mask or not so
very useful in today's world as far as a
fully running application welcome to the
rnn tutorial that's the recurrent neural
network so we talk about a feed forward
neural network in a feed forward neural
network information flows only in the
forward direction from the input nodes
through the hidden layers if any into
the output nodes there are no cycles or
loops in the network and so you can see
here we have our input layer i was
talking about how it just goes straight
forward into the hidden layers so each
one of those connects and then connects
to the next hidden layer connects to the
output layer and of course we have a
nice simplified version where it has a
predicted output the refer to the input
is x a lot of times and the output as y
decisions are based on current input no
memory about the past no future scope
why recurrent neural network issues in
feed forward neural network so one of
the biggest issues is because it doesn't
have a scope of memory or time a
feed-forward neural network doesn't know
how to handle sequential data it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever i put as an output
is going to affect the next one um a
feed forward doesn't look at any of that
it just looks at this is what's coming
in and it cannot memorize previous
inputs so it doesn't have that list of
inputs coming in solution to feed
forward neural network you'll see here
where it says recurrent neural network
and we have our x on the bottom going to
h going to y that's your feed forward
but right in the middle it has a value c
so there's a whole another process so
it's memorizing what's going on in the
hidden layers and the hidden layers as
they produce data feed into the next one
so your hidden layer might have an
output that goes off to y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the rnn image captioning
rnn is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair that's
very tough i mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using rnn and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the new york stock
exchange in the u.s produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades and fluctuations by
the second
it's like three terabytes a day of data
so we're going to look at one stock just
analyzing one stock is really tricky in
here we'll give you a little jump on
that so that's exciting but don't expect
to get rich off of it immediately
another application of the rnn is
natural language processing text mining
and sentiment analysis can be carried
out using rnn for natural language
processing and you can see right here
the term natural language processing
when you stream those three words
together is very different than ice if i
said processing language natural leap so
the time series is very important when
we're analyzing sentiments it can change
the whole value of a sentence just by
switching the words around or if you're
just counting the words you may get one
sentiment where if you actually look at
the order they're in you get a
completely different sentiment when it
rains look for rainbows when it's dark
look for stars both of these are
positive sentiments and they're based
upon the order of which the sentence is
going in machine translation given an
input in one language rnn can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output i myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking english you would say
big cat and if you're speaking spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in english and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in english in this
little diagram i guess that's denoted by
the flags i have a flag i own it no um
but they're speaking in english and it's
getting translated into
chinese italian french german and
spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged i can now travel into worlds
i would never think of because i can
have something translate my english back
and forth readily and i'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down i'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our x comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into y and they
usually draw very simplified x to h with
c as a loop a to y where a b and c are
the perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the h and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the c goes in and then the x
goes in so the x is going upward bound
and c is going to the right a is going
out and c is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn
cn and then we have y out and c out and
c is based on ht minus one so our value
is based on the y and the h value are
connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because h can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of t equals a function of c where h of t
minus 1 that's the last h output and x
of t going in so it's the last output of
h combined with the new input of x where
h t is the new state fc is a function
with the parameters c that's a common
way of denoting it
h t minus 1 is the old state coming out
and then x of t is an input vector
at time of step t
well we need to cover types of recurrent
neural networks and so the first one is
the most common one which is a
one-to-one single output
one-to-one neural network is usually
known as a vanilla neural network used
for regular machine learning problems
why because vanilla is usually
considered kind of a just a real basic
flavor but because it's very basic a lot
of times they'll call it the vanilla
neural network which is not the common
term but it is kind of a slang term
people will know what you're talking
about usually if you say that then we
run one to many so you have a single
input and you might have a multiple
outputs in this case uh image captioning
as we looked at earlier where we have
not just looking at it as a dog but a
dog catching a ball in the air and then
you have many to one network takes in a
sequence of inputs examples sentiment
analysis where a given sentence can be
classified as expressing positive or
negative sentiments and we looked at
that as we were discussing if it rains
look for a rainbow so positive sentiment
where rain might be a negative sentiment
if you were just adding up the words in
there and then the course if you're
going to do a one-to-one mini to one one
to many there's many to many networks
takes in a sequence of inputs and
generates a sequence of outputs example
machine translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in english and then
going out in all the different languages
you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations you know
if you're a translator you realize just
how difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called the vanishing gradient
problem while training an rnn your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this makes training difficult when
the slope is too small the problem is
known as vanishing gradient and you'll
see here they have a nice
image loss of information through time
so if you're pushing not enough
information forward that information is
lost and then when you go to train it
you start losing the third word in the
sentence or something like that or it
doesn't quite follow the full logic of
what you're working on exploding
gradient problem oh this is one that
runs into everybody when you're working
with this particular neural network when
the slope tends to grow exponentially
instead of decaying this problem is
called exploding gradient issues in
ingredient problem long training time
poor performance bad accuracy and i'll
add one more in there uh your computer
if you're on a lower end computer
testing out a model will lock up and
give you the memory error explaining
gradient problem consider the following
two examples to understand what should
be the next word in the sequence
the person who took my bike and blank a
thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the rnn must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief as singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the rnn must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the air to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's sending
we can lower that particular set of
layers make those smaller and finally is
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation function so we'll
look at that just minimally there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the lstms and we can make
adjustments to that so just like we can
clip the gradient as it comes out we can
also
expand on that we can increase the
memory network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's
setup is what they call long-term
dependencies suppose we try to predict
the last word in the text the clouds are
in the and you probably said sky here we
do not need any further context it's
pretty clear that the last word is going
to be sky suppose we try to predict the
last word in the text i have been
staying in spain for the last 10 years i
can speak fluent maybe you said
portuguese or french no he probably said
spanish the word we predict will depend
on the previous few words in context
here we need the context of spain to
predict the last word in the text it's
possible that the gap between the
relevant information and the point where
it is needed to become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior all recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent h
layer lstms's
also have a chain like structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior ls
tmss also have a chain like structure
but the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs get in here i
want you to note that you have x of t
minus one coming in you have x of t
coming in and you have x a t plus one
and you have h of t minus one and h of t
coming in and h of t plus 1 going out
and of course on the other side is the
output a
in the middle we have our tangent h but
it occurs in two different places so not
only when we're computing the x at t
plus one are we getting the tangent h
from x to t but we're also getting that
value coming in from the x of t minus
one so the short of it is as you look at
these layers not only does it does the
propagate through the first layer goes
into the second layer back into itself
but it's also going into the third layer
so now we're kind of stacking those up
and this can get very complicated as you
grow that in size it also grows in
memory too and in the amount of
resources it takes but it's a very
powerful tool to help us address the
problem of complicated long sequential
information coming in like we were just
looking at in the sentence and when
we're looking at our long short term
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing sensing in the lstms that we
look at the first one is we want to
forget irrelevant parts of the previous
state you know a lot of times like you
know is as in a unless we're trying to
look at whether it's a plural noun or
not they don't really play a huge part
in the language so we want to get rid of
them then selectively update cell state
values so we only want to update the
cell state values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like
so step one decides how much of the past
it should remember first step in the
lstm is to decide which information to
be omitted in from the cell in that
particular time step it is decided by
the sigmoid function it looks at the
previous state h to t minus 1 and the
current input x t and computes the
function so you can see over here we
have a function of t
equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the h at t minus 1 and then
x a t plus of course you have a bias in
there with any of our neural networks so
we have a bias function so f of t equals
forget gate decides which information to
delete that is not important from the
previous time step considering an stm is
fed with the following inputs from the
previous and present time step alice is
good in physics john on the other hand
is good in chemistry so previous output
john plays football well he told me
yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's our current input
so as we look at this the first step is
the forget gate realizes there might be
a change in context after encountering
the first full stop compares with the
current input sentence of x a t so we're
looking at that full stop and then
compares it with the input of the new
sentence the next sentence talks about
john so the information on alice is
deleted okay that's important to know so
we have this input coming in and if
we're going to continue on with john
then that's going to be the primary
information we're looking at the
position of the subject is vacated and
is assigned to john and so in this one
we've seen that we've weeded out a whole
bunch of information and we're only
passing information on john since that's
now the new topic so step two is then to
decide how much should this unit add to
the current state in the second layer
there are two parts one is the sigmoid
function and the other is the tangent h
in the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through zero or one
tangent eight function gives a weightage
to the values which are passed deciding
their level of importance minus one to
one and you can see the two formulas
that come up the i of t equals the
sigmoid of the weight of i h of t minus
one x of t plus the bias of i and the c
of t equals the tangent of h of the
weight of c of h to t minus 1 x t plus
the bias of c so our i of t equals the
input gate determines which information
to let through based on its significance
in the current time step if this seems a
little complicated don't worry because a
lot of the programming is already done
when we get to the case study
understanding though that this is part
of the program is important when you're
trying to figure out these what to set
your settings at you should also note
when you're looking at this it should
have some semblance to your forward
propagation neural networks where we
have a value assigned to a weight plus a
bias very important steps than any of
the neural network layers whether we're
propagating into them the information
from one to the next or we're just doing
a straightforward neural network
propagation let's take a quick look at
this what it looks like from the human
standpoint as i step out of my suit
again consider the current input at x of
t john plays football well he told me
yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's our input input
gate analysis the important information
john plays football and he was a captain
of his college team is important he told
me over the phone yesterday is less
important hence it is forgotten this
process of adding some new information
can be done via the input gate now this
example is as a human form and we'll
look at training this stuff in just a
minute
but as a human being if i wanted to get
this information from a conversation
maybe it's a google voice listening in
on you or something like that um how do
we weed out the information that he was
talking to me on the phone yesterday
well i don't want to memorize that he
talked to me on the phone yesterday or
maybe that is important but in this case
it's not i want to know that he was the
captain of the football team i want to
know that he served i want to know that
john plays football and he was the
captain of the college football team
those are the two things that i want to
take away as a human being again we
measure a lot of this from the human
viewpoint and that's also how we try to
train them so we can understand these
neural networks finally we get to step
three decides what part of the current
cell state makes it to the output the
third step is to decide what will be our
output first we run a sigmoid layer
which decides what parts of the cell
state make it to the output then we put
the cell state through the tangent h to
push the values to be between -1 and 1
and multiply it by the output of the
sigmoid gate so when we talk about the
output of t we set that equal to the
sigmoid of the weight of zero of the h
of t minus one and back one step in time
by the x of t plus of course the bias
the h of t equals the outer t times the
tangent of the tangent h of c at t so
our o t equals the output gate allows
the passed in information to impact the
output in the current time step let's
consider the example to predicting the
next word in the sentence john played
tremendously well against the opponent
and one for his team for his
contributions brave blank was awarded
player of the match there could be a lot
of choices for the empty space current
input brave is an adjective adjectives
describe a noun john could be the best
output after brave thumbs up for john
awarded player of the match and if he
were to pull just the nouns out of the
sentence team doesn't look right because
that's not really the subject we're
talking about contributions you know
brave contributions or brave teen brave
player brave match
so you look at this and you can start to
train this these this neural network so
starts looking at and goes oh no john is
what we're talking about so brave is an
adjective
john's going to be the best output and
we give john a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part the
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the lstm network based on the
stock price data between 2012 2016.
we're going to try to predict the stock
prices of 2017.
and this will be a narrow set of data
we're not going to do the whole stock
market it turns out that the new york
stock exchange generates roughly three
terabytes of data per day that's all the
different trades up and down of all the
different stocks going on and each
individual one
second to second or nanosecond to
nanosecond but we're going to limit that
to just some very basic fundamental
information so don't think you're going
to get rich off this today but you at
least you can give an eye you can give a
step forward in how to start processing
something like stock prices a very valid
use for machine learning in today's
markets
use case implementation of lstm let's
dive in we're going to import our
libraries we're going to import the
training set and get the scaling going
now if you watch any of our other
tutorials a lot of these pieces just
start to look very familiar because it's
very similar setup let's take a look at
that and just reminder we're going to be
using anaconda the jupiter notebook so
here i have my anaconda navigator when
we go under environments i've actually
set up a cross python 36 i'm in python36
and nice thing about anaconda especially
the newer version i remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of python in different
environments anaconda now has a nice
interface
and i have this installed both on a
ubuntu linux machine and on windows so
it works fine on there you can go in
here and open a terminal window and then
in here once you're in the terminal
window this is where you're going to
start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre-installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python id you like i'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine i have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with cross under
tensorflow we go back to home i've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment i've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now i've already in my jupiter
notebook
have set up a lot of stuff so that we're
ready to go kind of like martha
stewart's in the old cooking show so we
want to make sure we have all our tools
for you so you're not waiting for them
to load and if we go up here to where it
says new you can see where you can
create a new python 3. that's what we
did here underneath the setup so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and i'm actually renamed this if you
go under file you can rename it we've
i'm calling it rnn stock and let's just
take a look and start diving into the
code let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine let's start putting
that code in there and seeing what those
imports and uploading everything looks
like now first half is kind of boring
when we hit the run button because we're
going to be importing numpy as np that's
the number python which is your numpy
array and the matplot library because
we're going to do some plotting at the
end
and our pandas for our data set our
pandas is pd and when i hit run it
really doesn't do anything except for
load those modules just a quick note let
me just do a quick draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if i was to divide this
up oops i'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
in fact depending on what your system is
since we're using keras i put an overlap
here uh but you'll find that almost
maybe even half of the code we do is all
about the data prep and the reason i
overlapped this with cross let me just
put that down because that's what we're
working in uh is because cross has like
their own preset stuff so it's already
pre-built in which is really nice so
there's a couple steps a lot of times
that are in the kara setup we'll take a
look at that to see what comes up in our
code as we go through and look at stock
and the last part is to evaluate and if
you're working with
shareholders or
classroom whatever it is you're working
with the evaluate is the next biggest
piece
so the actual code here crossed is a
little bit more but when you're working
with some of the other packages you
might have like three lines that might
be it all your stuff is in your
pre-processing and your data since cross
has is cutting edge and you load the
individual layers you'll see that
there's a few more lines here and
crosses a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times like i
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
and say hey this is what i did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the pd or pandas dot read csv and
it's a google googlestockpricetrain.csv
and so under this we have training set
equals dataset train dot ilocation and
we've kind of sorted out part of that so
what's going on here let's just take a
look at let's look at the actual file
and see what's going on there now if we
look at this
ignore all the extra files on this i
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take
20 of the data out so we can test it and
then we train the rest of it that's what
we use to create our neural network that
way we can find out how good it is uh
but let's go ahead and just take a look
and see what that looks like as far as
the file itself and i went ahead and
just opened this up in a basic word pad
and text editor just so we can take a
look at it certainly you can open up an
excel or any other kind of spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date uh
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock or the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from google that's why
we call it the google stock price
and this specifically is google this is
the google stock values from as you can
see here we started off at 1 3 2012.
so when we look at this first setup up
here
we have a data set train equals pd
underscore csv and if you noticed on the
original frame
let me just go back there
they had it set to home ubuntu downloads
google stock price train i went ahead
and changed that because we're in the
same file where i'm running the code so
i've saved this particular python code
and i don't need to go through any
special paths or have the full path on
there and then of course we want to take
out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using
our data set
and we're now in pandas
so pandas basically it looks like a
spreadsheet
and in this case we're going to do i
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns 1 and 2.
and if you remember here from our data
as we switch back on over columns we saw
we start with zero which is the date
and we're going to be looking at open
and high which would be one and two
we'll just label that right there so you
can see now
when you go back and do this you
certainly can extrapolate and do this on
all the columns
but for the example let's just limit a
little bit here so that we can focus on
just some
key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again i said the first half is
very boring whenever we hit the run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it we want to do
what they call feature scaling and in
here we're going to pull it up from the
sk learn or the sk kit pre-processing
import min max scaler and when you look
at this you got to remember that biases
in our data we want to get rid of that
so if you have something that's like a
really high value let's just draw a
quick graph
and i have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value one stock has a
value of a hundred and another stock has
a value of 5
you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the max
and 5 is going to be the min
and then everything else goes and then
we change this so we just squish it down
i like the word squish so it's between
one and zero so 100 equals one or one
equals a hundred and zero equals five
and you can just multiply it's usually
just a simple multiplication we're using
uh multiplication so it's going to be
minus 5 and then 100 divided or 95
divided by 1. so or whatever value is is
divided by 95.
and once we've actually created our
scale we've tolling is going to be from
zero to one we want to take our training
set and we're going to create a training
set scaled and we're going to use our
scalar sc we're going to fit we're going
to fit and transform the training set
so we can now use the sc this this
particular object will use it later on
our testing set because remember we have
to also scale that when we go to test
our model and see how it works and we'll
go ahead and click on the run again it's
not going to have any output yet because
we're just setting up all the variables
okay so we paste the data in here and
we're going to create the data structure
with the 60 time steps and output
first note we're running 60 time steps
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our x train and y train variables
we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for i in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there there's
nothing below the 60. so if we're going
to use 60 time steps we have to start at
point 60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our x train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between 0 and 1 and then as
i is equal to 60 this value is going to
be
60 minus 60 is 0. so this actually is
0 to i so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61
2 to 62 and so on and so on and if you
remember i said 0 to 60 that's incorrect
because it does not count remember it
starts at 0 so this is a count of 60. so
it's actually 59. important to remember
that as we're looking at this and then
the second part of this that we're
looking at so if you remember correctly
here we go we go from 0 to 59 of i and
then we have a comma a 0 right here and
so finally we're just going to look at
the open value now i know we did put it
in there for one to two
if you remember quickly it doesn't count
the second one so it's just the open
value we're looking at just open
and then finally we have y train dot
append training set i to zero and if you
remember correctly i2 or i comma zero if
you remember correctly this is zero to
59 so there's 60 values in it uh so we
do i down here this is number 60. so
we're going to do this is we're creating
an array and we have 0
to 59
and over here we have number 60 which is
going into the y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a
0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12
58 that's where this value here comes in
that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has uh which is filled
with arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded
one array which is just the value and
what we're looking at you want to think
about this as a time sequence uh here's
my open open open open open open what's
the next one in the series so we're
looking at the google stock and each
time it opens we want to know what the
next one zero through 59 what's 60 1
through 60 what's 61 2 through 62 what's
62 and so on and so on going up and then
once we've loaded those in our for loop
we go ahead and take x train and y train
equals
dot np np.arrayxtrain.npr y train we're
just converting this back into a numpy
array that way we can use all the cool
tools that we get with numpy array
including reshaping so if we take a look
and see what's going on here we're going
to take our x
train we're going to reshape it
well what the heck does reshape mean uh
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly
so many numbers by 60.
that's how wide it is
and so we're when you when you do x
train dot shape that gets one of the
shapes and you get um x train dot shape
of one gets the other shape and we're
just making sure the data is formatted
correctly and so you use this to pull
the fact that it's 60 by um
in this case where's that value
60 pi
1199 1258 minus 60 11.99 and we're
making sure that that is shaped
correctly so the data is grouped into
11 99 by 60 different arrays and then
the one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the end layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more
and then you get the leaf np dot reshape
comes from and using the existing shapes
to form it we'll go ahead and run this
piece of code again there's no real
output and then we'll import our
different cross modules that we need so
from cross models we're going to import
the sequential model dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our dents our lstm
which is what we're focusing on and our
drop out and we'll discuss these three
layers more in just a moment but you do
need the with the lstm you do need the
dropout and then the final layer will be
the dents but let's go ahead and run
this and they'll bring port our modules
and you'll see we get an error on here
and if you read it closer it's not
actually an error it's a warning what
does this warning mean these things come
up all the time when you're working with
such cutting edge modules that are
complete being updated all the time
we're not going to worry too much about
the warning all it's saying is that the
h5py
module which is part of cross is going
to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5 pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the h5 pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and i said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean i meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the rnn
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the dropout lstm then dropout
lstm then dropout what the heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the rnn regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
dropout regularization and right there
should be the q dropout regularization
and if we go back here and remember our
exploding gradient well that's what
we're talking about the dropout drops
out unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amounts of data through
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and add this in i'll
go ahead and run this and we had three
of them so let me go ahead and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go ahead and put two more in i
mean i said one more end but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time i run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50. the units is the positive integer
and it's the dimensionality of the
output space this is what's going out
into the next layer so we might have 60
coming in but we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so we want to keep that
true and then you have to tell it what
shape it's in well we already know the
shape by just going in here and looking
at x train shape so input shape equals
the x train shape of one comma one makes
it really easy you don't have to
remember all the numbers that put in 60
or whatever else is in there you just
let it tell the regressor what model to
use and so we follow our stm with a
dropout layer now understanding the
dropout layer is kind of exciting
because one of the things that happens
is we can over train our network that
means that our neural network will
memorize such specific data that it has
trouble predicting anything that's not
in that specific realm to fix for that
each time we run through the training
mode we're going to take point two or
twenty percent of our neurons and just
turn them off so we're only gonna train
on the other ones and it's going to be
random that way each time we pass
through this we don't over train these
nodes come back in in the next training
cycle we randomly pick a different 20.
and finally they see a big difference as
we go from the first to the second and
third and fourth the first thing is we
don't have to input the shape because
the shapes already the output units is
50 here this item the next step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets that and
says so 50 is coming out from our last
layer that's coming up you know goes
into the regressor and of course we have
our dropout and that's what's coming
into this one and so on and so on and so
the next three layers we don't have to
let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had uh lstm
dropout and dents dense just says we're
going to bring this all down into one
output instead of putting out a sequence
we just know i want to know the answer
at this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we brought
in our different modules we formatted
the data for training it we set it up
you know we have our y x train and our y
train we have our source of data and the
answers where we know so far that we're
going to put in there we've reshaped
that we've come in and built our cross
we've imported our different layers and
we have in here if you look we have what
uh five total layers now cross is a
little different than a lot of other
systems a lot of other systems put this
all in one line and do it automatic but
they don't give you the options of how
those layers interface and they don't
give you the options of how the data
comes in cross is cutting edge for this
reason so even though there's a lot of
extra steps in building the model this
has a huge impact on the output and what
we can do with this these new models
from keras so we brought in our dents we
have our full model put together a
regressor so we need to go ahead and
compile it and then we're going to go
ahead and fit the data we're going to
compile the pieces so they all come
together and then we're going to run our
training data on there and actually
recreate our regressor so it's ready to
be used so let's go ahead and compile
that and i can go ahead and run that and
if you've been looking at any of our
other tutorials on neural networks
you'll see we're going to use the
optimizer atom atom is optimized for big
data there's a couple other optimizers
out there beyond the scope of this
tutorial but certainly atom will work
pretty good for this and loss equals
mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error we're
going to use the mean squared value for
our error and the atom optimizer for its
differential equations you don't have to
know the math behind them but certainly
it helps to know what they're doing and
where they fit into the bigger models
and then finally we're going to do our
fit fitting the rn into the training set
we have the regressor.fit x train y
train epochs and batch size so we know
where this is this is our data coming in
for the x train our y train is the
answer we're looking for of our data our
sequential input epics is how many times
we're going to go over the whole data
set we created a whole data set of x
trains so this is each each of those
rows which includes a time sequence of
60. and bad size another one of those
things where cross really shines is if
you were pulling the save from a large
file instead of trying to load it all
into ram it can now pick smaller batches
up and load those indirectly we're not
worried about pulling them off a file
today because this isn't big enough to
cause a computer too much of a problem
to run not too straining on the
resources but as we run this you can
imagine what happened if i was doing a
lot more than just one column in one set
of stock in this case google stock
imagine if i was doing this across all
the stocks and i had instead of just the
open i had open close high low and you
can actually find yourself with about 13
different variables times 60 because
there's a time sequence suddenly you
find yourself with a gig of memory
you're loading into your ram which will
just completely you know if it's just if
you're not on multiple computers or
cluster you can start running into
resource problems but for this we don't
have to worry about that so let's go
ahead and run this and this will
actually take a little bit on my
computer it's an older laptop and give a
second to kick in there there we go all
right so we have epic so this is going
to tell me it's running the first run
through all the data and as it's going
through it's batching them in 32 pieces
so 32 lines each time and there's 1198 i
think i said 11.99 earlier but it's 1198
is off by one and each one of these is
13 seconds so you can imagine this is
roughly 20 to 30 minutes run time on
this computer like i said it's an older
laptop running at 0.9 gigahertz on a
dual processor and that's fine what
we'll do is i'll go ahead and stop go
get a drink of coffee and come back and
let's see what happens at the end and
where this takes us and like any good
cooking show
i've kind of gotten my latte i also have
some other stuff running in the
background so you'll see these numbers
jumped up to like 19 seconds 15 seconds
but you can scroll through and you can
see we've run it through 100 steps or
100 epics so the question is what does
all this mean one of the first things
you'll notice is that our loss is over
here it kind of stopped at 0.0014 but
you can see it kind of goes down until
we hit about 0.014 three times in a row
so we guessed our epic pretty close
since our losses remain the same on
there so to find out we're looking at
we're going to go ahead and load up our
test data the test data that we didn't
process yet and a real stock price data
set test eye location this is the same
thing we did when we prepped the data in
the first place so let's go ahead and go
through this code and we can see we've
labeled it part three making the
predictions and visualizing the results
so the first thing we need to do is go
ahead and read the data in from our test
csv you see i've changed the path on it
for my computer and then we'll call it
the real stock price and again we're
doing just the one column here and the
values from i location so it's all the
rows and just the values from these that
one location that's the open stock open
let's go ahead and run that so that's
loaded in there and then let's go ahead
and create we have our inputs we're
going to create inputs here and this
should all look familiar because this is
the same thing we did before we're going
to take our data set total we're going
to do a little panda concat from the
datastate train now remember the end of
the dataset train is part of the data
going in and let's just visualize that
just a little bit here's our train data
let me just put tr for train and it went
up to this value here but each one of
these values generated a bunch of
columns it was 60 across and this value
here equals this one and this value here
equals this one and this value here
equals this one and so we need these top
60 to go into our new data so to find
out what we're looking at we're going to
go ahead and load up our test data the
test data that we didn't process yet and
a real stock price data set test eye
location this is the same thing we did
it when we prep the data in the first
place so let's go ahead and go through
this code and we can see we've labeled
it uh part three making the predictions
and visualizing the results so the first
thing that we need to do is go ahead and
read the data in from our test csv you
see i've changed the path on it for my
computer and then we'll call it the real
stock price and again we're doing just
the one column here and the values from
i location so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open stock open let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and create
we have our inputs we're going to create
inputs here and this should all look
familiar because this is the same thing
we did before we're going to take our
data set total we're going to do a
little panda concat from the datastate
train now remember the end of the data
set train is part of the data going in
and let's just visualize that just a
little bit here's our train data let me
just put tr for train and it went up to
this value here but each one of these
values generated a bunch of columns it
was 60 across and this value here equals
this one and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and so we need these top 60 to go into
our new data because that's part of the
next data or it's actually the top 59 so
that's what this first setup is over
here is we're going in we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're going
to load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test test location so
we're just looking at that first column
the open price and then our data set
total we're going to take pandas and
we're going to concat and we're going to
take our data set train for the open and
our dataset test open and this is one
way you can reference these columns
we've referenced them a couple different
ways we've referenced them up here with
the one two but we know it's labeled as
a panda set as open so pandas is great
that way lots of versatility there and
we'll go ahead and go back up here and
run this there we go and you'll notice
this is the same as what we did before
we have our open data set where pended
our two different or concatenated our
two data sets together we have our
inputs equals data set total length data
set total minus length and data set
minus test minus 60 values so we're
going to run this over all of them and
you'll see why this works because
normally when you're running your test
set versus your training set you run
them completely separate but when we
graph this you'll see that we're just
going to be we'll be looking at the part
that we didn't train it with to see how
well it graphs and we have our inputs
equals inputs dot uh reshapes or
reshaping like we did before we're
transforming our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between zero
and one and uh finally we want to go
ahead and take our x test and we're
going to create that x test and for i in
range 60 to 80. so here's our x test and
we're appending our inputs i to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and i comma 0 on the
other side so it's just the first column
which is our open column and once again
we take our x test we convert it to a
numpy array we do the same reshape we
did before and then we get down to the
final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor dot predicts x test so
we're predicting all the stock including
both the training and the testing model
here and then we want to take this
prediction and we want to inverse the
transform so remember we put them
between 0 and 1. well that's not going
to mean very much to me to look at a
float number between zero and one i want
the dollar amount so i want to know what
the cash value is and we'll go ahead and
run this and you'll see it runs much
quicker than the training that's what's
so wonderful about these neural networks
once you put them together it takes just
a second to run the same neural network
that took us what a half hour to train
add and plot the data we're going to
plot what we think it's going to be and
we're going to plot it against the real
data what the google stock actually did
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that in code and let's uh pull this code
up so we have our plt that's our oh if
you remember from the very beginning let
me just go back up to the top we have
our matplot library.piplot as plt that's
where that comes in and we come down
here we're going to plot let me get my
drawing thing out again we're going to
go ahead and plt is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always threw me when i'm doing
graphs in python because i always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case plt is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done html5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title
because it's always nice to give a title
to your graph especially if you're going
to present this to somebody you know to
your shareholders in the office and the
x label is going to be time because it's
a time series and we didn't actually put
the actual date and times on here but
that's fine we just know they're
incremented by time and then of course
the y label is the actual stock price
plt.legend tells us to build the legend
on here so that the color red and real
google stock price show up on there and
then the plot shows us that actual graph
so let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like and you can see
here we have a nice graph and let's talk
just a little bit about this graph
before we wrap it up here's our legend i
was telling you about that's why we have
the legend to show the prices we have
our title and everything and you'll
notice on the bottom we have a time
sequence we didn't put the actual time
in here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and
plotted the x since we know what the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know that it's only the last
piece of data that we're looking at so
last piece of data which in somewhere
probably around here on the graph i
think it's like about 20 of the data
probably less than that we have the
google price and the google price has
this little up jump and then down and
you'll see that the actual google
instead of a turn down here just didn't
go up as high and didn't go
down so our prediction has the same
pattern but the overall value is pretty
far off as far as um stock but then
again we're only looking at one column
we're only looking at the open price
we're not looking at how many volumes
were traded like i was pointing out
earlier we talk about stock just right
off the bat there's six columns there's
open high low close volume then there's
weather i mean volume shares then
there's the adjusted open adjusted high
adjusted low adjusted close they have a
special formula to predict exactly what
it would really be worth based on the
value of the stock and then from there
there's all kinds of other stuff you can
put in here so we're only looking at one
small aspect the opening price of the
stock and as you can see here we did a
pretty good job this curve follows the
curve pretty well it has like a little
jumps on it bins they don't quite match
up so this bin here does not quite match
up with that bin there but it's pretty
darn close we have the basic shape of it
and the prediction isn't too far off and
you can imagine that as we add more data
in and look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if i was running it across all
those different variables it might take
a little bit longer to train the data
not so good for doing a quick tutorial
like this we'll talk about interview
questions for
machine learning now this video will
probably help you when you're attending
interviews or machine learning positions
and the attempt here is to probably
consolidate 30 most commonly asked
questions and to help you in answering
these questions we tried our best to
give you the best possible answers but
of course what is more important here is
rather than the theoretical
knowledge you need to kind of add to the
answers or supplement your answers with
your own experience so the responses
that we put here are a bit more generic
in nature so that if there are some
concepts that you are not clear this
video will help you in kind of getting
those concepts cleared up as well but
what is more important is that you need
to supplement these responses with your
own practical experience okay so with
that let's get started so one of the
first questions that you may face is
what are the different types of machine
learning now what is the best way to
respond to this there are three types of
machine learning if you read any
material you will always be told there
are three types of machine learning but
what is important is you would probably
be better off emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of machine
learning which is supervised and
unsupervised and then there is a third
type which is reinforcement learn so
supervised learning is where
you have some historical data and then
you feed that data to your model to
learn now you need to be aware of a
keyword that they will be looking for
which is labeled data right so if you
just say past data or historical data
the impact may not be so much you need
to emphasize on labeled data so what is
label data basically let's say if you
are trying to do train your model for
classification you need to be aware of
for your existing data which class each
of the observations belong to right so
that is what is labeling so it is
nothing but a fancy name you must be
already aware but just make it a point
to throw in that keyword
labeled so that will have the right
impact okay so that is what is
supervised learning when you have
existing labeled data which you then use
to train your model that is known as
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning is when you don't have this
label data so you have data it is not
labeled so the system has to figure out
a way to do some analysis on this okay
so that is unsupervised learning and you
can then add a few things like what are
the ways of performing uh supervised
learning and unsupervised learning and
what are some of the techniques so
supervised learning we perform or we do
regression and classification and
unsupervised learning uh we do
clustering and clustering can be of
different types similarly regression can
be of different types but you don't have
to probably elaborate so much if they
are asking
for just the different types you can
just mention these and just at a very
high level but if they want you to
elaborate give examples then of course i
think there is a different question for
that we will see that later then the
third so we have supervised then we have
unsupervised and then reinforcement you
need to provide a little bit of
information around that as well because
it is sometimes a little difficult to
come up with a good definition for
reinforcement learning so you may have
to little bit elaborate on how
reinforcement learning works right so
reinforcement learning works in in such
a way that it basically has two parts to
it one is the agent and the environment
and the agent basically is working
inside of this environment and it is
given a target that it has to achieve
and
every time it is moving in the direction
of the target so the agent basically has
to take some action and every time it
takes an action which is moving the
agent towards the target right towards a
goal a target is nothing but a goal okay
then it is rewarded and every time it is
going in a direction where it is away
from the goal then it is punished so
that is the way you can
explain
and
this is used primarily or very very
impactful for teaching the system to
learn games and so on examples of this
are basically used in alphago you can
throw that as an example where alphacore
used reinforcement learning to actually
learn to play the game of go and finally
it defeated the co-world champion all
right this much of information that
would be good enough okay then there
could be a question on overfitting uh so
the question could be what is
overfitting and how can you avoid it so
what is overfitting so let's first try
to understand the concept because
sometimes overfitting may be a little
difficult to understand overfitting is a
situation where the model has kind of
memorized the data so this is an
equivalent of memorizing the data so we
can draw an analogy so that it becomes
easy to explain this now let's say
you're teaching a child about
recognizing some fruits or something
like that okay and you're teaching this
child about recognizing let's say three
fruits apples oranges and pineapples
okay so this is a small child and for
the first time you're teaching the child
to recognize fruits then so what will
happen so this is very much like that is
your training data set so what you will
do is you will take a basket of fruits
which consists of apples oranges and
pineapples
and
you take this basket to this child and
there may be let's say hundreds of these
fruits so you take this basket to this
child and keep showing each of this root
and then first time obviously the child
will not know what it is so you show an
apple and you say hey this is apple then
you show maybe an orange and say this is
orange and so on and so forth and then
again you keep repeating that right so
till that basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
then the process what has happened the
child has pretty much memorized these so
even before you finish that basket right
by the time you are halfway through the
child has learned about recognizing the
apple orange and pineapple now what will
happen after halfway through initially
you remember it made mistakes in
recognizing but halfway through now it
has learned so every time you show a
fruit it will exactly 100 accurately it
will identify it will say the child will
say this is an apple this is an orange
and if you show a pineapple it will say
this is a pineapple right so that means
it has kind of memorized this data now
let's say you bring another basket of
fruits and it will have a mix of maybe
apples which were already there in the
previous set but it will also have in
addition to apple it will probably have
a banana or maybe another fruit like a
jackfruit right so this is an equivalent
of your test data set which the child
has not seen before some parts of it it
probably has seen like the apples it has
seen but this banana and jackfruit it
has not seen so then what will happen in
the first round which is an equivalent
of your training data set towards the
end it has 100 it was telling you what
the fruits are right apple was
accurately recognized orange was
accurately recognized and pineapples
were accurately recognized right so that
is like 100 accuracy but now when you
get another a fresh set which we're not
part of the original one what will
happen all the apples maybe it will be
able to recognize correctly but all the
others like the jackfruit or the banana
will not be recognized by the child
right so this is an analogy this is an
equivalent of overfitting so what has
happened during the training process it
is able to recognize or reach 100
accuracy maybe very high accuracy okay
and we call that as very low loss right
so that is the technical term so the
loss is pretty much zero and accuracy is
pretty much hundred percent whereas when
you use testing there will be a huge
error which means the loss will be
pretty high and therefore the accuracy
will be also low okay this is known as
overfitting this is basically a process
where training is done training
processes it goes very well almost
reaching 100 accuracy but while testing
it really drops down now how can you
avoid it so that is the extension of
this question there are multiple ways of
avoiding overfitting there are
techniques like what you call
regularization that is the most common
technique that is used for
avoiding overfitting and within
regularization there can be a few other
subtypes like drop out in case of neural
networks and a few other examples but i
think if you give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like trick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training
certainty set in machine learning model
and how is the split done so the
question can be like that so in machine
learning when we are trying to train the
model so we have a three-step process we
train the model and then we test the
model and then once we are satisfied
with the test only then we deploy the
model so what happens in the train and
test is that you remember the labeled
data so let's say you have 1000 records
with labeling information now one way of
doing it is you use all the thousand
records for training and then maybe
right which means that you have exposed
all these thousand records during the
training process and then you take a
small set of the same data and then you
say okay i will test it with this okay
and then you probably what will happen
you may get some good results all right
but there is a flaw there what is the
flaw this is very similar to human
beings it is like you are showing this
model the entire data as a part of
training okay so obviously it has become
familiar with the entire data so when
you are taking a part of that again and
you are saying that i want to test it
obviously you will get good results so
that is not a very accurate way of
testing so that is the reason what we do
is we have the label data of this
thousand records or whatever we set
aside before starting the training
process we set aside a portion of the
data and we call that test set and the
remaining we call as training set and we
use only this for training our model now
the training process remember is not
just about passing one round of this
data set so let's say now your training
set has 800 records it is not just one
time you pass this 800 records what you
normally do is you actually as a part of
the training you may pass this data
through the model multiple times so this
thousand records may go through the
model maybe 10 15 20 times till the
training is perfect till the accuracy is
high till the errors are minimized okay
now so which is fine which means that
your that is what is known as the model
has seen your data and gets familiar
with your data and now when you bring
your test data what will happen is this
is like some new data because that is
where the real test is now you have
trained the model and now you are
testing the model with some data which
is kind of new that is like a situation
like like a realistic situation because
when the model is deployed that is what
will happen it will receive some new
data not the data that it has already
seen right so this is a realistic test
so you put some new data so this data
which you have set aside is for the
model it is new and if it is able to
accurately predict the values that means
your training has worked okay the model
got trained properly but let's say while
you're testing this with this test data
you're getting lot of errors that means
you need to probably either change your
model or retrain with more data and
things like that now coming back to the
question of how do you split this what
should be the ratio there is no fixed uh
number again this is like individual
preferences some people split it into 50
50 50 test and 50 training some people
prefer to have a larger amount for
training and a smaller amount for tests
so they can go by either 60 40 or 70 30
or some people even go with some odd
numbers like 65 35 are
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something that the
ratio has to be this you can go by your
individual preferences all right then
you may have questions around data
handling data manipulation
or what you call data management or
preparation so these are all some
questions around that area there is
again no one answer one single good
answer to this it really varies from
situation to situation and depending on
what exactly is the problem what kind of
data it is how critical it is what kind
of data is missing and what is the type
of corruption so the whole lot of things
which is a very generic question and
therefore you need to be little careful
about responding to this as well so
probably have to illustrate this again
if you have experience in doing this
kind of work in handling data you can
illustrate with example saying that i
was on one project where i received this
kind of data these were the columns
where data was not filled or these were
this many rows where the data was
missing that would be in fact a perfect
way to respond to this question but if
you don't have that obviously you have
to provide some good answer i think it
really depends on what exactly the
situation is and there are multiple ways
of handling the missing data or corrupt
data now let's take a few examples now
let's say you have data where some
values in some of the columns are
missing and you have pretty much half of
your data having these missing values in
terms of number of rows okay that could
be one situation another situation could
be that you have records or data missing
but
when you do some initial calculation how
many records are correct or how many
rows or observations as we call it has
this missing data let's assume it is
very minimal like 10 percent okay now
between these two cases how do we so
let's assume that this is not a mission
critical situation and in order to fix
this 10 percent of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also time and
money right so
it is not so mission critical and it is
okay to let's say get rid of these
records so obviously one of the easiest
ways of handling the data part or
missing data is remove those records or
remove those observations from your
analysis so that is the easiest way to
do but then the downside is as i said in
as in the first case if let's say 50 of
your data is like that because some
column or the other is missing so it is
not like every in every place in every
row the same column is missing but you
have in maybe 10 percent of the records
column one is missing and another ten
percent column two is missing another
ten percent column three is missing so
on and so forth so it adds up to maybe
half of your data set so you cannot
completely remove half of your data set
then the whole purpose is lost okay so
then how do you handle then you need to
come up with ways of filling up this
data with some meaningful value right
that is one way of handling so when we
say meaningful value what is that
meaningful value let's say for a
particular column you might want to take
a mean value for that column and fill
wherever the data is missing fill up
with that mean value so that when you're
doing the calculations your analysis is
not completely way off so you have
values which are not missing first of
all so your system will work number two
these values are not so completely out
of whack that your whole analysis goes
for a task right there may be situations
where if the missing values instead of
putting mean may be a good idea to fill
it up with the minimum value or with a
zero so or with the maximum value again
as i said there are so many
possibilities so there is no like one
correct answer for this you need to
basically talk around this and
illustrate with your experience as i
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
question okay so then the next question
can be how can you choose a classifier
based on a training set data size so
again this is one of those questions uh
where you probably do not have like a
one-size-fits-all answer first of all
you
may not let's say
decide your classifier based on the
training set size maybe not the best way
to decide the type of the classifier and
even if you have to there are probably
some thumb rules which we can use but
then again every time so in my opinion
the best way to respond to this question
is you need to try out few classifiers
irrespective of the size of the data and
you need to then decide on your
particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so
you will never be able to just by if
somebody defines a problem to you and
somebody even if you if they show the
data to you or tell you what is the data
or even the size of the data i don't
think there is a way to really say that
yes this is the classifier that will
work here no that's not the right way so
you need to still
you know test it out get the data try
out a couple of classifiers and then
only you will be in a position to decide
which classifier to use you try out
multiple classifiers see which one gives
the best accuracy and only then you can
decide then you can have a question
around confusion matrix so the question
can be explained confusion matrix right
so confusion matrix i think the best way
to explain it is by taking an example
and drawing like a small diagram
otherwise it can really become tricky so
my suggestion is to take a piece of pen
and paper and
explain it by drawing a small matrix and
confusion matrix is about to find out
this is used especially in
classification
learning process and when you get the
results and our model predicts the
results you compare it with the actual
value and try to find out what is the
accuracy okay so in this case let's say
this is an example of a confusion matrix
and
it is a binary matrix so you have the
actual values which is the labeled data
right and which is so you have how many
yes and how many no so you have that
efficient and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many know
right so the total actual values the
total yes is 12 plus 130 and they are
shown here and the actual value those
are 9 plus 3 12 okay so that is what
this information here is so this is
about the actual and this is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 plus 3 15 yes's and
no are one plus nine ten nose okay so
this is the way to look at this
confusion matrix okay and uh out of this
what is the meaning convey so there are
two or three things that needs to be
explained outright the first thing is
for a model to be accurate the values
across the diagonal should be high like
in this case right that is one number
two the total sum of these values is
equal to the total observations in the
test data set so in this case for
example you have 12 plus 3 15 plus 10 25
so that means we have 25 observations in
our test data set okay so these are the
two things you need to first explain
that the total sum in this matrix the
numbers is equal to the size of the test
data set and the diagonal values
indicate the accuracy so by just by
looking at it you can probably have a
idea about is this
an accurate model is the model being
accurate if they're all spread out
equally in all these four boxes that
means probably the accuracy is not very
good okay now how do you calculate the
accuracy itself right how do you
calculate the accuracy itself so it is a
very simple mathematical calculation you
take some of the diagonals right so in
this case it is 9 plus 12 21 and divide
it by the total so in this case what
will it be let me take a pen so your
your diagonal values is equal to if i
say d is equal to 12 plus 9 so that is
21 right and the total data set is equal
to right we just calculated it is 25 so
what is your accuracy it is 21 by your
accuracy is equal to 21 by 25 and this
turns out to be about 85
right so this is 85 so that is our
accuracy okay so this is the way you
need to explain draw diagram give an
example and maybe it may be a good idea
to be prepared with an example so that
it becomes easy for you don't have to
calculate those numbers on the fly right
so a couple of uh hints are that you
take some numbers which are with which
add up to 100 that is always a good idea
so you don't have to really do this
complex calculations so the total value
will be 100 and then diagonal values you
divide once you find the diagonal values
that is equal to your percentage okay
all right so
the next question can be a related
question about
false positive and false negative so
what is false positive and what is false
negative now once again the best way to
explain this is using a piece of paper
and pen otherwise it will be pretty
difficult to explain this so we use the
same example of the confusion matrix
and
we can explain that so a confusion
matrix looks somewhat like this and
when we just
yeah it looks somewhat like this and we
continue with the previous example where
this is the actual value this is the
predicted value and
in the actual value we have 12 plus 1 13
yes's and 3 plus 9 12 nose and the
predicted values there are 12 plus 3 15
yeses and
1 plus 9 10 nos okay now this particular
case which is the false positive what is
a false positive first of all the second
word which is positive okay is referring
to the predicted value so that means the
system has predicted it as a positive
but the real value so this is what the
false comes from but the real value is
not positive okay that is the way you
should understand this term false
positive or even false negative so false
positive so positive is what your system
has predicted so where is that system
predicted this is the one positive is
what yes so you basically consider this
row okay now if you consider this row so
this is this is all positive values this
entire row is positive values okay now
the false positive is the one which
where the value actual value is negative
predicted value is positive but the
actual value is negative so this is a
false positive right and here is a true
positive so the predicted value is
positive and the actual value is also
positive okay i hope this is making
sense now let's take a look at what is
false negative false negative so
negative is the second term that means
that is the predicted value that we need
to look for so which are the predicted
negative values this row corresponds to
predicted negative values all right so
this row corresponds to predicted
negative values and what they are asking
for false so this is the row for
predicted negative values and the actual
value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is a way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right 9 is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the
steps involved in the machine learning
process
or what are the three steps in the
process of developing a machine learning
model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model happens is like this so first of
all you try to understand the problem
and try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably decide
that there is one particular algorithm
which is more suitable usually it
happens through trial and error process
but at some point you will decide that
okay this is the model we are going to
use okay so in that case we have the
model algorithm and the model decided
and then you need to do the process of
training the model and testing the model
and this is where if it is supervised
learning you split your data the label
data into training data set and test
data set and you use the training data
set to train your model and then you use
the test data set to check the accuracy
whether it is working fine or not so you
test the model before you actually put
it into production right so once you
test the model you're satisfied it's
working fine then you go to the next
level which is putting it for production
and then in production obviously new
data will come and
the inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values whether it is
regression or classification now so this
can be an iterative process so it is not
a straightforward process where you do
the training through the testing and
then you move it to production now so
during the training and test process
there may be a situation where because
of either overfitting or things like
that the test doesn't go through which
means that you need to put that back
into the training process so that can be
an iterative process not only that even
if the training and test goes through
properly and you deploy the model in
production there can be a situation that
the data that actually comes the real
data that comes with that this model is
failing so in which case you may have to
once again go back to the drawing board
or initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will deteriorate so
that is again a recursive process so
once in a while you need to keep
checking whether the model is working
fine or not and if required you need to
tweak it and modify it and so on and so
forth so let net this is a continuous
process of
tweaking the model and testing it and
making sure it is up to date then you
might have question around deep learning
so because deep learning is now
associated with ai artificial
intelligence and so on so can be as
simple as what is deep learning so i
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and then obviously the
question would be then what is the
difference right so deep learning you
need to mention there are two key parts
that interviewer will be looking for
when you are defining deep learning so
first is of course deep learning is a
subset of machine learning so machine
learning is still the bigger let's say
scope and deep learning is one part of
it so then what exactly is the
difference deep learning is primarily
when we are implementing these our
algorithms or when we are using neural
networks for doing our training and
classification and regression and all
that right so when we use neural network
then it is considered as deep learning
and the term deep comes from the fact
that you can have several layers of
neural networks and these are called
deep neural networks and therefore the
term deep
deep learning the other difference
between machine learning and deep
learning which the interviewer may be
wanting to hear is that in case of
machine learning the feature engineering
is done manually what do we mean by
feature engineering basically when we
are trying to train our model we have
our training data right so we have our
training label data and
this data has several let's say if it is
a regular table it has several columns
now each of these columns actually has
information about a feature right so if
we are trying to predict the height
weight and so on and so forth so these
are all features of human beings let's
say we have census data and we have all
this so those are the features now there
may be probably 50 or 100 in some cases
there may be 100 such features now all
of them do not contribute to our model
right so we as a data scientist we have
to decide whether we should take all of
them all the features or we should throw
away some of them because again if we
take all of them number one of course
your accuracy will probably get affected
but also there is a computational part
so if you have so many features and then
you have so much data it becomes very
tricky so in case of machine learning we
manually take care of identifying the
features that do not contribute to the
learning process and thereby we
eliminate those features and so on right
so this is known as feature engineering
and in machine learning we do that
manually whereas in deep learning where
we use neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably
will add value to your response all
right so the next question is what is
the difference between or what are the
differences between machine learning and
deep learning so here this is a quick
comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
missions to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and
it needs only a small amount of data for
training and then works well on low end
system so you don't need large machines
and most features need to be identified
in advance and manually coded so
basically the feature engineering part
is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural
lines so that is the key differentiator
between machine learning and deep
learning and usually deep learning
involves a large amount of data and
therefore the training also requires
usually the training process requires
high-end machines because it needs a lot
of computing power and the machine
learning features are the or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end-to-end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of a question
then you might get a question around the
uses of machine learning or some real
life applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but
the meaning is how exactly is machine
learning used or actually supervised
machine learning it could be a very
specific question around supervised
decision learning so this is like give
examples of supervised machine learning
use of supervised machine learning in
modern business so that could be the
next question so there are quite a few
examples or quite a few use cases if you
will for supervised machine learning the
very common one is email spam detection
so you want to train your application or
your system to detect between spam and
non-spam so this is a very common
business application of supervised
machine learning so how does this work
the way it works is that you obviously
have historical data about of your
emails and they are categorized as spam
and not spam so that is what is the
labeled information and then you feed
this information or the all these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have label data you already have emails
which are tagged as spam or not spam and
then you use that to train your model
right so this is one example now there
are a few industry specific applications
for supervised machine learning one of
the very common ones is a healthcare
diagnostics in healthcare diagnostics
you have these images and you want to
train models to detect whether from a
particular image whether it can find out
if the person is sick or not whether a
person has cancer or not right so this
is a very good example of supervised
machine learning here the way it works
is that existing images it could be
x-ray images it'd be mri or any of these
images are available and they are tagged
saying that okay this x-ray image is
defective or the person has an illness
or it could be cancer whichever illness
right so it is tagged as defective or
clear or good image and defective
something like that so we come up with a
binary or it could be multi-class as
well saying that this is defective to 10
this is 25 and so on but let's keep it
simple you can give an example of just a
binary classification that would be good
enough so
you can say that in healthcare
diagnostics using image we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when new
image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so i think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
unsupervised then so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
part of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of the diagnostic images we
can just let's say take x-ray images now
there are actually millions of x-ray
images available all over the world but
the problem is they are not labeled so
their images are there but whether it is
effective or whether it is good that
information is not available along with
it right in a form that it can be used
by a machine which means that somebody
has to take a look at these images and
usually it should be like a doctor and
then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where
semi-supervised learning comes into play
so what happens is there is a large
amount of data maybe a part of it is
labeled then we try some techniques to
label the remaining part of the data so
that we get completely labeled data and
then we train our model so i know this
is a little long winding explanation but
unfortunately there is no
quick and easy definition for semi
supervised machine learning this is the
only way probably to explain this
concept
we may have another question
as
what are unsupervised machine learning
techniques or what are some of the
techniques used for performing
unsupervised machine learning so it can
be worded in different ways so how do we
answer this question so unsupervised
learning you can say that there are two
types clustering and association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is
clustering then association you can i
think the best way to explain
association is with an example in case
of association you try to find out how
the items are linked to each other so
for example if somebody bought
maybe a laptop the person has also
purchased a mouse so this is more in an
e-commerce scenario for example so you
can give this as an example so people
who are buying laptops are also buying
the mouse so that means there is an
association between laptops and mouse or
maybe people who are buying bread are
also buying butter so that is a
association that can be created so this
is unsupervised learning one of the
techniques okay all right then we have
very fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so
machine learning these are the two main
types of machine learning supervised and
unsized and in case of supervised and
again here probably the keyword that the
person may be wanting to hear is labeled
data very often people say we have
historical data and if we run it it is
supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot use it for supervised
learning so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
label okay so when we have labeled data
for training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have label data then we use unsupervised
learning and there are different
algorithms available to perform both of
these types of trainings so
there can be another question a little
bit more theoretical and conceptual in
nature this is about inductive machine
learning and
deductive machine learning so the
question can be what is the difference
between inductive machine learning and
deductive machine learning or somewhat
in that manner so the exact phrase or
exact question can vary they can ask for
examples and things like that but that
could be the question so let's first
understand what is inductive and
deductive training inductive training is
induced by somebody and you can
illustrate that with a small example i
think that always helps so whenever
you're doing some explanation try as
much as possible as i said to give
examples from your work experience or
give some analogies and that will also
help a lot in explaining as well and for
the interviewer also to understand so
here we'll take an example or rather we
will use an analogy so inductive
training is when we induce some
knowledge or the learning process into a
person without the person actually
experiencing it okay what can be an
example so we can probably tell the
person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage
right so this is inductive learning
compared to that what is deductive
learning so here you draw conclusion or
the person draws conclusion out of
experience so we will stick to the
analogy so compared to the showing a
video let's assume a person is allowed
to play with fire right and then he
figures out that if he puts his finger
it's burning or if throw something into
the fire it burns so he is learning
through experience so this is known as
deductive learning okay so you can have
applications or models that can be
trained using inductive learning or
deductive learning all right i think
probably that explanation will be
sufficient
the next question is are knn and k means
clustering similar to one another or are
they same
and k means of course is the clustering
mechanism now these two are completely
different except for the letter k being
common between them k n is completely
different k means clustering is
completely different k n n is a
classification process
and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k means clustering is
actually
unsupervised okay when you have k and n
when you want to implement k n which is
basically k nearest neighbors the value
of k is a number so you can say k is
equal to 3 you want to implement k n
with k is equal to 3 so which means that
it performs the classification in such a
way that how does it perform the
classification so it will take three
nearest objects and that's why it's
called nearest neighbor so basically uh
based on the distance it will try to
find out its nearest objects that are
let's say three of the nearest objects
and then it will check whether the class
they belong to which class right so if
all three belong to one particular class
obviously this new object is also
classified as that particular class but
it is possible that they may be from two
or three different classes okay so let's
say they are from two classes and then
if they are from two classes now usually
you take a odd number you assign an odd
number to so if there are three of them
and two of them belong to one class and
then one belongs to another class so
this new object is assigned to the class
to which the two of them belong now the
value of k is sometimes tricky whether
should you use three should you use five
should you use seven that can be tricky
because the ultimate classification can
also vary so it's possible that if
you're taking k as three the object is
probably in one particular class but if
you take k is equal to five maybe the
object will belong to a different class
because when you are taking three of
them probably two of them belong to a
class one and one belong to class two
whereas when you take five of them it is
possible that only two of them belong to
class one and three of them belong to
class 2 so which means that this object
will belong to class 2 right so you see
that so it is the class allocation can
vary depending on the value of k now k
means on the other hand is a clustering
process and it is unsupervised where
what it does is the system will
basically identify how the objects are
how close the objects are with respect
to some of their features okay and but
the similarity of course is the the
letter k and in case of k means also we
specify its value and it could be three
or five or seven there is no technical
limit as such but it can be any number
of clusters that you can create okay so
based on the value that you provide the
system will create that many clusters of
similar objects so there is a similarity
to that extent that k is a number in
both the cases but actually these two
are completely different processes
we have what is known as naive bayes
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive bayes is the name of
the person who found this classifier or
who developed this classifier which is
not 100 true base is the name of the
person bayes is the name of the person
but naive is not the name of the person
right so naive is basically an english
word and that has been added here
because of the nature of this particular
classifier naive bayes classifier is a
probability based classifier and
it makes some assumptions that presence
of one feature of a class is not related
to the presence of any other feature of
maybe other classes right so which is
not a very strong or not a very what do
you say accurate assumption because
these features can be related and so on
but even if we go with this assumption
this whole algorithm works very well
even with this assumption and that is
the good side of it but the term comes
from that so that is the explanation
that you can
then there can be question around
reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement
learning or it can be any game so the
best way to explain this is again to
talk a little bit about what
reinforcement learning is about and then
elaborate on that to explain the process
so first of all reinforcement learning
has an environment and an agent and the
agent is basically performing some
actions in order to achieve a certain
goal and this goals can be anything
either if it is related to game then the
goal could be that you have to score
very high score a high value high number
or it could be that your
number of lives should be as high as
possible don't lose life so this could
be some of them more advanced examples
could be for driving the automotive
industry self-driving cars they actually
also make use of reinforcement learning
to teach the car how to navigate through
the roads and so on and so forth that is
also another example now how does it
work so if the system is basically there
is an agent and environment and every
time the agent takes a step or performs
a task which is taking it towards the
goal the final goal let's say to
maximize the score or to minimize the
number of lives and so on or minimize
the deaths for example it is rewarded
and every time it takes a step which
goes against that code right contrary or
the reverse direction it is penalized
okay so it is like a carrot and a stick
system now how do you use this to create
a game of chess or to create a system to
play a game of chess now the way this
works is and this could probably go back
to this alphago example where alphago
defeated a human champion so the way it
works is in reinforcement learning the
system is allowed for example in this
case we are talking about chess so we
allow the system to first of all watch
playing a game of chess so it could be
with a human being or it could be the
system itself there are computer games
of chess right so
either this new learning system has to
watch that game or watch a human being
play the game because this is
reinforcement learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent it works on
that so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to start playing
the game so it pretty much starts from
scratch okay and as it moves forward it
it's right at the beginning and the
system really knows nothing about the
game of chess okay so initially it is a
clean slate it just starts by observing
how you're playing so it will make some
random moves and keep losing badly but
then what happens is over a period of
time so you need to now allow the system
or you need to play with the system not
just one two three four or five times
but hundreds of times thousands of times
maybe even hundreds of thousands of
times and that's exactly how alphago has
done it played millions of games between
itself and the system right so for the
game of chess also you need to do
something like that you need to allow
the system to pitch us and then learn on
its own over a period of repetition so i
think you can probably explain it to
this much to this extent and it should
be
sufficient
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming into picture so the
question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem i would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm i am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision trees you have svm you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes for this particular
problem since you have explained this
now this is the exact algorithm that you
can use that is not possible okay so we
have to try out a bunch of algorithms
see which one gives us the best
performance and best accuracy and then
decide to go with that particular
algorithm so in machine learning a lot
of it happens through trial and error
there is no real possibility that
anybody can just by looking at the
problem or understanding the problem
tell you that okay in this particular
situation this is exactly the algorithm
that you should use
then the questions may be around
application of machine learning and this
question is specifically around how
amazon is able to recommend other things
to buy so this is around recommendation
engine how does it work how does the
recommendation engine work so this is
basically the question is all about so
the recommendation engine again works
based on various inputs that are
provided obviously something like uh you
know amazon a website or e-commerce site
like amazon collects a lot of data
around the customer behavior who is
purchasing what and if somebody is
buying a particular thing they are also
buying something else so this kind of
association right so this is the
unsupervised learning we talked about
they use this to associate and link or
relate items and that is one part of it
so they kind of build association
between items saying that somebody
buying this is also buying this that is
one part of it then they also profile
the users right based on their age their
gender their geographic location they
will do some profiling and then when
somebody is logging in and when somebody
is shopping kind of the mapping of these
two things are done they try to identify
obviously if you have logged in then
they know who you are and your
information is available like for
example your age may be your agenda and
where you're located what you purchased
earlier right so all this is taken and
the recommendation engine basically uses
all this information and comes up with
recommendations for a particular user so
that is how the recommendation engine
works all right then the question can be
uh something very basic like when will
you go for classification versus
regression right when do you do
classification instead of regression or
when will you use classification instead
of regression now yes so so this is
basically going back to the
understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values and other is the
continuous values so for regression if
you are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if you
are trying to find some discrete values
you use classification and then you need
to illustrate what are some of the
examples so classification is like let's
say there are images and you need to put
them into classes like cat dog elephant
tiger something like that so that is a
classification problem or it can be that
is a multi-class classification a
problem it could be binary
classification problem like for example
whether a customer will buy or he will
not buy that is a classification binary
classification it can be in the weather
forecast area now weather forecast is
again combination of regression and
classification because on the one hand
you want to predict whether it's going
to rain or not that's a classification
problem that's a binary classification
right whether it's going to rain or not
rain however you also have to predict
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow right now temperature is a
continuous value you can't answer the
temperature in a yes or no kind of a
response right so what will be the
temperature tomorrow so you need to give
a number which can be like 20 degrees 30
degrees or whatever right so that is
where you use regression one more
example is stock price prediction so
that is where again you will use
regression so these are the various
examples so you need to illustrate with
examples and make sure you include those
keywords like discrete and continuous so
the next question is more about a little
bit of a design related question to
understand your concepts and things like
that so it is how will you design a spam
filter so how do you basically design or
develop a spam filter so i think the
main thing here is he's looking at
probably understanding your concepts in
terms of what is the algorithm you will
use or what is your understanding about
difference between classification and
regression
and things like that right and the
process of course the methodology and
the process so the best way to go about
responding to this is we say that okay
this is a classification problem because
we want to find out whether an email is
a spam or not spam so that we can apply
the filter accordingly so first thing is
to identify what type of a problem it is
so we have identified that it is a
classification then the second step may
be to find out what kind of algorithm to
use now since this is a binary
classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as i said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support vector missions for
example svm so we will kind of list down
a few of these algorithms and we will
say okay we want we would like to try
out these algorithms and then we go
about taking your historical data which
is the labeled data which are marked so
you will have a bunch of emails and then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used or rather
the model actually
so and you actually will have three
models let's say you are trying to test
out three algorithms so you will
obviously have three models so you need
to try all three models and test them
out as well see which one gives the best
accuracy and then you decide that you
will go with that model okay so training
and test will be done and then you zero
in on one particular model and then you
say okay this is the model will you use
we will use and then go ahead and
implement that or put that in production
so that is the way you design a spam
file the next question is about random
forest what is random forest so this is
a very straightforward question however
the response you need to be again a
little careful while we all know what is
random forest explaining this can
sometimes be tricky so one thing is
random forest is kind of in one way it
is an extension of decision trees
because it is basically nothing but you
have multiple decision trees and
trees will basically you will use for
doing if it is classification mostly it
is classification you will use the trees
for classification and then you use
voting for finding the the final class
so that is the underlying but how will
you explain this how will you respond to
this so first thing obviously we will
say that random forest is one of the
algorithms and the more important thing
that you need to probably the
interviewer is waiting to hear is
ensemble learner right so this is one
type of ensemble learner what is
ensemble learner ensemble learner is
like a combination of algorithms so it
is a learner which consists of more than
one algorithm or more than one maybe
models okay so in case of random forest
the algorithm is the same but instead of
using one instance of it we use multiple
instances of it and we use so in a way
that is a random forest is an ensemble
learner there are other types of
ensemble learners where we have likely
use different algorithms itself so you
have one maybe logistic regression and a
decision tree combined together and so
on and so forth or there are other ways
like for example splitting the data in a
certain way and so on so that's all
about ensembl we will not go into that
but random foreign i think the
interviewer will be happy to hear this
word ensemble learners and so then you
go and explain how the random forest
works so if the random forest is used
for classification then we use what is
known as a voting mechanism so basically
how does it work let's say your random
forest consists of 100 trees and each
observation you pass through this forest
and each observation let's say it is a
classification problem binary
classification 0 or 1 and you have 100
trees now if 90 trees say that it is a 0
and 10 of the trees say it is a 1 you
take the majority you may take a vote
and since 90 of them are saying 0 you
classify this as 0 then you take the
next observation and so on so that is
the way random forest works for
classification if it is a regression
problem but somewhat similar but only
thing is instead of vote what we will do
is sorry in regression remember what
happens you actually calculate a value
right so for example you are using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
100 trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
forest right so you have outputs of
individual
trees which are a part of this forest
but then you need to find the final
output of the forest itself so how do
you do that so in case of regression you
take like an average or the mean of all
the 100 trees right so this is also a
way of reducing the error so maybe if
you have only one tree and if that one
tree makes a error it is basically
hundred percent wrong or 100 right right
but if you have on the other hand if you
have a bunch of trees you are basically
mitigating that reducing that error okay
so that is the way random forest works
so the next question is considering the
long list of machine learning algorithms
how will you decide on which one to use
so once again here there is no way to
outright say that this is the algorithm
that we will use for a given data set
this is a very good question but then
the response has to be like again there
will not be a one size fits all so we
need to first of all you can probably
shorten the list in terms of by saying
okay whether it is a classification
problem or it is a regression problem to
that extent you can probably shorten the
list because you don't have to use all
of them if it is a classification
problem you only can pick from the
classification algorithms right so for
example if it's a classification you
cannot use linear regression algorithm
there or if it is a regression problem
you cannot use svm or maybe now you can
use svm but maybe a logistic regression
right so to that extent you can probably
shorten the list but still you will not
be able to 100
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that i am going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on what the problem is
you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accuracy and based on that you
choose that particular algorithm okay
all right then they can be questions
around bias and variance so the question
can be what is bias and variance in
machine learning so you just need to
give out a definition for each of these
for example a bias in machine learning
it occurs when the predicted values are
far away from the actual values so that
is a bias okay and whereas they are all
all the values are probably they are far
off but they are very near to each other
though the predicted values are close to
each other right while they are far off
from the actual value but they are close
to each other you see the difference so
that is bias and then the other part is
your variance now variance is when the
predicted values are all over the place
right so the variance is high that means
it may be close to the target but it is
kind of very scattered so the points the
predicted values are not close to each
other right in case of bias the
predicted values are close to each other
but they are not close to the target but
here they may be close to the target but
they may not be close to each other so
they are a little bit more scattered so
that is what in case of a variance okay
then the next question is about again
related to bias and variance what is the
trade-off between bias and variance yes
i think this is a interesting question
because these two are heading in
different directions so for example if
you try to minimize the bias variance
will keep going high and if you try to
minimize the variance bias will keep
going high and there is no way you can
minimize both of them so you need to
have a trade-off saying that okay this
is the level at which i will have my
bias and this is the level at which i
will have variance so the trade-off is
that pretty much uh attack you you
decide what is the level you will
tolerate for your bias and what is the
level you will tolerate for variance and
a combination of these two in such a way
that your final results are not way off
and having a trade-off will ensure that
the results are consistent right so that
is basically the output is consistent
and which means that they are close to
each other and they are also accurate
that means they are as close to the
target as possible right so if either of
these is high then one of them will go
off the track define precision and
recall now again here i think it would
be best to
draw a diagram and take the confusion
matrix and it is very simple the
definition is like a formula your
precision is true positive by true
positive plus false positive and your
recall is true positive by true positive
plus false negative okay so that's you
can just show it in a mathematical way
that's pretty much you know that can be
shown that's the easiest way to define
so the next question can be about
decision tree what is decision tree
pruning and why is it so
basically decision trees are really
simple to implement and understand but
one of the drawbacks of decision trees
is that it can become highly complicated
as it grows right and the rules and the
conditions can become very complicated
and this can also lead to overfitting
which is basically that during training
you will get 100 accuracy but when you
are doing testing you will get a lot of
errors so that is the reason
ruling needs to be done so the purpose
or the reason for doing
decision tree pruning is to reduce
overfitting or to cut down on
overfitting and
what is decision tree pruning it is
basically that you reduce the number of
branches because as you may be aware a
tree consists of the root node and then
there are several internal nodes and
then you have the leaf nodes now if
there are too many of these internal
nodes that is when you face the problem
of overfitting and pruning is the
process of reducing those internal nodes
all right so the next question can be
what is logistic regression uh so
basically logistic regression is
one of the techniques used for
performing classification especially
binary classification now there is
something special about logistic
regression and there are a couple of
things you need to be careful about
first of all the name is a little
confusing it is called logistic
regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if it's
really you know if it is required and
they can also ask this like a trick
question right so that is one part
second thing is the term logistic has
nothing to do with the usual logistics
that we talk about but it is derived
from log so that the mathematical
derivation was log and therefore the
name logistic regression so what is
logistic regression and how is it used
so logistic regression is used for
binary classification and the output of
a logistic regression is either a 0 or a
1 and it varies so it's basically it
calculates a probability between 0 and 1
and we can set a threshold that can vary
typically it is 0.5 so any value above
0.5 is considered as 1 and if the
probability is below 0.5 it is
considered as 0. so that is the way we
calculate the probability or the system
calculates the probability and based on
the threshold it sets a value of zero or
one which is like a binary
classification zero or one okay then we
have a question around k nearest
neighbor algorithm so explain k nearest
neighbor algorithm so first of all what
is a k nearest neighbor algorithm this
is a classification algorithm so that is
the first thing we need to mention and
we also need to mention that the k is a
number it is an integer and this is
variable and we can define what the
value of k should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we need to mention
technically it can be even number also
but then typically it would be odd
number and we will see why that is okay
so based on that we need to classify
objects okay we need to classify objects
so again it will be very helpful to draw
a diagram you know if you're explaining
i think that will be the best way so
draw some diagram like this and let's
say we have three clusters or three
classes existing and now you want to
find for a new item that has come you
want to find out which class this
belongs to right so you go about as the
name suggests it you go about finding
the nearest neighbors right the points
which are closest to this and how many
of them you will find that is what is
defined by k now let's say our initial
value of k was 5
so you will find the k the five nearest
data points so in this case as it is
illustrated these are the five nearest
data points but then all five do not
belong to the same class or cluster so
there are one belonging to this cluster
one the second one belonging to this
cluster two three of them belonging to
this third cluster so how do you decide
that's exactly the reason we should as
much as possible try to assign an odd
number so that it becomes easier to
assign this so in this case you see that
the majority actually if there are
multiple classes then you go with the
majority so since three of these items
belong to this class we assign which is
basically the in in this case the green
or the tennis or the third cluster as i
was talking about right so we assign it
to this third class so in this case it
is uh that's how it is decided okay so k
nearest neighbor so first thing is to
identify the number of neighbors that
are mentioned as k so in this case it is
k is equal to five so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that and and then the new data
point is assigned to that class okay so
that's pretty much how k nearest
neighbors work we're going to help you
prepare for interview questions dealing
with deep learning and we're going to go
from the very basics of neural networks
and deep learning into some of the more
commonly used models so you can have
understanding of what kind of questions
are going to come up and what you need
to know in interview questions we'll
start with a very general concept of
what is deep learning this is where we
take large volumes of data in this case
on cats and dogs or whatever a lot of
times you use
a training setup to train your model
remember it's kind of like a magic black
box going on there then we use that to
extract features or extract information
in this case classify the image of a cat
and a dog so the primary takeaway we're
talking about deep learning is it learns
from large volumes of structured and
even unstructured data and uses complex
algorithms to train neural network it
also performs complex operations to
extract hidden patterns and features and
if we're going to discuss deep learning
in this very
simplified overview and we also have to
go over what is a neural network this is
a common image you'll see of a drawing
of a forward propagation neural network
and it's it's a human brain inspired
system which replicates the way humans
learn so this is inspired how our own
neurons and our brain fire but at a much
simplified level obviously it's not
ready to take over the human uh
population and be our leader yet not for
many years it's very much in its infant
stage but it's inspired by how our
brains work and they use a lot of other
inspirations you can study brains of
moths and other animals that they've
used to figure out how to improve these
neural networks the most common one
consists of three layers of network and
this is generally how you view these
networks is you have an input you have a
hidden layer and an output and the
neural network is uh broken up into many
pieces but we focus just on the neural
network it's always on the hidden layers
that we're making all the adjustments
and figuring out how to best set up
those hidden layers for their functions
to both train faster and to function
better when we look at this of course we
have our input hidden and output each
layer contains neurons called as nodes
perform various operations and you can
see here we have the list of the nodes
we have both our input nodes and our
output nodes and then our hidden layer
nodes and it's used in deep learning
algorithm like cnn
or mlp a lot of times they're referred
to and you'll see these abbreviations
i'll be honest i have to write them down
on a piece of paper and go through them
because i never remember what they all
mean even though i play with them all
the time what is a multi-layer
precipitant well if you look at the
image on the right it's very similar to
what we just looked at you have your
input layer your hidden layer and your
output layer and that's exactly what
this is it has the same structure of a
single layer perceptron with one or more
hidden layers except the input layer
each node in the other layers uses a
non-linear activation function what that
means is your input layers your data
coming in and then your activation
function is based upon all those nodes
and weights being added together and
then it has the output mlp uses
supervised learning method called back
propagation for training the model very
key word there is back propagation
single layer perceptron can classify
only linear separable classes with
binary output 0 1 but the mlp can
classify non-linear classes so let's
break this down just a little bit the
multi-layer perceptron with an input
layer and a hidden layer and an output
layer as you see that it comes in there
it has adds up all the numbers and
weights depending on how your setup is
that then goes to the next layer that
then goes to the next hidden layer if
you have multiple hidden layers and
finally to the output layer the back
propagation takes the error that it sees
so whatever the output is it says hey
this has an error to it it's wrong and
then sends that error backwards from
where it came from and there's a lot of
different functions used to uh train
this based on that error and how that
error goes backwards in the notes so
forward is you get your answers backward
is for training you see this every day
even my uh google pixel phone has this
it they train the neural network which
takes a lot more data to train than it
does to use and then they load up that
neural network into in this case i have
a pixel 2 which actually has a built-in
neural network for processing pictures
and so it's just the forward propagation
i use when it processes my photos but
when they were training it use the back
propagation to train it with the errors
they had we'll be coming back to
different models that are used for right
now though multi-layer perspectron mlp
but that down is your vocabulary word
and of course back propagation
what is data normalization and why do we
need it this is so important we spend so
much time in normalizing our data and
getting our data clean and setting it up
so we talk about data there's a
pre-processing step to standardize the
data so whatever we have coming in we
don't want it to be a you know one
gigabyte file here a two gigabyte
picture here and a three kilobyte text
there even as a human i can't process
those all in the same group i have to
reformat them in some way that loops
them together so the standardized format
we use this uh data normalization in
pre-processing to reduce it and
eliminate data redundancy a lot of times
the data comes in and you end up with
two of the same images or
the same information in different
formats then we want to rescale values
to fit into a particular range for
achieving better convergence what this
means is with most neural networks they
form a bias we've seen this in recently
in attacks on neural networks where they
light up one pixel or one piece of the
view and it skews the whole answer so
suddenly
because one pixel is really bright it
doesn't know what to do but when we
start rescaling it we put all the values
between say minus one and one and we
change them and refit them to those
values it helps get rid of that bias
helps fix for some of those problems and
then finally we restructure the data and
improve the integrity we want to make
sure that we're not missing values or we
don't have partial data coming in one
way to look at this is
bad data in bad data out
so you want clean data in and you want
good answers coming out one of the most
basic models used is a boltzmann machine
so let's address what is a boltzmann
machine and if you know we just did the
mlp multi-layer perceptron so now we're
going to come into almost a simplified
version of that and in this we have our
visible input layer and we have our
hidden layer the boltzmann machines are
almost always shallow they're usually
just two layer neural nets that make
stochastic decisions whether a neuron
should be on or off true false yes no
first layer is a visible layer and
second layer is the hidden layer nodes
are connected to each other across
layers but no two nodes of the same
layer are connected hence it is also
known as restricted boltzmann machine
now that we've covered a basic mlp or
multi-layer perceptron and we've gone
over the boltzmann machine also known as
the restricted boltzmann machine let's
talk a little bit about activation
formulas and this is a huge topic that
can get really complicated but it also
is automated so it's very simple so you
have both a complicated and a simple at
the same time so what is the role of
activation functions in a neural network
activation function decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not that's the
most basic one and that actually changes
a little bit because it's either whether
fired or not in this case activation
function or what value should come out
when it's fired but in these models
we're looking at just the boltzmann
restricted layers so this is what causes
them to fire either they don't or they
do it's a yes or no true false all or
nothing it accepts the weighted sum of
the inputs the bias as input to any
activation function so whatever
activation function is it needs to have
the sum of the weights times the input
so each input if you remember on that
model and let's just go back to that
model real quick and then you always
have to add a bias and you can look at
the bias if you remember from your
euclidean geometry you draw a straight
line formula for that line has a
y-coordinate at the end it's always
cx plus m or something like that where m
is where it crosses the y-coordinates if
you're doing a straight line with these
weights it's very similar but a lot of
times we just add it in as its own
weight we take it as a node of a one
value coming in and then we compute its
new weight and that's how we compute
that bias just like we compute all the
other weights coming in the node which
gets fires depends on the y value and
then we have a step function and the
step function this is where remember i
said is going to get complicated and
simple all at the same time we have a
lot of different step functions we have
the sigmoid function we have just a
standard step function we have the relu
it's pronounced like re the
from the sun and liu like a name so relu
function and we have the tangent h
function and if you look at these they
all have something similar they all
either force it to be
one value or the other they force it to
be in the case of the first three is
zero or one and in the last one it's
either a minus one or a one and you can
easily convert that to a zero one yes no
true false and on this one of the most
common ones is the step function itself
because there is no middle value there
is no
discrepancy that says well i'm not quite
sure but as you get into different
models probably the most commonly used
used to be the sigmoid was most commonly
used but i see the relu used more often
really depending on what you're doing
you just have to play with these and
find out which one works best
depending on the data and your output
the reason to have a non zero one answer
or something kind of in the middle is
when you're looking at this and it's
coming out you can actually process that
middle ground as part of the answer into
another neural network so it might be
that the rayleigh function says hey this
is only a 0.6 not a 1. and even though
the one is what's going into the next
neural network or the next hidden layer
as an input the 0.6 value might also be
going in there to let you know hey this
is not a straight up 1 or straight up 0
is someplace in the middle this is a
little uncertain what's coming out here
so it's a very powerful tool but the
basic neural network you usually just
use the step function it's yes or no
let's take a a big step back and take a
kind of an overview the next function is
what is a cost function that we're going
to cover this is so important because
this is your end result that you're
going to do over and over again and use
to decide whether the model is working
or not whether you need to try a
different step function whether you need
to try a different activation whether
you need to try a fully different model
used
so what is the cost function cost
function is the measure to evaluate how
good your model's performance is it is
also referred as loss or error used to
compute the error of the output layer
during back propagation there's our back
propagation where we're training our
model that's one of our key words mean
squared error is an example of a popular
cost function and so here we have the
cost function c equals half of y minus y
predicted and then you square that so
the first thing is um you know real
quick if you haven't done statistics
this is not a percentage it's not a
percentage of how accurate it is it's
just a measurement of the error and we
take that error for training it and we
push that error backwards through the
neural network and we use that through
the different training functions
depending on what model you're using to
train the neural network so when you
deploy the network you're usually done
training it because it takes a lot of
computational force to train it this is
a very simple model and so you deploy
the trained one but we want to know how
your error is and so how do we do that
well you split your data part of your
data is for trading and part of your
data is for testing and then we can also
test the error on there so it's very
important and then we're going to go one
more step on this we got to look at both
the local and the global setup it might
work great to test your data on what you
have on your computer but that's
different than in the field so when
we're talking about all these different
tests in the error test as far as your
loss you don't you want to make sure
that you're in a closed environment when
you do initial testing but you also want
to open that up and make sure you follow
up with the testing on the larger scale
of data because it will change it might
not fit the larger scale there might be
something in there in the way you
brought the data in specifically or the
data group you used or any of those
could cause an error so it's very
important to remember that we're looking
at both the local and the global context
of our error and just one other side
note on a lot of the newer models of
neural networks by comparing the error
we get on the data our training data
with a portion of the test data we can
actually figure out how good the model
is whether it's over fitted or not we'll
go into that a little bit more as we go
into some of the different models so we
have our output we're able to
figure out the error on it based on the
square means usually although there's
other functions used so we want to talk
about what is gradient descent another
vocabulary word gradient descent is an
optimization algorithm to minimize the
cost function or to minimize the error
aim is to find the local or global
minima of a function determine the
direction the model should take to
reduce the error so as we're looking at
this we have our squared error that we
just figured out the cop based on the
cost function it says how bad is my
model fitting the data i just put
through it and then we want to reduce
that error so how do you figure out what
direction to do that in well it could be
that you're looking at just that line of
that line of data coming in so that
would be a local minima we want to know
the error of that particular setup
coming in and then you have your global
your global minima we want to minimize
it based on the overall data we're
putting through it and with this we can
figure out the global minimum cost we
want to take all those local minimum
cost of each piece of data coming in and
figure out the global one how we're
going to adjust this model to fit all
the data we don't want it to be biased
just on three or four lines of data
coming in we wanted to kind of
extrapolate a general answer for all the
data coming in but this of course we
mentioned it briefly about back
propagation this is where really comes
in handy is training our model neural
network technique to minimize the cost
function helps to improve the
performance of the network back
propagates the error and updates the
weights to reduce the error so as you
can see here is a very nice depiction of
a back propagation we have our predicted
y coming out and then we have since it's
a training set we already know the
answer and the answer comes back and
based on case of square means was one of
the functions we looked at one of the
activation functions based on cost
function that cost function then
depending on what you choose for your
back propagation method and there's a
number of them we'll change the weights
it will change the weight going to each
of the one of those nodes in the hidden
layer and then based upon the error
that's still being carried back it'll
change the way it's going to the next
hidden layer and then it computes an
error level on that and sends that back
up and you're going to say well if it
computes the air into the first hidden
layer and fixes it why would it stop
there well remember we don't want to
create a biased neural network so we
only make small adjustments on these
weights we don't make a big adjustment
that changes everything right off the
bat so no matter how far back you go
you're always going to have a small
amount of error and that's still going
to continue to go all the way back up
the hidden layers for right now focus on
the back propagation is taking that
error moving it backwards on the neural
network to change the weights and help
program it so that it'll have the
correct answers so far we've been
talking about forward propagation neural
networks everything goes forwards goes
left to right uh but let's just take a
little detour let's see what is the
difference between a feed-forward neural
network and a recurrent neural network
now this is in the function not when
we're training it using the back
propagation so you've got new
information coming in and you want to
get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there and we want
to know we have a feed forward neural
network and we have a new vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a feed
forward neural network signals travel in
one direction from input to output no
feedback loops considers only the
current input cannot memorize previous
inputs one example of one of these feed
forward neural networks and we've
covered a number of them but one of the
ones that has a big highlight nowadays
is the cnn a convolutional neural
network tensorflow the one put out by
google is probably most known for their
cnn where the information goes forward
it first takes a picture splits it apart
goes through the individual pixels on
the picture so it picks up a different
reading then calculates based on that
goes into a regular feed forward neural
network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the cnn today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
youtube put out by simply learn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
cnn is a forward propagation neural
network only so it's only moving in one
direction so we will look at a recurrent
neural network signals travel in both
directions making it a looped network
considers the current input along with
the previous received inputs for
generating the output of a layer has the
ability to memorize past data due to its
internal memory and you can see they
have a nice image here we have our
input and for some reason they always do
the recurrent neural network
in reverse from bottom up in the images
kind of a standard although i'm not sure
why your x goes into your hidden layer
and your hidden layer the answer for
part of the answer from that it
generates feeds back into the hidden
layer so now you have an input of both x
and part of the hidden layer and then
that feeds into your output now if we go
back to the forward let me just go back
a slide and we're looking at our forward
propagation network one of the tricks
you can do to use just a forward
propagation network is if you're in a
what they call a time sequence that's a
good uh term to remember are a time
series meaning that a sequential data
each term comes after the other you can
trick this by creating your input nodes
as with the history so if you know that
you have values one five and seven going
in and you know what the output is from
one what those outputs are you can
expand the input to include the history
input that's one of the ways to trick a
forward propagation network into looking
at that but when you do with the
recurrent neural network you let the
hidden layer do that for you it sends
that data and reprocesses it back into
itself what are some of the applications
of recurrent neural network the rnn can
be used for sentiment analysis and text
mining getting up early in the morning
is good for health it's a positive
sentiment one of the catches you really
want to look at this when you're looking
at the language is that i could switch
this around and totally negate the
meaning of what i'm doing so would no
longer be positive so when you're
looking at a sentence knowing the order
of the words is as important as the
meaning of the words you can't just
count how many good words there are
versus bad words to get some positive
sentiment you now have to know what
they're addressing and there's lots of
other different uses uh kids are playing
football or soccer as we call it in the
us rn can help you caption an image so
based on previous information coming in
it refeeds that back in and you have a
image setter and then time series
problems like predicting the prices of
stocks in a month or quarter or sell a
product can be solved using an rnn and
this is a really good example you have
whatever your stocks were doing earlier
this month will have a huge effect on
what they're doing today if you're
investing so having an rnn model a
recurrent neural network feeding into
itself what's happening previously
allows it to take that model and program
in the whole series without having to
put in the whole a month at a time of
data you only put in one day at a time
but if you keep them in order it will
look back and say oh this because what
happened yesterday i need some
information from that and i'm going to
use that to help predict today's and so
on and so on we're going to go back to
our activation functions remember i told
you rayleigh was one of the most common
functions used
so let's talk a little bit more about
relu and also softmax softmax is an
activation function that generates the
output between 0 and 1. it divides each
output such that the total sum of the
outputs is equal to one it is often used
in the output layers soft max l of the n
equals e to l on the n over the absolute
value of e to the l so what does this
function mean i mean what is actually
going on here so we have our output
nodes and our output nodes are giving us
let's say they gave us 1.2 0.9 and 0.4
as a human being i look at that and i
say well the greatest value is 1.2 so
whatever category that is if you have
three different categories maybe you're
not just doing if it's a cat or it's a
dog or well let's say it's a cow and we
had cats and dogs earlier why the cats
and dogs are hanging out with a cow i
don't know but we have a value and it
might say 1.2 is a cat 0.9 is the dog
and 0.4 is a cow for some reason it
thinks that there's a chance of it being
any one of these three items and that's
how it comes out of the output layer
well as a human i can look at 1.2 and
say this is definitely what it is it's
definitely a cat or whatever it is maybe
it's looking at different kinds of cars
might be a bitter whether it's a car
truck or a motorcycle maybe that'd be a
better example well from a computer
standpoint that might be a little
confusing because they're just numbers
waving at us and so with the soft max we
want all those numbers to always add up
to one so when i add three numbers
together i want the final output to be
one on there and so it goes through this
formula changes each of these numbers in
this case it changes them to 0.46 0.34
and 0.20 they all add up to one and
that's a lot easier to register because
it's very set it's a set output it's
never going to be more than one it's
never going to be less than zero and so
you can see here that there's probably a
pretty high chance that it's the first
one so you're a human being we have no
problem knowing that but this output can
then also go into say another input so
it might be
an automated car that's picking up
images and it says that image in front
of us is probably a big truck we should
deal with it like it's a big truck it's
probably not a motorcycle or whatever
those categories are that's the soft max
part of it but now we have the relu well
what's where's the relu coming from well
the relu is what's generating the 1.2
and the 0.9 and the 0.4 and so if you
remember our relu stands for rectified
linear unit and is the most widely used
activation function we looked at a
number of different activation functions
including tangent h the step function
remember i said the step function is
really used if that's what your actual
output is because then you know it's a
zero or one but the ray loop if you have
that as your output you now have a
discrepancy in there and if that's going
into another neural network or another
process having that discrepancy is
really important and it gives an output
of x if x is positive and zero otherwise
so it says my x value is going to be
somewhere between zero or one and then
the
usually unless it's really uncertain the
output's usually a one or zero and then
you have that little piece of
uncertainty there that you can send
forward to another network or you can
look at to know that there's uncertainty
involved and is often used in the hidden
layers this is what's coming out of the
hidden layers into the output layer
usually or as we reference the
convolutional neural network the cnn
you'd have to go to another video to
review the relu is the most common used
for convolutional part of that network
it has a bunch of little pieces that are
very simplified looking at all the
different images or different sections
of the map and the rayleigh works really
good for that like i said there's other
formulas used but that this is the most
common one and you'll see that in the
hidden layers going maybe between one
layer and the next layer so just a quick
recap we have our soft max which means
that if you have numerous categories
only one of them is going to be picked
but you also want to have some value
attached to it how well it picked it and
you put that between 0 1 so it's very
standardized so we have our soft max we
looked at that let's go back one we
looked at that here where it transforms
the numbers and then we have our relu
function which takes the information and
the summation and puts it between a zero
and a one where it's either clearly a
zero or depending on how confident our
model is it'll go between the zero and
one value what are hyper parameters well
this is a great interview question hyper
parameters when you are doing neural
networks this is what you're playing
with most the time once you've gotten
the data formatted correctly a
hyperparameter is a parameter whose
value is set before the learning process
begins determines how a network is
trained and the structure of the network
this includes things like the number of
hidden units how many hidden layers are
you going to have and how many nodes in
each layer learning rate learning rate
is usually multiplied once you've
figured out the error how much you want
to change the weights we talked about or
i mentioned it early just briefly you
don't want to just make a huge change
otherwise you're going to have a biased
model so you only take some little
incremental changes and that's what the
learning rate is is those small
incremental changes epics how many times
are you going to go through all the data
in your training set so one epic is one
trip through all the data and there's a
lot of other things depending on which
model you're working with and which
programming script you're working with
like the python sk learn package will
have a slightly different than say
google's tensorflow package which will
be a little bit different than the spark
machine learning package so these are
just some examples of the hyper
parameters and so you see in here we
have a nice image of our data coming in
and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so and we send it back and we
change our hyper parameters to see if we
can get an unbiased model or we can have
a better prediction on it it matches our
data closer what will happen if learning
rate is set too low or too high we have
a nice couple graphs here we have one
over here says the learning rate set to
load you can see that it slowly works
its way down the curve and on the right
you can see a learning rate set too high
it's just bouncing back and forth when
your learning rate is too low that's
what we studied at two slides over this
what the learning rate was training of
the model will progress very slowly as
we are making very tiny updates to the
weights we'll take many updates before
reaching the minimum point so i just
mentioned epic going through all the
data you might have to go through all
the data a thousand times instead of 500
times for it to train learning rate too
high causes undesirable divergent
behavior to the loss function due to
drastic updates and weights at times it
may fail to converge or even diverge so
if you have your learning rate set too
high and it's training too quickly maybe
you'll get lucky and it trains after one
epic run but a lot of times it might
never be able to train because the
weights are changing too fast they they
flip back and forth too easy and you see
down here we've introduced two new terms
converge and diverge a converge means
that our model has reached a point where
it's able to give a fairly good answer
for all the data we put in all those
weights have adjusted and it's minimized
the error diverged means that the data
is so chaotic that it can never manage
to to train to that data the data is
just too chaotic for it to train so we
have two new words there converge and
diverge are important to know also what
is dropout and batch normalization
dropout is a technique of dropping out
hidden and visible units of a network
randomly to prevent overfitting of data
it doubles the number of iterations
needed to converge the network so here
we have our standard neural network and
then after applying dropout now it
doesn't mean we actually delete the note
the note is still there and we're still
going to use that note what it means is
that we're only going to work with a few
of the notes
a lot of times i think the most common
one right now used is 20 percent
so you'll drop out 20 of the nodes when
you do your training you reverse
propagate your data and then you'll
randomly pick another 20 nodes the next
time you go through an epic data
training so each time you go through one
epic you will randomly pick 20 of those
nodes not not to mess with and this
allows for
less overfitting of the data so by
randomly doing this you create some i
guess it just kind of pulls some nodes
off to the side it says we're going to
handle the data later on so we don't
over fit batch normalization is a
technique to improve the performance and
stability of neural network the idea is
to normalize the inputs in every layer
so that they have mean output and
activation of zero and standard
deviation of one this question covers a
lot of different things which is great
it's a great interview question because
it pulls in that you have to understand
what the mean value is so a mean output
activation of zero that means our
average activation is zero so when you
normalize it remember usually we're
going between minus one and one on a lot
of these it's a very standard setup so
you have to be very aware that this is
your mean output activation of zero and
then we have our standard deviation of
one so we want to keep our error down to
just a one value the benefits of this
doing a batch normalization is it
provides regularization it trains faster
higher learning rates and weights are
easier to initialize what is the
difference between batch gradient
descent and stochastic gradient descent
batch gradient descent batch gradient
computes the gradient using the entire
data set it takes time to converge
because the volume of data is huge and
weights update slowly so you can look at
the batches a lot of times if you're
using big data batch the data in but you
still go through a full epic you still
go through all the data on there so
batch gradient descent means you're
going to use it to fit all the data and
look for convergence there stochastic
gradient descent stochastic gradient
computes the gradient using a single
sample it converges much faster than
batch gradient because it updates weight
more frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when the model
learns the details and noise and the
training data to the degree that it
adversely impacts the execution of the
model on the new information it is more
likely to occur with non-linear models
that have more flexibility when learning
a target function an example of this
would be if you're looking at say cars
and trucks and motorcycles it might only
recognize trucks that have a certain
box-like shape it might not be able to
notice a flatbed truck unless it's only
a specific kind of flatbed truck or only
ford trucks because that's what it saw
on the training set this means that your
model performs great on your trained
data and great on maybe a small test
amount of data but when you go to use it
in the real world it leaves out a lot
and starting is not very functional
outside of your small area your slow
laboratory data coming in under fitting
doing the opposite when you under fit
your data underfitting alludes to a
model that is neither well trained on
training data nor can generalize to new
information usually happens when there
is less and improper data to train a
model has a verb performance and
accuracy so if you're using underfitted
data and you generate a model and you
distribute that in a commercial zone
you'll have a lot of people unhappy with
you because it's not going to give them
very good answers so we've explained
overfitting and under fitting so now we
want to ask how to combat them combating
overfitting and underfitting resampling
the data to estimate the model accuracy
k-fold cross-validation having a
validation data set to evaluate the
model so we do the re-sampling we're
randomly going to be picking out data
and we'll run it a few times to see how
that works depending on our random data
and how we uh sample the data to
generate our model and then we want to
go ahead and validate the data set by
having our training data and then
keeping some data on the side testing
data to validate it how are weights
initialized in a network initializing
all weights to zero all the weights are
set to zero this makes your model
similar to a linear model so if you have
linear data coming in doing a basic
setup like that might work all the
neurons in every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the deep net useless right there
is a key word it's going to be useless
if you initialize everything to zero at
that point be looking into some other
machine learning tools initializing all
weights randomly here the weights are
assigned randomly by initializing them
very close to zero it gives better
accuracy to the model since every neuron
performs different computations and here
we have the weights are set randomly we
have our input layer the hidden layers
and the output layer and w equals np
random random end layer size l layer
size l minus one this is the most
commonly used is to randomly generate
your weights what are the different
layers in cnn convolutional neural
network first is the convolutional layer
that performs a convolutional operation
we have our other video out if you want
to explore that more so go into detail
exactly how the c the convolutional
layer works on the cnn as far as
creating a number of smaller picture
windows to go over the data the second
step is as a rayleigh layer relu brings
non-linearity to the network and
converts all the negative pixels to zero
output is rectified feature map so it
goes into a mapping feature there
pooling layer pulling is a down sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map so we
have all our relu layer which is pulling
all these little maps out of our
convolutional layer it's taking that
picture and little creating little tiny
neural networks to look at different
parts of the picture uh then we need to
pull it together and then finally the
fully connected layer so we flatten our
pulling layer out and we have a fully
connected layer recognizes and
classifies the objects in the image and
that's actually your forward propagation
reverse propagation training model
usually i mean there's a number of
different models out there of course
what is pooling in cnn and how does it
work pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a cnn performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pooled feature
map by sliding a filter matrix over the
input matrix i mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide it's important to
know that you have if you can see here
they have a rectified feature map and so
each one of those colors like the yellow
color that might be one of the a smaller
little neural network using the relu
you'll look at it'll just kind of go
over the main picture and look at all
the different areas on the main picture
so you might step one two three four
spaces and then you have another one
that's also looking at features and it
has a two seven eight five each one of
those is a map so it might be the first
one might be a map looking for cat ears
the second one looking for human eyes
when it does this you then have this
rectified feature map looking at these
different features and the max pooling
with the two by two filters and a stride
a two stride means instead of skipping
every pixel you're going to go every two
pixels you take the maximum values and
you can see over here we look at a pull
feature map one of the features says hey
i had a max value of eight so somewhere
in here we saw a human eye labeled as
eight pretty high label and maybe seven
was a human hand and maybe four was cat
whiskers or something that we thought
might be cat whiskers four is kind of a
low number in this particular case
compared to the other ones so you have
your full pool feature map you can see
the process here is we have our stepping
we look for the max value and then we
create a pooled feature map of the max
values how does a lstm network work
that's long short-term memory so the
first thing to know is that an lstms are
a special kind of recurrent neural
network capable of learning long-term
dependencies remembering information for
long periods of time is their default
behavior we did look at the rnn briefly
talked about how the hidden layer feeds
back into itself with the lstm as a much
more complicated feedback and you can
see here we have the hidden layer of t
minus one and hidden layer that's what
the h stands for hidden layer of t and
the formula is going in as we can see
here we have the hidden layers we have t
minus one and then h of t where t stands
for time so this is a series remember
working with series and we want to
remember the past and you can see you
have your x your input of t and that
might be a frame in a
video as a frame comes in they usually
use in this one the tangent h activation
formula but you also see that it goes
through a couple other formulas the
omega formula and so when it combines
these that then goes into the next layer
your next hidden layer that then goes
into the data that's submitted to the
next input so you have your x of t plus
one so when you have that coming in then
you have your h values coming forward
from the last process and depending on
how many of these omega structures you
put in there depends on how long term
the memory gets so it's important to
remember this is more for your long-term
recurrent neural networks the three
steps in an lstm step one decides what
to forget and what to remember step two
selectively update cell state values so
based on what we want to remember and
forget we want to update those cell
values and then decides what part of the
current state make it to the output so
now we have to also have an output on
there what are vanishing and exploding
gradients this is a great question that
affects all our neural networks while
training an rnn your slope can become
either too small or too large and this
makes the training difficult when the
slope is too small the problem is known
as vanishing gradient so our slope we
have our change in x and our change in y
when the slope decreases gradually to a
very small value sometimes negative and
makes training difficult when the slope
tends to grow exponentially instead of
decaying this problem is called
exploding gradient the slope grows
exponentially you can see a nice graph
of that here issues in gradient problem
long training time poor performance and
low accuracy what is the difference
between epic batch and iteration and
deep learning epic an epic represents
one iteration over the entire data set
so that's everything you're going to go
ahead and put into that training model
batch we cannot pass the entire data set
into the neural network at once so we
divide the data set into a number of
batches and then iteration if we have 10
000 images as data and a batch size of
200 then the epic should run 10 000
times over 200 so that means we have our
total number over the 200 equals 50
iterations so in each epic we're running
over all the data set we're going to
have 50 iterations and each of those
iterations includes a batch of 200
images in this case why tensorflow is
the most preferred library in deep
learning uh well first tensorflow
provides both c plus plus and python
apis that makes it easier to work on has
a faster compilation time than other
deep learning libraries like cross and
torch tensorflow supports both cpus and
gpus computing devices so right now
tensorflow is at the top of the market
because it's so easy to use for both
programmer side and for hardware side
and for the speed of getting something
up and running what do you mean by
tensor in tensorflow tensor is a
mathematical object represented as a
rays of higher dimension these arrays of
data with different dimensions and ranks
that are fed as input to the neural
network are called tensors you can see
here we have a tensor of dimensions five
comma four so it's a two dimensional
tensor coming in you can look at an
image like this that each one of those
pixels is a different value if it's a
black and white so it might be zero and
ones and then each one represents a
black and white image in a color photo
you might
either find a different value system or
you might have a tensor value that has
the x y coordinates as we see here plus
the colors so you might have three more
different dimensions for the three
different images the red the blue and
the yellow coming in and even as you go
from one layer or one tensor to the next
these layers might change we might
flatten them might bring in numerous in
the case of the convergence neural
network we have all those smaller
different mappings of features that come
in so each one of those layers coming
through is a tensor if it has multiple
dimensions coming in and weights
attached to it what are the programming
elements in tensorflow well we have our
constants constants are parameters whose
value does not change to define a
constant we use tf.constant command
example a equals tf.constant 2.0 tf
float32 so it's a tensorflow value of 32
b equals tf constant 3.0 print a b if we
did a print of a b we'd have tf.constant
and then of course b is that instance of
it variables variables allow us to add
new trainable parameters to graph to
divide a variable we use tf.variable
command and initialize them before
running the graph in session example w
equals tf variable 0.3d type tf float32
or b equals the tf variable -3 comma d
type float32 placeholders placeholders
allow us to feed data to a tensorflow
model from outside a model it permits a
value to be assigned later to define a
placeholder we use tf placeholder
command example a equals tf placeholder
b equals a times two with the tf session
as sess result equals session run b
comma feed dictionary equals a 3.0 print
result so we have a nice example there
replace holder session a session is run
to evaluate the nodes this is called as
the tensorflow runtime so for example
you have a equals tf constant 2.0 b
equals tf constant 4.0 c equals a plus b
and at this point you'd go ahead and
create a session equals tf session and
then you can evaluate the tensor c print
session run c that would input c as an
input into your session what do you
understand by a computational graph
everything in tensorflow is based on
creating a computational graph it has a
network of nodes where each node
performs an operation nodes represent
mathematical operation and edges
represent tensors since data flows in a
form of a graph it is also called a data
flow graph and we have a nice visual of
this graph or graphic image of a
computational graph and you can see here
we have our input nodes our add multiply
nodes and our multiply node at the end
and then we have the edges where the
data flows so we have from a going to c
a going to d you can see we have a two
flowing uh for flowing explain
generative adversarial network along
with an example suppose there's a wine
shop that purchases wine from dealers
which they will resell later so we have
our dealer going to the wine or shop
owner that then sells it for a profit
but there are some malfactor dealers who
sell fake wine in this case the shop
owner should be able to distinguish
between fake and authentic wine the
forger will try to different techniques
to sell fake wine and make sure certain
techniques go past the shop owner's
check so here's our forager fake wine
shop owner the shop owner would probably
get some feedback from the wine experts
that some of the wine is not original
the owner would have to improve how he
determines whether a wine is fake or
authentic goal of forger to create wines
that are indistinguishable from the
authentic ones goal of shop owner to
accurately tell if the wine is real or
not there are two main components of
generative adversarial network and we
refer to as a noise vector coming in we
have our forger who's going to generate
fake wine and then we have our real
authentic wine and of course our shop
owner who has to figure out whether it's
real or fake the generator is a cnn that
keeps producing images that are closer
in appearance to the real images while
the discriminator tries to determine the
difference between real and fake images
the ultimate aim is to make the
discriminator learn to identify real and
fake images what is an auto encoder the
network is trained to reconstruct its
inputs it is a neural network that has
three layers here the input neurons are
equal to the output neuron the network's
target outside is same as the input it
uses dimensionality reduction to
restructure the input input image comes
in we have our latin space
representation and then it goes back out
reconstructing the image it works by
compressing the input to a latin space
representation and then reconstructing
the output from this representation what
is bagging and boosting bagging and
boosting are ensemble techniques where
the idea is to train multiple models
using the same learning algorithm and
then take a call so we have in here
where we're bagging we take a data set
and we split it we're gonna have our
training data and our test data very
standard thing to do then we're going to
randomly select data into the bags and
train your model separately so we might
have bag one model one bag two model two
bag three model three and so on in
boosting the emphasis is to select the
data points which give wrong output in
order to improve the accuracy so in
boosting we have our data set again we
split it to test data and train data and
we'll take a bag one and we'll train the
model data points with wrong predictions
then go into bag two and we then train
that model and repeat and that brings us
to the end of this live session on ai
and machine learning full course
hope you liked watching the video if you
have any questions then please feel free
to put them in the comments section
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
you